WERE TADO.
JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOG [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HERE ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN.
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY KASKI
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
MADAM SECRETARY NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM GOOD
MORNING AND HAPPY THURSDAY TO
ALL.
THIS IS OUR FINAL FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING FORGET THAT
LEAVES US SCHEDULE SO FAR.
AND BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES DURING WHICH WE
WILL FOCUS IN MORE DETAIL ON ALL
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT.
AS I KNOW ALL OF MY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS DO AS WELL.
IN RECENT YEARS THE STATE IS
TAKING ACTION TO ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
COMPREHENSIVE HOUSING RELATED
BILLS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN INCLUDING
THE CREATION OF A DEDICATED
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING VIA SB.
TO THIS COMMITTEE ALSO PASSED A
MAJOR HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PACKAGE LAST YEAR INCLUDING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
DIRECT AID FOR HOMELESSNESS TO
LOCAL ENTITIES.
CLEARLY MORE REMAINS TO BE DONE
THIS HEARING WILL GIVE US A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AT A HIGH LEVEL
INCLUDING THE OVERALL STRATEGY.
THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE CHOSEN
STRATEGY AND HOW THE PROPOSAL'S
COMPLEMENT PROGRAM TO PROPOSAL'S
ALREADY APPROVED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO GET
INPUT FROM BOTH STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS AS WE BEGAN OUR
DELIBERATIONS.
WE WILL START THE HEARING WITH
THE PRESENTATION FROM THE ALEJO
DESCRIBING THE CONTEXT IN WHICH
WE WERE HAVING THE CONVERSATION
AFTER WHICH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL PRESENT AND WE'LL
DISCUSS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
HOUSING THE HOMELESS PROPOSALS.
NEXT REPRESENTATIVES FROM A CD
AND CAL HFA AND THE HOMELESS
COORDINATED IN FINANCING COUNCIL
BE ON HAND TO GIVE US AN UPDATE
ON RECENTLY ENACTED PROGRAMS IN
THEIR PLANTS IMPLEMENT NEW
PROGRAMS.
IN BOTH THE CURRENT AND BUDGET
YEAR.
LASTLY WILL DISCUSS THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS AND THE STATE'S
ROLE IN ADDRESSING BELL WILL BE
I'M PLEASE IT WILL BE JOINED BY
STOCKTON MAYOR MICHAEL TUBBS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HIS COMMENTS
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM COUNTY
HALMOS OFFICIALS AS WELL AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
WHO DO THE HARD WORK OF ACTUALLY
BUILDING THE NECESSARY HOUSING.
AFTER WE CONCLUDE ALL OF THE
PANEL PRESENTATIONS WE WILL OPEN
THE MIKE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WILL BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING WITH
LORD AS MORALIS PRINCIPLE FISCAL
AND POLICY ANALYST AT THE LA ELS
OFFICE.
MR THIS ONE OFTEN CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
SENATORS --
I AM NEW TO THIS MODEL IS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AT THE REQUEST OF YOUR STAFF
THIS MORNING WE WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT ONE PUTS THE STATE'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES IN CONTEXT.
BUT ALSO SUMMARIZES SOME OF THE
RECENT MAJOR ACTION IN THIS
SPACE AND THIRD IDENTIFIES SOME
POSSIBLE RESPONSES THAT ARE
BEING CONSIDERED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS.
I WILL BE REFERRING TO THIS HAND
OUT DURING THE COURSE OF MY
COMMENTS.
AND SO IF YOU WILL TURN TO PAGE
ONE I WILL BE BECAUSE I WILL
BEGIN BY DISCUSSING PERCENT
ATTENTION DRIVERS TO THE STATE
HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
SO WHILE MANY FACTORS HAVE A
ROLE IN CONTRIBUTING TO THE
STATE'S HIGH HOUSING COSTS THE
MOST IMPORTANT IS THE
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF HOUSING
PARTICULARLY IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES.
TODAY AN AVERAGE HOME IN THE
STATE COST ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE
TIME AND RENTS ARE ABOUT 50%
HIGHER THAN THE REST OF THE
NATION.
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS BUILT
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND HOMES EACH YEAR --
WHICH AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE
FIGURE ON PAGE ONE SIGNIFICANTLY
LAGS NATIONAL TRENDS IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES.
SO ALTHOUGH THE EXACT NUMBER OF
HOUSING UNITS THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BUILD A TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES
ON CERTAIN.
THE GENERAL MAGNITUDE IS
ENORMOUS IF YOU TURN TO THE
SECOND PAGE OF THE HANDOUT WE
OUTLINED SOME OF OUR PRIOR
RESEARCH THAT SUGGESTS THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BUILD ABOUT
TWICE AS MUCH HOUSING AS IT
CURRENTLY DOES EACH YEAR. TO
MEET DEMAND TO THAT MEANS IN
ORDER TO SORT OF CATCH UP WITH
THE SHORTFALLS IN PRIOR YEARS
THE STATE NEEDS OVER THREE
MILLION HOUSING UNITS.
AND LASTLY ON THIS PAGE WE
DISCUSS THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WHICH AS YOU CAN SEE
HISTORICALLY HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR
JUST A VERY SMALL PORTION OF ALL
AND YOU HOUSING BUILT IN THE
STATE ANNUALLY.
IN THE NEXT SECTION OF THE
HANDOUT BEGINNING ON PAGE THREE
WE DISCUSS AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES MANY HOUSEHOLDS IN
THE STATE FAITH.
THE FIGURE HERE DEMONSTRATES
THAT CALIFORNIANS SPEND MORE ON
HOUSING THAN IN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION.
AND IN PARTICULAR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE THOSE THAT ARE
MOST COST BURDENED.
THE HIGH HOUSING COSTS IN THE
STATE DOES CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE'S POVERTY RATE SO WELL THE
STATE'S OFFICIAL POVERTY RATE IS
NEAR THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
THE STATE SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
RATE IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
ACTUALLY THE HIGHEST ON THE
NATION ON THAT METRIC BECAUSE IT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE STATE'S HOUSING
COSTS.
SO UNSURPRISINGLY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE THE MOST LIKELY
TO BE COST BIRD AND THIS MEANS
THAT THEY SPEND MORE THAN 30% OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING.
AND THEREFORE MAY FACE
CHALLENGES AFFORDING OTHER
NECESSITIES SUCH AS FOOD AND
MEDICAL CARE.
IN PARTICULAR AROUND TWO TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE COST BURDEN.
AND OVER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS FACE MORE DIRE COST
PRESSURES THEY SPEND OVER 50% OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR WE
ALSO DISCUSSED HOW OLD.
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES ARE
AFFECTING MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
SO ABOUT ONE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE STATE AT OR ABOVE THE
MEDIAN INCOME ALSO FACED COST
BURDENS AGAIN SPENDING MORE THAN
30% OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING.
IF YOU'LL TURN TO PAGE FIVE OF
THE HANDOUT WE DISCUSS HOW THE
NEED FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
ASSISTANCE OUTSTRIPS RESOURCES.
IN RECENT DECADES FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS
HAVE REALLY FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES BY SUBSIDIZING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND THEN REDUCING THE COST OF
HOUSING FOR SOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR
EXAMPLE THROUGH THE USE OF
HOUSING VOUCHERS.
THERE ABOUT THREE POINT ONE
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE THAT
RENT HOUSING.
AND ABOUT TWO POINT THREE
MILLION THAT ARE VERY LOW INCOME
CITIES ARE HOUSEHOLDS EARN 50%
OR LESS OF THE MEDIAN INCOME IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND JUST THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT WERE INVESTED IN THESE
PROGRAMS AREN'T ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT THIS ENTIRE POPULATION.
AROUND ONE QUARTER OF THE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE.
ARE BENEFITING FROM SUBSIDIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT THIS POINT
THAT'S ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE --
AND SO BECAUSE THE PROGRAM THAT
AIM TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HISTORICALLY KIND OF JUST FOR
SUCH A SMALL SHARE.
THESE PROGRAMS ALONE HAVE NOT
BEEN ENOUGH TO ADDRESS THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE STATE'S --
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES.
SO HAVE YOU PROVIDED SOME
CONTEXT ON THE STATE'S HOUSING
CHALLENGES ON PAGE. SIX OF THE
HAND OUT WE TURN TO ADDRESS SEEN
HOMELESSNESS.
THE STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES ARE LINKED TO THE
STATE'S AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES
RISING HOUSING COSTS.
THAT HAVE EXCEEDED THE WEIGHT
OVER THE RISE OF WAGES
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES PUTS CALIFORNIANS AT
RISK OF HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS.
THOSE WHO PAY AT LEAST HALF OF
THEIR INCOME TOWARDS HOUSING ARE
AT GREATEST RISK AND SO FOR
THESE ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
JOB LOSS OR UNEXPECTED EXPENSE
COULD PUSH THEM INTO
HOMELESSNESS.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
STATE THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION.
AS OF JANUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
LIVE IN THE STATE IS ABOUT 25%
OF THE TOTAL.
POPULATION OF HOMELESSNESS
AROUND THE COUNTRY'S
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IS JUST
ABOUT 12% OF THE NATION WE CAN
WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THE LAST TWO BULLETS ON PAGE SIX
PROVIDE SOME CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND HERE I'LL JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE STATE ALSO HAS THE
HIGHEST SHARE OF AN SHELTERED
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
AND SHELTERING ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WE ESTIMATE WOULD
COST ABOUT TWO TO THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO NOT ONLY PROVIDE A CONTEXT
FOR BOTH THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES WOULD
PROVIDE A SUMMARY ON PAGE SEVEN
OF RECENT MAJOR ACTION IN THE
STATE.
SO BOTH ACTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO BY VOTERS
REFLECTS THIS RECOGNITION STATE
HAS A MAJOR PROBLEM ON ITS HANDS.
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE TURN-NOTED IN HER OPENING COMMENTS
ADOPTED A PACKAGE OF BILLS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT TACKLE
SOME OF THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES IN THE STATE THE
PACKAGE INCLUDED.
YOU FUNDING SOURCES FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUT ALSO CHANGES INTENDED TO
STREAMLINE LOCAL APPROVALS FOR
NEW HOUSING AND THAT ENCOURAGED
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO PLAN FOR
AN APPROVED MORE HOUSING.
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALSO MADE STRIDES IN THESE
EFFORTS BY REVAMPING LOCAL
PROCESSES THAT REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS USED TO ALLOCATE
STATE HOUSING TARGETS BUT THEN
ALSO TE METHODOLOGY THE STATE
USES TO DEVELOP THOSE TARGETS.
AND TO THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS FOR HOMELESSNESS IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES CARE FOR SHORT
TERM SOLUTIONS ESSENTIALLY FOR
HOMELESS POPULATIONS.
AND SO ON PAGE EIGHT WE TURN TO
SORT OF ACTIONS BY THE VOTERS.
WHICH AUTHORIZED TO BONDS AS
PART OF THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ELECTION THE FIRST WITH
A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BOND THAT
SUPPORTS LOW INCOME MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING.
VETERANS ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS
AND THEN A TWO MILLION DOLLAR
BOND THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
THAT SUPPORTS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR THOSE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS THAT EITHER
ARE HOMELESS OR AT OR ARE AT
RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND SO ON THE FINAL PAGE OF YOUR
HAND OUT --
WE DISCUSSED SORT OF THE
ENORMITY OF THE CHALLENGE BEFORE
POLICYMAKERS AND THAT ADDRESSING
THIS CHALLENGE WILL LIKELY NEED
YOU WILL NEED TO BE APPROACHED
BY A NUMBER OF ANGLES AND SO WE
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF THINGS
ARE BEING DISCUSSED TO
UNDERSTAND BY.
THE LEGISLATURE AND BY
STAKEHOLDERS.
ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THIS LIST
INVOLVE TRADE OFFS AND ADDRESS
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THE
CHALLENGES THE STATE FACES.
AND THE LEGISLATURE OR WELL IT
COULD PURSUE A VARIETY OF OF
APPROACHES WILL HAVE TO SERVE
AWAY THESE TRADES TRADE OFF AS
IT CONSIDERS ITS NEXT STEPS --
AND WITH THAT OF THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
HOLD QUESTIONS ON TO THE END OF
A AND SO WE CAN HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FOR TED BE HERE ALL BRIEFLY
OUTLINE FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ON HOUSING AND THEN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ON
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE ARE THREE PRINCIPLES --
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION --
WERE THINKING I'VE AS WE ALL PUT
TOGETHER HIS PROPOSALS ON
HOUSING.
THE FIRST IS THAT HOUSING HAS
HISTORIC STILL FUNDAMENTALLY
REMAINS A LOCAL FOR SPOTS
ABILITY ITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
DRIVE THE PERMITTING PROCESS
SEES AND THE ZONING PROCESS SEES
AND GENERALLY TAKE THE LEAD.
IN DEVELOPING PLANS FOR HOUSING
FOR THEIR RESIDENTS.
THE SECOND PRINCIPLE AS MISS
FOUR HOURS MENTIONED IS THAT
HOUSING HAS REACHED CRISIS
LEVELS OF STATEWIDE IN TERMS OF
LACK OF ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY.
WE HAVE A MEDIAN HOME PRICE
THAT'S MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WE HAVE GROWTH
AND RUNS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES THAT FAR OUTSTRIPPED
GROWTH IN INCOMES.
AND WE ARE MILLIONS OF UNITS
SHORT OF JUST WHAT WE NEED TO
BUILD JUST TO KEEP UP WITH
INCREASES IN POPULATION OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
UNTIL THE THIRD PROMISE FLOWS
FROM THE FIRST TWO WHICH IS THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE A ROLE
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS.
BUT THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND EMPOWER THEM TO STEP UP TO
THAT WE ALL WORK TOGETHER
JUMPSTART LOCAL LEADERSHIP TO
MEET THESE GOALS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THIS NOT JUST IN THIS BUDGET AND
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WE HAVE
INCLUDES A LOT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY BUT THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A LONG TERM
PROPOSITION THIS PROBLEM IS NOT
CAN BE SOLVED IN ONE YEAR OR TWO
YEARS.
OR EVEN OVER THE LIFE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION BUT WE WANT TO
START RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE VERY
COGNIZANT AS MADAM CHAIR
MENTIONED THAT THESE PROPOSALS
BUILD ON PROPOSALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED OVER THE
LAST.
SEVERAL YEARS.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ON HOUSING
I THINK THE EASIEST WAY TO THINK
ABOUT IT IS TO BREAK IT INTO TWO
BUCKETS A SHORT TERM BUCKET.
AND THEN A LONG TERM BUCKET.
IN THE SHORT TERM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
SPENDING TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE CURRENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
OF THAT ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS FOR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL PLANNING AND PRODUCTION
GRANTS THAT INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH STAFFING
AND PERSONNEL WOULD PROCESSES
FOR ZONING AND PERMITTING TO
GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES TO
ACTUALLY MEET THE GOALS THAT WE
ARE SENDING OUT FOR THEM AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO SET OUT FOR
THEM.
IN THE FUTURE.
AND THEN AS THOSE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS MEET
MILESTONES WILL HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCENTIVE PAYMENTS TO
THESE GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY CAN
USE FOR ANY GENERAL PURPOSE AND
I KNOW MANY OF YOU HAVE SERVED
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO RAISE
REVENUE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
SO WE THINK THIS WILL BE A GOOD
INCENTIVE AGAIN IN THE SHORT
TERM. TO HELP THESE GOVERNMENTS
MEET THESE GOALS.
THE SECOND BUCKET OF MONEY WE
HAD IS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY.
AD THIS IS TO EXPAND THEIR
MIXED INCOME WELL [inaudible]
HISTORICALLY CALIFORNIA'S
ASSISTANCE ON HOUSING HAS BEEN
DIRECTED TOWARD LOWER INCOME
POPULATIONS THAT NEEDS TO BE THE
CASE THAT IS THE CASE IT REMAINS
THE CASE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ACROSS OTHER INCOME LEVELS
THAT MAY NOT BE GETTING AS MUCH
SUPPORT AS THEY NEED BUT ARE
ALSO EXPERIENCING CRISIS IN
AFFORDING HOUSING.
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROPOSALS TO HELP THEM AS WELL.
AND THEN THE LAST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS TO EXPAND OUR
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS AND
THIS INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM THAT EXISTS.
WITHIN THAT PROGRAM THERE'S A 9%
PROGRAM AND A 4% PROGRAM AND THE
4% PROGRAM WHICH IS LESS
GENEROUS IS HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDER SUBSCRIBE TO SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PROVIDE MORE
SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAMS.
SO THAT WE BUILD MORE UNITS
THROUGH THAT VEHICLE AND THEN IN
ADDITION WE HAVE ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO DEDICATE --
FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE WITHIN
6280% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME
TO MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT WE GO
ACROSS A NUMBER OF INCOME LEVELS.
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO HOUSING WHILE
CONTINUING TO PRIORITIZE THE
LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES.
AND THEN THE LAST TWO POINTS SO
MAKE ON THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING
PROPOSAL FOR THE SHORT TERM IS
THAT WE ARE UNDERGOING A PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
IDENTIFYING ALL ACCESS STATE
PROPERTY.
THESE ARE PROPERTIES TO THE
STATE ALREADY OWNS AND THAT
COULD BE USED FOR A VARIETY OF
MECHANISMS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO THAT GOVERNOR HAS ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CREATE THAT LIST AND
ONCE WE DO ONCE WE IDENTIFY THE
MOST PROMISING CANDIDATES WE
WILL FIND WAYS TO OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS AND YEARS.
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF TURNING
SOME THOSE PARCELS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY SUITABLE INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
AND THEN THE LAST POINT I'LL
MAKE ON THE SHORT TERM IS. FOR
E. I. F. THESE THESE ARE
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES COULD BE
A POSITIVE VEHICLE TO JUMPSTART
THE KIND OF REGIONAL
COLLABORATION THAT WE THINK IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT.
AND SOLVING THIS PROBLEM AND WE
ARE PROPOSING PAIRING THAT
PROPOSAL WITH THE GOVERNOR'S TAX
CONFIRM THE PROPOSAL TO CONFORM
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
OPPORTUNITY SOUNDS.
SO WE THINK THAT WHEN WE JUMP
START THE CREATION OF THE CIF
THESE BY MAKING THEM EASIER TO
FORM AND WE COMBINED WITH
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS THAT PROMOTE
INVESTMENT.
IN THESE TYPES OF AREAS THAT CAN
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN MOVING
THE NEEDLE ON THE HOUSING FRONT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LONG TERM
NOT JUST IN THIS COMING YEAR BUT
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS WE
RECOGNIZE CONSISTENT WITH
STATUTES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED IN MOST RECENT
SESSION?
THAT THE RENO GOALS TO REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT NEEDS
OF REVAMPING AND THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
ARE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THE SCHOOLS MAKES SENSE GIVEN
EACH JURISDICTION AND THEN
EVENTUALLY ONCE WE COLLABORATE
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN TERMS
OF COMING UP WITH THOSE GOALS.
BEGIN TO ENFORCE THOSE
REQUIREMENTS BUT I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT THIS LONG TERM
PROCESS IS SEPARATE FROM THE
SHORT TERM FINDING THAT WE ARE
GIVEN TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
HELP THEM COME UP WITH THESE
GOALS.
AND ALSO THE LYNC TWO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WHICH I
KNOW HAS GOTTEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION --
FROM VARIOUS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE GOALS ARE HARD BUT IT
SHE VERBAL --
THEY'RE CONSISTENT WITH THAT
LEGISLATION THAT ALL TO YOU
ENACTED LAST YEAR AND WILL BE
TAKING PLACE IN THE COMING YEARS
AFTER A CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF
YOU SO THERE WILL BE A LEAD TIME.
THERE WILL BE A LINK TO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THE
GOVERNORHAS MADE THAT VERY
CLEAR BUT ISN'T IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE END OF A
PROCESS.
THAT WILL BE VERY DELIBERATE AND
COLLABORATIVE US AS WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS ON
HOMELESSNESS --
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
BEFORE HE WAS GOVERNOR AND
BEFORE HE WAS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR --
WAS MAYOR THE HEAD OF THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY AND IN ONE OF HIS
EFFORTS ON HOMELESSNESS HE
ANNOUNCED IN A STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS LAST WEEK THAT
HE'S ANNOUNCING ANOTHER MAYOR.
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO LEAD HIS
COMMISSION ON HOMELESSNESS AND
IN PARTICULAR MAKING SURE THAT
WE NOT ONLY GET PEOPLE SHELTERED
BUT WE PROVIDE THEM THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED TO HOPEFULLY.
MOVE OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
SO ARE KEY PROPOSAL HERE FROM A
BUDGETARY PERSPECTIVE.
AS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
I KNOW MISS MORE ALL TO MENTION
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PART OF THE BUDGET.
THAT ALL OF YOU ENACTED LAST
YEAR THIS BUILDS ON THAT OF THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BIG
THIRTEEN THE THIRTEEN BIGGEST
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
GOING FROM LOS ANGELES WITH
SEVERAL MILLION PEOPLE ALL THE
WAY TO STOCKTON CALIFORNIA WITH
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND I KNOW MAYOR TOPS WILL BE
HERE WITH US --
IN JUST A LITTLE BANGED UP TO
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS JUST
FOR THOSE BIG THIRTEEN CITIES
ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR JURISDICTIONS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THESE WILL BE FUNDED THROUGH
THESE CONTINUUM'S OF CARE WHICH
ARE THESE AREAS DESIGNATED BY
THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT MONEY GETS TO
WHERE IT NEEDS AND THERE IS A
REGIONAL PROCESS FOR ALLOCATING
AND COLLABORATING ON USING THAT
MONEY.
AND THEN FINALLY AS WITH THE
HOUSING PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS AS A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HIT THESE
MILESTONES WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF SHELTERS.
AND GETTING WHAT WE CALL POWS
POSITIVE HOUSING ACTS AS HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING WE
ALSO HAVE A PROPOSAL. TO AT THIS
STREAMLINED AND EXPEDITE SEQUEL
REVIEW FOR IN THESE HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION CENTERS
AND MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER --
PRIVILEGES WE GET TO SPORTS
STADIUMS AS WE HAD DONE FOR
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION WE ALSO
GIVE THAT TO HOMELESS SHELTERS
AND NAVIGATIONS.
CENTERS IN ADDITION TO THAT FOR
CALTRANS --
WITH WHAT'S KNOWN AS AIR SPACE
WHICH IS FOR CALTRANS RIGHT OF
WAY WHERE THERE MAY BE ROOM TO
BUILD EMERGENCY SHELTERS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE USE THAT
BECAUSE THAT IS EXISTING.
GOVERNMENT STATE GOVERNMENT
PROPERTY WHERE THAT SUCH USE IS
SUITABLE AND FINALLY TO OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT I'LL MENTION THE
FIRST IS OUR HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM WHICH I KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FUNDED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
FUNDING IS ON GOING AND THAT'S
TO MAKE SURE GOING BACK TO THE
POINT ABOUT WRAPAROUND SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OFTEN ELIGIBLE
FOR SSI BUT I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
APPLIED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN APPLY AND THEY
HAVE.
ALL THE RESOUCES TO DO SO AND
THAT WOULD DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
MONEY YOU KNOW NOT JUST STATE
MONEY.
AND THEN THE LAST POINT I
MENTIONED ARE THESE HOLD PERSON
CARE PILOTS ARE BUDGET INCLUDES
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND THESE PILOTS THAT HELP
PEOPLE WITH THESE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES.
AND THAT COMES ON TOP OF OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS IN FUNDING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THESE PILOTS
BUT WE THINK THAT THIS CAN MAKE.
A BIG DIFFERENCE SO IN SUMMARY
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF THESE ARE
JUST YOUR ONE ONE TIME SPENDING
PROPOSALS WE KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CANNOT BE SOLVED
IN A YEAR.
BUT WE WANTED TO LAY DOWN A
MARKER WITH THIS BUDGET AS THE
GOVERNOR IS OPENING PROPOSAL AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF
YOU AND THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN COME UP WITH A STRATEGY THAT
MAKES SENSE.
BUT FOR THE SHORT AND LONG TERM
SO THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
SLIDE.
AS THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT REALLY ARE DESIRE AND
EXPECTATION OF THE LA --
REALLY HELP US IN IDENTIFYING
AREAS IN WHICH WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON AND PAYING ATTENTION.
IN A VARIETY POLICY AREAS REALLY
TO COME. TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS
FOR APPRECIATE THAT LIST AND SO
I'M CURIOUS --
AS TO WHETHER YOU HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON WHERE THE
STATE COULD TAKE ACTION SOME OF
THE LOWER HANGING FRUITS.
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN PASS BUDGET ACTIONS TO
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IN THE HOUSING MARKET ON WHAT
ARE DO YOU THINK SOME OF THE
APPROPRIATE.
LEVERS IF YOU WILL WE SHOULD BE
PULLING TO TRY TO EXPEDITE.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO THE ITEMS THAT APPEAR ON THAT
FINALIST OF THE HOUSE OF THE
HAND OUT DON'T NECESSARILY
REFLECT SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
OF OUR OFFICE BETTER REALLY
IDENTIFYING THE CONVERSATION
THEM TAKING PLACE --
AND EVEN THOUGH I THINK SOME OF
THE OPTIONS ARE IDENTIFIED THERE
THAT WOULD PROBABLY HAVE THE
BIGGEST THE ACT IN THE SPACE
ARE ALSO THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL.
UNTIL REQUIRED DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE DETAILS
WILL VERY MUCH MATTER --
BUT THINGS LIKE REFORMING LOCAL
ZONING LAWS ALTERING ALLOCATION
OF LOCAL LOCAL TAXES TO
INCENTIVIZE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT --
AND STREAMLINING SEEK A COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE MAJOR IMPACTS
BUT IT'LL BE ABOUT THINKING
ABOUT THE PARTICULARS.
UNDERSTANDABLE THIRTY NIELSEN.
AS YOU PREPARED THIS.
FINANCE.
HAVE YOU HAD ANY DATA OR
RESEARCH THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
YOU AS TO WHY WE HAVE NOT BEEN
MORE SUCCESSFUL IN WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN DONE.
IT DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN THIS IS.
EVOLVE OVER DECADES.
HAVE YOU TRIED TO FOCUS ON SOME
OF THOSE THINGS IN THE
CONCENTRATION.
OF THE PROBLEM AND WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE.
A LOT OF COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
A SOME OF THEM HAVE COME IN AN
AXE THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY TO
EXEMPT THEM.
FROM MEETING THEIR GOALS.
WHICH I THINK IT'S RATHER
AMAZING.
THAT THESE MORE WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WOULD WANT TO HAVE
AN EXEMPTION WHEN.
A LITTLE TOWN IKE WHITMAN DISH
CONDEMN.
OR I GUESS IT WAS --
HUNTINGTON BEACH TO MAYBE THEY
DESERVE THAT BUT SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT CERTAINLY
SHOULD HAVE GREATER WEALTH AND
RESOURCES.
HAVE NOT STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE.
END ARE NOT EVEN BE IN THE
CHIDED FOR IT.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON TO THE
YEARS THAT HAS OF GIVEN THE COST
UP.
BUT NOT GIVEN INCENTIVE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING TO
PROVIDE.
AN TO RELIEVE.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE WHAT HAVE
BEEN THE FAILURES THUS FAR NOT
JUST TO NEW IDEAS AHEAD BUT THE
FAILURES.
SO ALL MAKE A COUPLE POINTS AND
THAT A COLLEAGUE OF MINE MIGHT
HAVE A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
ON SOME OF THE SPECIFIC DATA
THAT YOU REFERENCED.
BUT THE FIRST IS ONE THING THAT
WE NOTICED AND LOOKING AT
PREVIOUS PACKAGES --
AND THE LA --
COMMENTED ON THIS AND THEIR
REPORT THERE TENDED TO BE A ONE
OFF QUALITY TO THESE THINGS YOU
KNOW LET'S PUT IN THIS MUCH
MONEY HERE OR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THERE.
AND OUR BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES A
LOT OF ONE WE HOPE TO EMPHASIZE
FOR THIS BUDGET IS.
THIS IS NOT A ONE TIME PROCESS
THIS IS NOT A ONE TIME LEVEL OF
THINKING SO WE REALLY WANTED TO
FOLD THIS INTO NOT ONLY A
REGIONAL STRATEGY BUT THE
STRATEGY OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS
BECAUSE YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT
THAT YOU KNOW FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS HERE A HUNDRED MILLION.
DOLLARS THERE IS NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM SO I THINK
THAT'S THE FIRST THING THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THIS TAKES A BROADER
COMMITMENT AND JUST.
THROWING MONEY AT IT ESPECIALLY
IN A GIVEN YEAR --
I THINK THE SECOND THING IS THAT.
THIS IS AN ISSUE AND YOU'RE
CERTAINLY DIFFERENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE DIFFERENT AND
EACH HAS ITS OWN PRIORITIES BUT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
BUILDING OVER TIME AND SO IN THE
ABSENCE OF STATE ACTION WE
RECOGNIZE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THERE'S OFTEN.
A FORCE FOR THE STATE TO KEEP
THINGS THE WAY THEY ARE AND WHEN
THE POPULATION IS GROWING THE
WAY IT HAS IN CALIFORNIA WITH.
A LOT OF THAT POPULATION GROWTH
COMING IN THE COASTS IN
PARTICULAR WERE CASA CON OUT
THAT'S NOT REALLY TENABLE
SOLUTION RIGHT AND WE THINK OF
CALIFORNIA IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY HAD ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
NINETEEN NINETY IT HAD ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE AND NOW
WE'RE JUST ABOUT AT FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE AND SO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM
THAT YOU HAVE HAPPENS IN A MONTH
OR A YEAR BUT SLOWLY OVER THOSE
YEARS OVER THE LAST IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AT THIRTY FORTY YEARS.
IF YOU'RE NOT KEEPING UP EACH
YEAR AND IF YOU'RE TEN OVER TIME
THAT'S HOW YOU WIND UP MILLIONS
OF HOUSING UNITS SHORT HAVE
WHERE YOU NEED TO BE.
A AND THEN I THINK THE LAST
POINT THAT ALL NAY CASE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND CERTAINLY THE
LAWSUIT WITH HUNTINGTON BEACH
GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION OVER THE
LAST MONTH?
AND YET THERE WERE REASONS THAT
SPECIFIC LAWSUITS WERE FILED IN
IN TERMS OF THE HISTORY OFTHAT
PROCEEDING.
AS WELL AS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS BUT I THINK THE
GOVERNOR WOULD BE THE FIRST TO
SAY THAT WE DO HAVE TO ENFORCE
OUR HOUSING GOALS AND THE LAW
BUT YOU KNOW IN MY PRESENTATION
TODAY DID NOT MENTION LAWSUITS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY
LAWSUITS ARE NOT THE WAY THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO GET OUT OF THIS MESS.
THE REASON --
HE TOOK ACTION THERE IN CONCERT
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT THERE'S PLANNING.
THEN THERE'S ENTITLEMENT AND
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS IS TO
ACTUALLY GET UNITS READY AND
THEN THERE'S ACTUALLY PRODUCING
THE HOUSING AND WE KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK.
AND I TALKED ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT WITH RENO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PROCESS FOR HOW WE ASSIGN
GOALS AND HOW WE MAKE SURE
JURISDICTIONS MEAT AND IS REALLY
UP TO SNUFF.
BUT I THINK WHICH ARE SECTIONS
THAT AREN'T REALLY EVEN STEPPING
UP TO THE PLATE IN TERMS OF
THEIR PLANNING --
AND MEETING THAT REQUIREMENT OR
EVEN WORK THAT'S AND CAN LAW AND
DOUBLE OUR HOUSING PACKAGE IS
MUCH BROADER THAN THAT WILL I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT COMMUNITIES
ARE SAYING GIVE ME EIGHT MORE
YEARS AND DON'T BOTHER ME.
IS ALSO AVOIDING JUST AS MUCH AS
ANY COMMUNITY THAT HAD JUST
HASN'T DONE ANYTHING.
THEY'RE JUST NOT DOING ANYTHING
AND SAYING GIVEN THIS EXEMPTION
IN THE THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
TIGHTEN UP ON THAT A LITTLE BIT.
AND HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE THE
NEED AND HOW RIGHTEOUSLY LOOKING
AT THE NEED FOR LITIGATION
PREVENTION AND INSURANCE AND
SUCH AS INSURANCE MEANING TO
DIMINISH.
THE VULNERABILITY OF COMMUNITIES
FACING LWSUITS TICKLE REFORM
BEING PART OF THAT HOW SERIOUS.
IS THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
[inaudible]
SICK REFORM.
YES SIR TWO POINTS ON THAT FIRST
IN TERMS OF HELPING COMMUNITIES
MORE BROADWAY THAT'S PART OF WHY
WE WANTED THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE PUT OUT --
IT'S YOU KNOW CAN GO TOWARD
ULTIMATELY HOUSING PRODUCTION
BUT IT'S REALLY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND STAFFING FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE
WANT JURISDICTIONS TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW'S SO WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE THAT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE.
BOTH IN THIS BUDGET YEAR AND FOR
FUTURE YEARS FOR SEQUEL REFORM
THAT SOMETHING THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS MENTIONED AND I MENTIONED IN
THE HOMELESSNESS CONTACTS HE'S
ALSO MENTIONED IN THE HOUSING
CONTACTS BUT THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE TAKING
A LOOK AT BUT WE KNOW.
WE HAVE MORE TO DO AND BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER ON THAT --
I'LL HAVE SOME MORE BUT THAT'S
ENOUGH FOR ME THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT CENTERS SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM BUDGET CHAIRMAN
A PRESHEAF HIS HEARING. FOR THE
START OF A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
ALEJO.
ON THE DIFFERENT FINANCE SO YOU
DESCRIBED ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BE IN NEW SPENDING.
AND YOU REFER TO THOSE THE SHORT
TERM.
BUT YOU ALL THINGS THAT OF
COURSE ARE.
TOTAL MORE THAN ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BE SO I WANTED TO JUST
UNDERSTAND.
WHICH OF THE THINGS WERE THE NEW
pSPENDING I UNDERSTAND THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL PLANNING
GRANTS IS THAT.
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS IS PART OF
THAT ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE WHAT'S
THE NEXT PORTION.
SO IT SAYS THAT SEVEN HER FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE LOCAL GRANTS
RIGHT PLUS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MIXED INCOME LOANS
RIGHT AND THEN WE'VE GOT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN AN
EXPANSION OF STATE TAX CREDITS.
SO YEARS SO THE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION NEW IS THOSE THREE
THINGS YES OKAY.
AND THEN THE OTHER AMOUNTS.
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
HOUSING AGENCY THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR FAMILIES WITHIN 68%
AREA MEDIAN.
AND A COUPLE OF OTHERS THOSE ARE.
IN.
PART OF BUDGET ALLOCATIONS MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE'D HAVE TO RENEW
THEM BUT THEIR ON GOING
APPROPRIATION.
SO THESE ARE ALL ONE TIME
APPROPRIATE SO THERE WAS A ONE
TIME DOWN THERE AND THOSE
ELEMENTS AND SO MONEY SO THERE'S
THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THAT PLANNING AND PRODUCTION AND
THAT WITHIN THAT INCLUDES. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS OF THAT GETS
YOU.
TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY ARE YES
SAID THOSE YES SOME THESE ARE
ELEMENTS OF OTHER THING RIGHT SO
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION WAS ENCAPSULATED
IN THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CORRECT YEAH OKAY.
SO BUT THE HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS.
IS THAT PART OF THE ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION NEW SPENDING SO IT
IS BUT ACTUALLY WHEN THAT HITS
THE BUDGET THE WAY THOSE TAX
CREDITS ARE STRUCTURED IS THAT
IT'S ONLY AFTER THE PROJECT IS
COMPLETED --
BECAUSE THE TAX CREDITS ARE
AWARDED FOR CALLING THE TAX
BENEFITS OF THAT TAKES PLACE
OVER SEVERAL YEARS FROM --
SO THAT A GO HEAD YES IT'S OKAY
YEAH GO AHEAD OF SAID THAT LAST
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ACTUALLY WHEN I WAS --
REFERRING TO THAT --
ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE CLEAR THAT
INCLUDES BOTH OUR HOUSING AND
ARE HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE --
SO THAT'S HOW YOU GET TO ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION.
AND THEN THAT LAST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TAX CREDITS --
THAT WILL BE OUT IN THE OUT
YEARS AND NOT THIS YEAR I SHOULD
MAKE ONE POINT ABOUT THAT THAT
WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IN --
AND IT IT MAY BE THERE AND I
DIDN'T CATCH IT BUT I DID TRY TO
LOOK IN DETAIL ON THAT.
IS JUST ONE OF ONE PAGE THAT
KINDS OF BREAKS THAT DOWN SO
THAT.
WHEN WE HEAR IT VERBALLY WE
DON'T --
ASSUME THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION NCENTIVE IS
SEPARATE FROM THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY SO WE JUST KIND OF SEE
THAT BREAK DOWN THAT BE ACTUALLY
DELIVERY AND I SHOULD MAKE ONE
LAST POINT TO YOUR POINT THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX CREDITS. FOR HER THOUGH IT
DOESN'T HIT THE BUDGET RIGHT
AWAY THAT IS DESIGNED AS AN
ONGOING PROGRAM.
SO MY SECOND QUESTION WAS THAN
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT
YOU DESCRIBED ON HOMELESSNESS
AND YOU DID BREAK THAT DOWN SO I
KNOW THAT THE HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED AND THE TWO HUNDRED ARE
ALL PART OF THAT.
FIVE BUT THAT [inaudible]
FIVE IS.
SUBSUMED IN THIS ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION FOR ITS FROM A IT'S
A DIFFERENT ALLOCATION IS IN THE
WHAT FOR IN THE ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE THAT'S BEING IT IS.
ON THE RIGHT POSE A VERY GREAT
SO THAT IT JUST A BREAK DOWN
WITH YOU HELD A WILL MAKE SURE I
GET THAT TF IS HEARING IT
VERBALLY I GOT A LITTLE CONFUSED.
OKAY SO THEN --
FOR THE LA JOH --
FOR ASK THE QUESTION I NOTE THAT.
IN YOUR MATERIALS YOU GAVE US
YOU SHOW THAT --
AS BEST AS WE CAN TELL AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT
OF DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER WE ARE
ABLE TO ACCURATELY COUNT.
BECAUSE THERE'S A GOOD PORTION
OF HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT REALLY
DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN.
THEY REALLY THERE'S A STIGMA
AROUND BEING HOMELESS THEY'RE
NOT THE ONES THAT ARE LIVING IN
A TENT YOU KNOW THEIR COUCH
SURFING OR THEY'RE IN CARS BUT
THAT'S OUR BEST ESTIMATE NOW.
BUT THE OTHER THING I NOTICED
THAT.
YOU THREE THOUSAND SO THAT'S A
SMALL PROPORTION OF THAT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS.
SO WHAT I THINK WE'VE SEEN IN%
DATA RECENTLY IS THAT.
WE THERE'S A LARGE PERCENT OF
OUR HOMELESS FOLKS.
WHO?
OUR HAVE IN.
THEIR NEWLY ON HOUSE.
THEY'RE NOT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
THEY ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE JOBS
THEY ARE YOU KNOW FAMILIES THEY
ARE PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW WERE
HOUSED.
IN WHETHER THAT WAS SIX MONTHS
AGO OR THREE YEARS AGO.
RIGHT IN SO WHAT I ONE THING I
WAS INTERESTED IN IS WHETHER WE
HAVE ANY DATA.
ON THE GROWTH [inaudible]
OF THESE HOMELESS BECAUSE WE
HAVE A PERCEPTION I THINK.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE SEE MOST
VISIBLY THAT HOMELESS ROLE
MENTALLY ILL AND ADDICTED.
WHEN IN FACT WHAT THE WHEN WE
GET INTO THE DIFFERENT --
CITIES OR COUNTIES THAT ARE.
DOING A LOT OF MORE ACCURATE
COUNT SIR SIR YOU KNOW DEALING
WITH THOSE POPULATIONS BETTER
THEY'RE SHOWING US NO.
THESE ARE NEWLY HOMELESS PEOPLE
THESE ARE NOT.
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE THESE ARE
NOT ADDICTED PEOPLE SO DO DO WE
HAVE ANY.
I KNOW IT'S HARD BUT DATA ON
THIS GROWTH OF THE HOMELESS.
A YEAR BY YEAR.
YES I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT --
THERE THERE'S RESEARCH THAT
SUPPORTS THAT BECAUSE OF THAT
THERE'S A A DIRECT LINK BETWEEN
JUST THE THE GENERAL
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES AND
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING MARKETS AND
AN IN --
KIND OF FRICTIONAL NOT
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED ARE KIND OF
ON THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS AND
ONE KIND OF NEGATIVE LIFE EVENT
CAN KIND OF PUSH THEM INTO
HOMELESS DISORGANIZED ILL OR
EXPENSE AND SO.
AND SO THAT IS DEFINITELY ORE
PREVALENT IN CALIFORNIA THAN ANY
OTHER STATES --
THERE IS SOME --
DATA IT YOU KNOW AS WE BROKE OUT
IN YOUR HAND OUT HERE THAT THAT
KIND OF SEPARATES --
CONNICK HOMELESSNESS FROM THE
GENERAL POPULATION IN THAT DID
IT DOES GO BACK SEVERAL YEARS
AND WE DON'T HAVE IT ON HAND BUT
WE COULD CERTAINLY CIRCLE BACK
WITH.
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THAT ONE CAVEAT IS THAT.
I CAN BE SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT TO
COMPARE THESE COUNTS YEAR OVER
YEAR JUST BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED JUST THE DIFFICULTY IN
DOING THE COUNTS EACH YEAR SO
THERE'S JUST SOME.
KIND OF JUST SOME NOISE EACH
YEAR IN THE NUMBERS --
AND ALSO BECAUSE THERE'S KIND OF
CHANGING DEFINITIONS AND
METHODOLOGIES AND THE WAY THAT
THE COUNCIL BEEN DONE OVER YEARS
BUT WITH TIS CABBIE OUT SOME
MIND KIND OF LOOKING AT THE
GENERAL TREND OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS -- YOU
KNOW YOU THINK YOU CAN YOU CAN
GET A SENSE AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU AND SO I
THINK -- YOU
KNOW I'M NOT ABOUT TO RECOMMEND
NECESSARILY A NEW EXPENDITURE IN
THE BUDGET BY THINK.
ADDITIONAL DATA WOULD HELP US
BECAUSE AS WE CONSIDER WHERE WE
PUT.
HOMELESS MONEY FOR EXAMPLE --
UNDERSTANDING THE POPULATION.
CAN REALLY ASSIST US FIGURE OUT
WHERE IT COULD BE MOST EFFECTIVE.
AND SO ANY --
ANY ASSISTANCE IN THAT FROM LA --
WOULD BE HELPFUL EITHER HOW WE
CAN GET BETTER DATA OR HOW QUEEN
VALUE WITH THAT WHICH LEADS ME
TO MY NEXT QUESTION OR
SUGGESTION.
WHICH FOLLOWING THE BUDGETEERS
ON PAGE.
NINE A LIST OF POSSIBLE
RESPONSES IN YOU'VE NOW
CLARIFIED THAT THESE ARE ONES
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED VERSUS
PRETEND.
NECESSARILY THE LA YO'S WEIGHING
IN AS TO WHAT THE LA --
FROM IN FROM A STANDING BACK
PERSPECTIVE MIGHT ADVICE --
US TO PURSUEAS BEING MOST
EFFECTIVE SO I WOULD I WOULD
WELCOME THE ELLIE OWES
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SOME OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS.
THAT WE CAN USE OUR EXPENDITURES
FIRST.
TO RESPOND TO THE CURRENT
HOMELESS POPULATION IN OTHER
WORDS SHRINK IT.
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY HOMELESS.
SECOND TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
HOW DO WE KEEP CURTAIL THIS
GROWTH?
AND THIRD WHAT WOULD BE SOME OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE THINGS TO
INCREASE THE HOUSING SUPPLY.
AND WE KNOW VERY COMMONLY WE WE
HERE -- SEE
FOR REFORM OR HEAR THIS OR WE
HEAR THAT.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT GOOD DATA.
WE COULD DIRECT OUR EFFORTS IN A
WAY THAT YES COULD BRING US SOME
BENEFIT BUT MAYBE NOT.
A A SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT THAT IS
RIGHT OUT THERE WE HAVEN'T WE
JUST HAVEN'T.
UNDERSTOOD YET.
SO I THINK THOSE THINGS WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL.
AND I KNOW THAT IN TERMS OF
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS --
THAT DATA THAT I'VE SEEN AND
WOULD BE NICE TO POTENTIALLY
HAVE COMPILED.
IS THAT.
HISTORICALLY STATES HAVE RELIED
ON FEDERAL FUNDS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING ASSISTANCE WHETHER IT
SECTION EIGHT OR MORE MONIES
MEAN MONIES FOR BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT HUD IS
BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT SOURCE.
BUT OVER THE LAST THIRTY TO
FORTY YEARS ALLOCATION HAS
SHRUNK SO DRAMATICALLY THAT FOR
EXAMPLE.
IN TERMS OF SECTION EIGHT THEIR
SEARCH WHEN WE LOOK AT THE NEED
FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE COMPARED
TO THAT WHICH WE HAVE.
IT'S SO DISPROPORTIONATE AND SO
UNDERSTANDING BETTER.
WHETHER THE STATE EXPANDING ITS
PART OF RENTAL ASSISTANCE HOW
SIGNIFICANT COULD THAT BE IN
TERMS OF HELPING TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL TO US.
AS WE WAIT THESE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOB FOR THE LIST IS TO
EVERYONE KNOWS I'VE GOT SENATORS
MORLOCK BAIL ROSTER RAZA WHITE
HOUSE KEY AND REQUIRE CENTER
MORE LOCK.
MADAM CHAIR I SAID A FEW QUICK
QUESTIONS --
SERVICE WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING WITH SB TO REVENUES
WE PASS THAT LECTURE HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO AN ESCROW.
ASSOCIATION THEIR SAMBOY WERE
COLLECTED A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
WHERE'S IT GOING SO HOW WHAT I
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
YES SO I'M GONNA TURN THAT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE DANIELLE WHO'S
RIGHT BACK THERE WHO SHOULD BE
COMING UP BUT THESE REVENUES AS
YOU KNOW IT WAS.
PASSED BUT THEY'RE JUST
BEGINNING TO COMMENT ACTUALLY
RIGHT NOW SO THAT'S ACTUALLY A
PUZZLE THAT WERE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BRAND WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE ARE JUST CALCULATE JUST
RECEIVED THAT FULL FIRST YEARS
WORTH OF REVENUES WERE STILL
WORKING ON PLANNING TO DO THAT
AND ACTUALLY --
I'M GONNA PASS THAT UP TO EACH
CD YOU WHO IS PLANNED TO SPEAK
AND THEN --
DURING THE GOVERNOR'S SPEECH
LAST WEEK HE USED THE TERM
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
SO I'M I'M LOOKING AT PAGE
SEVENTEEN OF OUR HANDS OUT AND
ANOTHER.
SHEET OF THE NUMBERS AT AND I'M
NOT FINDING NAVIGATION CENTERS
ANYWHERE DIED.
DUE TO WHAT IS HE REFERRING TO
SO THE NAVIGATION CENTERS AND
DANIELLE CAN ELABORATE BUT
THEY'RE BASICALLY SO THERE ARE
HOMELESS SHELTERS THESE ARE
EMERGING EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
AND NAVIGATION CENTERS HAVE A
SHELTER COMPONENT BUT ALSO HAVE
SERVICES IN OTHER WAYS TO HELP
PEOPLE NOT SIMPLY FOR THAT NIGHT
BUT TRANSITION TO THE LONGER
TERM SUPPORT THAT THEY MAY NEED
AND THEN EVENTUALLY.
GET THAT POSITIVE HOUSING EXIT
WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL WANT SO
THAT SPECIFIC CONCEPT IS WITHIN
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
HOMELESSNESS BUCKET.
KATE THANK YOU.
AND THEN --
YOU ALSO HAVE A AT LEAST AT
LEAST SOME OF THREE YEARS I'M
LOOKING AT FOR NO PLACE LIKE
HOME -- ON
THIS SHEET WHICH IS THAT THE
PACKET SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
PROVIDED HERE.
BUT IT HAS TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
MILLION. 417-182-62418 NINETEEN
AND FOUR HUNDRED MILLION FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY AND I'M.
JUST WONDERING.
WHAT THAT IS ABOUT?
AND THE ANSWER TO THAT SO I
THINK WE CAN GET BACK ON THAT --
SO AS YOU KNOW WITH NO PLACE
LIKE HOME IT WAS ORIGINALLY
BRING A BROADWAY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT MONEY AND
THEN THE BOND THAT PASSED LAST
NOVEMBER.
ENABLED THE STATE TO USE UP TO
TWO BILLION DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY
FOR HOUSING SO WE HAVE AS A GOAL
IN OUR BUDGET TO ACCELERATE THE
USE THAT MONEY FOR HOUSING AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE BUT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE NONE OF THAT MONEY HAS.
HAS GONE OUT THE DOOR JUST YET
SO WE HAVEN'T EVEN SO WE ARE WE
GOING THROUGH THE GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
AND YOUR FRIEND IT AGAIN --
YES WE ARE CURRENTLY AYE WE HAVE
I BELIEVE THE NO FAT OUT AND WE
RECEIVE SOME APPLICATIONS --
CAM HDD CAN MAYBE SPEAK TO
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE SPECIFICS
ON THAT BUT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS SUPPORTING THE FIRST
ROUND OF FUNDING.
KAY AND THEN MY LAST QUESTION IS
ON SB TWO ZONES --
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BEEN.
REALLY FRUSTRATED WITH THAT RENO
GOALS -- SO
CONTENT TO LITIGATION I WON'T
TALK ABOUT IT.
NOTE.
I WAS SENATOR OF BERGEN I SURE
HUNTINGTON BEACH SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK ON SOMETHING BUT
EVEN THE READING GOALS.
BABY COULD USE A LITTLE REFINING
BECAUSE HUNTINGTON BEACH HAS RE
NIGGLES OF LIKE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THREE UNITS IN THERE
JUST FOR UNDER CHAI.
BUT THE CITY NEXT DOOR FROM
VALUE ONLY HAS EIGHTY SIX COSTA
MESA.
TO NEWPORT BEACH FIVE SO THERE'S
SOMETHING KIND OF COULD BE I I
THINK BUT WHERE MY FRUSTRATION
HAS BEEN AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
IS WE'VE BEEN TOLD EACH CITY HAS
TO ESTABLISH AN SP TWO ZONE
WHICH IS WHERE YOU COULD PUT.
A YEAR ROUND HOMELESS SHELTER
USING TWO HUNDRED BEDS.
SO THE CITY OF FULLERTON
ESTABLISHES A LOCATION.
I BUY A BUILDING.
AND THE CITY GOES NUTS.
AND THE COUNCIL VOTED DOWN.
SANTA ANA SET UP IN SB TWO ZONE
I BY BUILDING.
OR BUT SHOULD BY AYE OPEN ESCROW.
CITY GOES NUTS AND I HAVE TO
PULL OUT OF ESCROW.
SO.
I'M.
I'M JUST WONDERING AS AS THE
GOVERNOR'S GETTING A LITTLE
FIRMER.
ABOUT RINA.
HOW DO WE GET A LITTLE FIRMER
FOR THE HOMELESS?
WITH SB TWO ZONES BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S.
DOING THE GENERAL PLANTS.
IN THEIR IN THEIR A AND THEY'RE
DOING THEM.
BUT IGNORING NEMESIS CENTER
NIELSEN KIND OF ALLUDED TO IT'S
LIKE.
SO SO YOU'RE HAPPY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW.
THE CITY HAS DONE THEIR GENERAL
PLAN AND EVERYTHING'S FINE.
AT LEAST HUNTINGTON BEACH WAS
HONEST.
AND SAID WE'RE CUTTING BACK.
YOU KNOW TO WORK IN A DIFFERENT
MODE -- BUT
WE'RE GETTING CITIES THAT SAY
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS AND
THEN DON'T.
AND SO I'M I'M FRUSTRATED THEIR
IS AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
HOMELESSNESS.
THAT ARE YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT
TO END UP [inaudible]
JUST SERVICE.
SB TWOS SO I I JUST I I JUST PUT
THAT OUT THERE FOR YET BECAUSE
THIS WILL BE A MORE CRITICAL
ONCE WE START [inaudible]
ALLOCATING THESE --
THE SAYS.
PROP TWO FUNDS SO.
ABSOLUTELY IN TWO QUICK POINTS
ON THAT FIRST IS ON ARENA
HEADING THE MINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES JUST LIKE YOU SAID
THAT.
IN THE PAST THESE GOALS HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY REFLECTED REALITY
AND SAID THAT SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE A PRIORITY FOR H. C. D. --
BUILDING ON THE LEGISLATION THAT
WILL BE PASSED LAST YEAR TO MAKE
SURE THAT WITHOUT COMMENTING ON
THE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT SOME THESE
DISPARITIES.
THE DON'T SEEM TO REFLECT THE
ACTUAL HOUSING NEEDS OF THAT
JURISDICTION ARE CORRECTED
OVERTIME SO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
GOAL OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHEN IT COMES MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU MENTION AROUND HOMELESSNESS
SHELTERS.
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE AND THERE'S
NO EASY ANSWER TO THAT AND TO
SENATOR NIELSEN'S POINT.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
CAN DRAFT YEAR OVER YEAR WHEN
YOU FIND WORKING WE PUT THIS
WILL WAIT TILL NEXT YEAR IT'S
NOT GETTING APPROVED.
STIRS NO GOOD ANSWER BUT I THINK
ONE THING THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS NOT ONLY DOES HE TRY
WITH THIS ONE TIME MONEY TO
REWARD.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FOR DOING
THE RIGHT THING HE REALLY
REWARDS REGIONAL COOPERATION
BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT RIGHT THE
COUNTY MIGHT WANT ONE THING AND
THEN THE CITY MIGHT WANT TO VERY
DIFFERENT BANKS AND THAT'S HOW
THINGS GET PUSHED.
INTO THE FUTURE AND SO WITH THIS
POT OF MONEY AND THIS IS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS DEPENDING ON OUR FISCAL
SITUATION IN THE YEARS AFTER
THAT BUT IF THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS STEP UP WITH THIS.
NOT ONLY WILL THEY GET THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
NEED BUT THEY'LL ALSO GET SOME
DECENT SENT A PAYMENT SO.
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT YOUR THAT YOU BRING UP BUT
IT'S AND GENTLE KNOWLEDGE TO
HELP PEOPLE DO THE RIGHT THING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU --
I HAD I HAD A LONG LIST OF CD BG
R. HOUSING PUBLIC HOUSING ALL
THE ALL THE PROGRAMS A GOT A
LIMITED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR LAST DECADE OR SO.
IF IT WAS IS A SOUNDING LIST OF
PROGRAMS --
RELATED TO HOUSING HOMELESSNESS.
OF FUNDING --
FOR PEOPLE THAT.
WERE NEEDED RENT SUBSIDIES ALL
THOSE THINGS WERE ELIMINATED --
AND THE LAST SAY DECADE OR OR
BEYOND OUT SO WE ALL WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE BURDEN HAS SHIFTED. TO
THE STATE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INNOCENCE
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE
KINDA HAVING A TROUBLE WITH
DEVELOPING.
DOUBT REALITY AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE.
TO HAVE A REAL SPECIFIC.
PLAN ON HOUSING.
OKAY THAT'S WHY YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE USED TO BE A
OF FEDERAL THING.
IS NO LONGER FEDERAL THING THEY
ONLY WANT TO GET INVOLVED IN IT
ANYMORE.
OF ME THEY'RE VERY CLEAR.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY --
IDEAS.
COMING OUT ON THAT SUBJECT SO
NOW IT'S SURE.
TO AND IT'S NOW KIND OF MORE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT'S KIND
OF LOOK WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE SO FOR ME --
I LOOK AT THIS AS SETTING SOME
TARGETS HOW MANY YEARS YOU WANT
TO BUILD YOU'RE WHO YOU WANT
BUILDING.
FOR AND HOW MUCH MONEY IS GOING
TO COST.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO DO THAT
SOME PEARLY SIMPLE ARITHMETIC.
MINUS OF THE SUBJECT --
THE THE CAR SHARING BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS TO BE DEFINED WE
HAVE TO SAY OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
PUT IT X. AMOUNT.
THEY HAVE TO PUT UP X. AMOUNT.
WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY THAT WE HAD
TO BE REAL SPECIFIC WITH IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SPECIFIC
TARGETS OF NUMBER UNITS.
WE HAVE TO SAY YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PUT UP MIX MOUNT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PUT OF X.
AMOUNT [inaudible]
NO.
WE'VE ALREADY PUT A LOT OF
EMPHASIS.
IN -- TO OF
STARTING UP.
I WOULD SAY A HOUSING PROGRAM.
BUT WE HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED YET.
ON ON GOING SOURCE OF REVENUE
FOR A MAJOR HOUSING PROGRAM FROM
FROM THE STATE WE HAVE A LOT OF
ONE TIME PROGRAMS HERE.
THIS IS ONE TIME MONEY IS NT
ONGOING MONEY IT'S LIKE THIS
YEAR MAYBE NEXT YEAR WE HAVE
BUDGET FROM IT'LL GO IT WILL
IT'LL GO AWAY WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY.
SO I THINK WE ARE TODAY --
FIVE MORE OF AN ONGOING.
SOURCE OF FUNDS THAT WE HAVE TO
GO BACK IN AND ABLE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE AN ONGOING
SOURCE OF FUNDS.
THOSE ARE THE THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS IN GENERAL.
OF I I WANTED TO MANAGER WANTED
TO SAY.
I THINK THAT THIS WAS A
EXCELLENT REPORT WRITTEN BY THE
STAFF OVER VIEWING THIS ISSUE.
I WANTED TO CONGRATULATE THEM I
ALSO WANT TO GRADUATE DAILY --
REPORT
EXCELLENT VERY GOOD --
MY WAY OF THINKING IS THIS --
HOW MUCH SUBSIDY?
DO WE DO WE HAVE TO HAVE TO GET
THE VERY LOW.
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
REALLY BE AIDED BY.
SIR THIS TRICKLE DOWN HOUSING.
THERE TOO LOW THERE TOO FAR DOWN.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE HELD BY
ANY.
TRICKLE DOWN OF MASSIVE
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM THAT WOULD
THAT.
CREATES --
MORE HOUSING THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
GONNA NEED THEY'RE ALWAYS GONNA
NEED SOME CARS SUBS.
SO WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY WHO THOSE
PEOPLE ARE I'VE IDENTIFIED THEM
AS THE VERY LOW AND LOW VERY LOW
AND EXTREMELY LOW INCOME --
HOUSING A CHALLENGE PEOPLE HAT
PAY OVER 50% OF THEIR INCOME FOR
HOUSING THAT'S ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS.
SO THOSE WHO THE PEOPLE IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE THAT AND YOU WANT
TO SAY HOW LONG YOU SHOULD WE
WORK TO PROVIDE THEM HOUSING WE
DID A TEN YEAR PLAN --
ONLY WE HAVE TO DO ABOUT A
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND UNITS
HERE.
BOOK THAT'S A LOT.
SO -- HOW TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO IT HOW
TO THE STATE GOVERNMENT'S DO IT
WE'RE GONNAHAVE TO PUT UP? FIVE
SIX BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
STE IT TOOK TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GOING OUT TO
PUT UP THREE THREE MAYBE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
OKAY SO WE HAVE TO HAVE LAWS
THAT ENABLE THEM TO DO THAT I
THINK THE ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE.
FINANCING DISTRICT --
LAW IS A GOOD START.
OF OF SAN WHICH DEDICATES 50% OF
THE FUNDS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT'S ANOTHER START ALLOWING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
TO START RESTART SOME KIND OF
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT KIND OF
PROGRAM --
THAT'S ANOTHER START OF BUT THE
STATE GOVERNMENT'S GOING OUT.
TO HAVE A STREAMLINED HOUSING
PROGRAM I THINK ONE WAY WE CAN
HELP HOUSING IS TO REDUCE FEES.
OF SIR WHAT KOWSKI.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST TO PUT ONE
IN YOUR E. D. USE?
IN FREMONT WHAT WHAT HOW MUCH
VISA THEY'VE CHART IT WAS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY
FOR A FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT --
ALTERNATE DWELLING UNIT PROJECT
FOR TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY OF CHANGE THAT
THERE'S AN ANNOYING SENATOR
REPRESENTS.
THE DATA BACK.
THEY THEY HAVE ACTUALLY KICK UP
AND DECIDED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND NOT CHARGE NUMBER
EIGHTY YOU SO SO SO MY POINT IS
THE FEE THE FEE ISSUE HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A POLICY.
THAT.
KEEPS LOCAL GOVERNMENT FROM SHE
OVER CHARGING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS.
PROCESS REDRAWN KNOWS ALL THOSE
KIND OF PROJECTS WE NEED A
POLICY A LAW.
THAT PROTECTS.
THE THOSE ISSUE CENTER SKINNER
HAD A HAD A PROPOSAL ON RENTS I
THINK THOSE KINDS OF THINGS HELP --
PREVENT --
THE A GENTRIFICATION I'D LIKE
I'D LIKE TO ASK DAILY --
FINALLY IF THEY COULD FIND OUT.
OUR HOUSING STOCK.
OF WE'RE LOOKING AT LIKE IT'S
STATIC HERE.
BUT WE'RE REALLY NEED TO KNOW IS
HOW MANY UNITS HAVE GONE FROM
AFFORDABLE.
THE OF THE EXISTING HOUSING
STOCK HOW MANY YEARS HAVE GONE
FROM AFFORDABLE TO NON
AFFORDABLE.
DUE TO THE GENTRIFICATION OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES
BECAUSE THAT'S A NEGATIVE.
TO WHEN THE PRICES GO SO HIGH
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD AND
THEY HAVE TO MOVE OUT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THEY LIVE THEIR
LIVES IN.
BECAUSE THE RENTS ARE GONNA HI
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE AEAS LIKE
THAT NEVER DISTRICT I DO.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE THE THE TREND IN CALIFORNIA --
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS RESTRICTIVE
SUPPLY?
WE HAVE THIS JENNIFER CATION
THAT ACTUALLY --
MAYBE DUE TO SOME GOVERNMENT
POLICIES WE HAVE TO FIND OUT
WHAT GOVERNMENT POLICIES
ENCOURAGE GENTRIFICATION.
IN IN A NEGATIVE WAY IN TERMS OF
PRICING OF HOUSE HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE RENTS.
AND I TAKE THOSE --
THOSE ISSUES HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED --
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
AND THANK YOU MANAGER.
ROB WHO'LL BE FOLLOWED BY
CENTERS TO RISE SO WHY CAL SKI
AND REQUIRE SONORA VENTURE OVER
THE LAST.
YEAR TO WE'VE.
HAD SEVERAL BILLS PASSED THROUGH
BOTH SENT IN THE ASSEMBLY SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR.
HAVING TO DO WITH OUR HOUSING
PACKAGE ONE OF THEM WAS THE
SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR ZERO WHICH
HAD TO DO WITH HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
WHICH ALLOWED CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO COMBINE --
NONCONTIGUOUS PARCELS OF
PROPERTY OVERLY WITH THIS BILL
AND THEN [inaudible]
APPROVED. FOR A RAPID SCHEDULE
PROJECT PROPOSALS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED TO COMPLY.
OF THAT WHOLE PROCESS OF COURSE
DEPENDS ON HAVING THE MONEY TO
FUND THE PLANNING THIS SPECIFIC
PLAN IN THE E. I. ARE --
IS THE IS THERE SOME PORTION OF
THE SEVEN IF YOU'VE COVERED THIS
JUST TELL ME SO AND I'LL.
SHUT UP.
BUT IS THERE SOME PORTION OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE HOUSING PLANNING
AND PRODUCTION GRANT PEACE.
ALLOCATED FOR THAT PLANNING
PURPOSE FOR EXAMPLE THE SB.
FIVE FOUR ZERO PLANNING PROCESS
SO WE HAVEN'T MADE THAT SPECIFIC
DETERMINATION YET IT SO WE KNOW
THAT THE GOALS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND THE GOALS AND
SB FIVE FORTY ARE VERY SIMILAR.
AND WE ALSO KNOW AS YOU POINTED
OUT FUNDING IS THE KEY ISSUE FOR
THE LOANS AND WHERE IS IT GOING
TO COME FROM.
AND THAT SB TO FUNDING IS
DANIELLE MENTIONED IS JUST
COMING IN --
SO GIVEN THAT A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAM FIND I THINK EIGHT CD IN
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AND MONTHS
WE'LL BE TAKING THE LEAD IN
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES FOR HOW
THAT WILL BE FUNDED SO TENSE
YOUR QUESTION IT'S NOT IN OUR
BUDGET.
RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THANK YOU AND THEN ONE FINAL
QUESTION ARE ONE SECOND QUESTION
IN MY FINAL ONE HAS TO DO WITH A
MENTAL HEALTH.
TRANSITIONAL IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES FUNDING AS OPPOSED TO
THE CONSTRUCTION OF FACILITIES.
TO HOUSE THOSE WHO ARE --
HOMELESS --
WHAT?
I HAVE I'M LOOKING AT THIS LIST
OF THAT WE HAVE ANYWHERE OUR
PACKET HAVING TO DO WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
[inaudible]
VARIOUS --
APPROPRIATIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHICH PIECE
OF THIS DEALS WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
IS IT IS IT THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR A WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS HOUSING INVESTMENT.
THE PROJECT ASSISTANCE IN THE
TRANSITION FROM HOMELESSNESS
IT'S ABOUT NINE MILLION.
SO I WOULD SAY WITHIN THE
HOUSING LIST OF ITEMS THAT YOU
HAVE TO KEEP PORTIONS ARE NUMBER
ONE THAT ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A WHOLE CREEK PERSON
CARE PILOTS.
AND SECOND AND WHILE NOT
DIRECTLY THERE IS OFTEN AN
OVERLAP FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR SSI WERE ELIGIBLE
BUT ARE NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING
SSI THERE IS AN OVERLAP THERE
OFTEN WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL.
HEALTH CONDITIONS SO THOSE ARE
THE TWO IN OUR BUDGET BETTER
SPECIFICALLY TIED TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE ARE OTHER PORTIONS OF OUR
BUDGET.
THAT DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH
MORE BROADWAY AND THAT INCLUDES
OUR NEW MONEY FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR EARLY PSYCHOSIS
DETECTION.
AND ALSO INCLUDES --
THE CHANGES THAT WERE MAKING TO
OUR AYE HSS PROGRAM INCLUDING RE
BENCHING THE COUNTY MOE ACTUALLY
FREES UP MONEY FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AT THE COUNTY LEVEL SO
THAT SHOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE
ACROSS THE STATE.
SINCE IT'S ALL RIGHT FOOD
RELATED I MEAN MY LISTEN GIVING
THEM A LEG UP AND MOVING ON I I
ASSUME WE'LL DO THIS IN THIS AT
THE SUBCOMMITTEE LEVEL DOCTOR
PAN AND HIS GROUP --
AND SO ALL RELY ON THEM WOULD BE
NICE TO HAVE SORT OF A A TOTAL
LOOK AT WHAT OUR TOTAL MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING PIECES AND HOW IT
ALL SORT OF RELATES BUT AGAIN
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
MANAGER APPRECIATE YOU PATIENCE
SIR I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
THE SHORT QUESTION --
BUT IT'S RELATED TO WHAT SENATOR
NIELSEN HAD RAISED.
ON SOMEONE OTHERS HAD.
OF SAID ABOUT ONGOING SOURCES OF
FUNDING --
THESE TO BE THE COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE WHICH WERE ELIMINATED.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE WERE.
SOME THAT DIDN'T WORK AT ALL
SOME THAT WORKED.
REALLY WELL IN SOME THAT KIND OF
WORK BUT IN LOS ANGELES IT AT
LEAST KIND OF WORK BECAUSE THAT
WAS A STEADY.
IT WAS A SOURCE OF CONTINUE WITH --
HOUSING.
THAT WAS --
THAT'S HOW IT WAS DONE RIGHT WE
WE ALWAYS KNEW THERE WAS AN
AGENCY THAT WAS CONTINUOUSLY
MOVING AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
HOUSING WAS BUILT.
WITH THERE WAS ENOUGH FOR WAS
AND IS ANOTHER QUESTION SO.
I GUESS BUT TO TO WHAT THE
EARLIER QUESTION WAS DO WE KNOW.
HOW MUCH AND HOW WELL THOSE
SERIES?
WORKED TO BE A CONTINUOUS SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR HOUSING --
BECAUSE WE THREW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATH WATER HERE AND
JUST IT WAS ALL ELIMINATED
WITHOUT HAVING ANY ANALYSIS.
OF WHERE IT WAS DOING GOOD AND
WHY IT WAS DOING GOOD BUT IT
CERTAINLY WAS A LOCAL SOURCE OF
FUNDING.
REGULAR SOURCE OF FUNDING SO DO
YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON THAT.
THE ALL MAKE ONE OR TWO KEY
POINTS AND THEN DANIELLE OR LA I
MIGHT WANT TO WEIGH IN AS WELL I
THINK THE FIRST IS.
AS YOU MENTIONED YOU NOT ONLY
WAS A DIFFERENT PROGRAM BUT IT
WAS ELIMINATED A VERY DIFFERENT
TIME FOR THE STATE EVEN THOUGH
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT YOU
KNOW WE IT WORKS --
THE REASON THE GOVERNOR FOCUSED
ON THE I. S. D.'S IS HE VIEWED
THIS AS A WAY.
TO CONTINUE TO HARMONIZE YOU GET
YOUR SECTIONS WORKING TOGETHER
WHICH WAS A KEY GOAL OF THAT
PROGRAM THAT WAS ELIMINATED.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME RAIN AND
SOME OF THE EXCESSES OR THE FACT
THAT THIS WOULD BE MONEY THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO SCHOOLS
AND HERE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE.
PROBLEMS WERE CORRECTED FOR BUT
YOU ARE RIGHT THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO AN ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDING
WE HAVE SP TWO WHICH IS A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE HAVE THE FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
HOUSING BONDS WHERE HE BOND
MONEY WILL HOPEFULLY START
FLOWING THIS YEAR THAT WE HAVE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDING --
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO A BROADER
ON GOING FUNDING SOURCE --
THAT'S REALLY A BUDGETARY
CHALLENGE BECAUSE I CERTAINLY
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LOOK
FAVORABLY ON IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF WHERE THE MONEY IS COMING
FROM AND WHEN IT CAME TO THOSE.
REYES AND REDEVELOPMENT NO THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
ELIMINATED IN A BUDGET CRISIS
AND AS MENTIONED IT REALLY.
IN SOME WAYS TOOK MONEY FROM THE
SCHOOL SHARE THAT WAS DONE BACK
FILLED BY THE STATE AND THAT WAS
MONEY THAT THE STATE.
COULD AND THEN SPEND ON OTHER
PRIORITIES --
SO CERTAINLY THAT'S A
CONVERSATION WE WANT TO HAVE
WITH YOU YOU KNOW WE I THINK WE
SHARE A LOT OF THE SAME GOALS
IT'S JUST A MATTER ESPECIALLY AS
A FINANCE.
THINKING WHERE IS THAT ONGOING
MONEY COMING FROM.
AND JUST A COMMENT --
I KNOW YOU MADE TO REFORM SUCH
AS OR SPORTSVENUES --
I WAS INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
VERY FIRST --
PULLS ALL THAT INVOLVED A SPORTS
VENUE.
AND I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
WHAT WE DID WAS TO NEGOTIATE A
VERY BROAD VERY INCLUSIVE
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENT.
SO WHILE IT'S REFERRED TO AS
DOING A FAVOR FOR BILLIONAIRES
THAT -- ONE
WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE MODEL
FOR SUBSEQUENT --
YOU KNOW SEQUEL --
SORT OF REFORM TYPE OF PROJECTS
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN MODELED ALL
THE WAY THROUGH.
AND ALL THE WAY THROUGH MEANT
THAT THERE WERE MANY ISSUES IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE GIVEN IN
EXCHANGE FOR THE VALUE.
OF HAVING --
A CHANGED ONE PIECE OF THE SUPER
PROCESS THAT DIDN'T ELIMINATED
ALTOGETHER BUT I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T JUST
SORT OF THROW EVERYTHING INTO
ONE CATEGORY.
BUT JUST LOOK AT WHAT THE VALUE
WAS AND THE EFFORT THAT WAS PUT
INTO -- SEEK
WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
AND THERE ARE WAYS OF DOING THAT
THAT DOESN'T HARM ANY COMMUNITY
WE HAD A VERY BROAD INCLUDING
BUYER MENTALIST COMMUNITY BASED
GROUPS GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ALL AGREED.
AND IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT SO I
JUST THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
OTHERWISE IT BECOMES ARE YOU PRO
OR AGAINST SEE PLUS.
AND THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT SHOULD
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
YOUR Q. --
SENATE DRUGS OF CENTER WHAT
CASCADE.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE TALKS
ABOUT SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS WE'VE
ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT TO SEND
PROBLEMS.
DOESN'T JUST GO BACK TO THE
FISCAL STATION OF OF LAND USE
MEAN WE'RE WE'RE SITTING HERE
TELLING CITIES THAT THEY HAVE TO
DO THIS AND WE DON'T GIVE THEM
THE ECONOMIC MEANS THE REASON
THEY HAVE AUTO MALL SAYS BECAUSE
OR ALMOST AS BECAUSE THE PROP.
THIRTEEN AND AND I WANT TO ASK
DAILY -- AND
AND THE FINANCE YOU KNOW.
MY COLLEAGUES TO EACH SIDE OF ME
HAVE PROP SIXTY TWO IMPROPER TO
EIGHTEEN WHICH TAKES CARE
GENERAL LAW GENERAL TAX
INCREASES IMPARTIAL TEXAS TO ALL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS SPECIAL
TAXES.
ON PROP THIRTEEN WHICH SEEMS TO
BE WHAT EVERYBODY'S DANCING
AROUND HIS HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING WHY IS IT A BAD IDEA NOT
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE REPEAL OF PROP.
THIRTEEN SO THAT WOULD BE
DISCUSSION.
SO I THINK --
I WILL SAY IT IS JUST WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID WHICH IS THAT
HE IS OPEN TO A DISCUSSION.
ON TAX REFORM AND WE ALL KNOW
THERE IS AN INITIATIVE THAT HAS
ALREADY QUALIFIED FOR THE BALLOT
IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY AND CERTAINLY THAT
CONVERSATION BOTH THISYEAR AND
NEXT YEAR.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN CHANGES TO THE
PROPOSITION PROCESS NOW
INVOLVING THE LEGISLATURE AS
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS --
THAT CERTAINLY DISCUSSION THAT'S
COMING AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION ARE OPEN TO
HEARING ALL PERSPECTIVES ON THAT.
WOULDN'T WITH ALEJO DON'T WE
JUST RETURNED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
DECISIONS WE ACTUALLY DON'T
RAISE THE ASSESSED VALUE OR
CREATE SPECIAL TAXES WE JUST GET
THE AUTHORITY BACK TO THEM.
WELL SO THERE SHOULD ONLY
CONCERN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT
ACCOMMODATING YOU HOUSING AND
THEREFORE YOU PEOPLE WILL NOT
RAISE ENOUGH REVENUE TO COVER
THE ADDITIONAL SERVICES THAT
THOSE RESIDENTS WOULD NEED.
AND SO ALL THREE OF THE
ALLOCATION OF LOCAL TAXES --
COULD HELP SO THAT YOU GET A THE
NEW SERVICES NEEDED ASK NEW
HOUSING COMES AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT THAT CAN BE
DONE -- ONE
OPTION IS TO ALLOCATE FUTURE TAX
REVENUE GROWTH IN A WAY THAT'S
REFLECTIVE OF OF POPULATION
GROWTH AND AND HOUSING BUILDING --
WHILE THESE CHANGES ARE
CERTAINLY WORTHWHILE AND AND
MERIT CONSIDERATION THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY HURDLES TO THAT AS
WELL THERE'S SOME CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMITS THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED ON HOW THESE
ALLOCATIONS HAPPEN --
THERE'S ALSO CLEARLY IT WOULD BE
SOME LOCAL PUSH BACK BECAUSE ANY
REALLOCATION WOOD RIDGE
NATURALLY RESULT IN NEW WINNERS
AND LOSERS AND THERE CAN BE SOME
CONCERN THAT.
SOME COMMUNITIES WOULD NOT FARE
WELL IN THAT PROCESS OF THERE'S
DIFFICULT DISCUSSIONS BUT IT
COULD CERTAINLY LEAD TO
MEANINGFUL CHANGES IN THE SPACE.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE IS --
THAT THE IMPACT FEES FOR NEW
HOMES AT LEAST IN IN MY
COMMUNITY --
NOW HAVE BROKEN THE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AREA AND WE CAN SIT
HERE AND DANCE AROUND IN STATE
AND SAY THINGS MY QUESTION.
IS ON THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THAT WE'RE GIVING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I HAVE A AN INTEREST
IN EIGHTY USE WE PASSED ALONG
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT SAID
IF YOU DON'T COMPLY WITH STATE
LAW YOUR YOUR YOUR LOCAL
ORDINANCES ARE FALLING NóI.
NOT TWO HUNDRED CITIES OF
ACTUALLY PASSED NEW EIGHTY USE
LAWS BUT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY HAVE
NOT NOW SOME OF THEM ARE
COMPLYING WITH STATE LAW AND I
APPLAUD THEM BUT A WHOLE BUNCH
OF THEM.
NOT TO POINT OUT ANYONE'S
REPRESENTED ON THIS PAGE HE USES
TO JUST TO MOST TO BE DOING WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE DOING TO TO HELP
US MEET OUR HOUSING TARGETS.
ARE THEY GONNA BE LIMITATIONS ON
THEM TO JUST COMPLY WITH STATE
LAW.
SO WE HAVE A DEMONSTRATION IS
STILL PUTTING TOGETHER AND BE
TRAILER BILL FOR CONSIDERATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE PRODUCTION
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED IN
THE ABSENCE OF THIS MONEY.
THAT IS THE GOAL.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DETAILS.
THANK YOU US AND WE CAN SEND
REQUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
PLACE LIKE HOME AND THE I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND IF
IT'S OKAY MISTER CHAIR TO BE
ABLE. TO TALK ON MISTER MOORE
LAST QUESTION I WANNA TAKE ONE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE GOOD
FOLKS EIGHT CD IS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS ARE ALREADY
MOVED SELF SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
A HUNDRED THOUSAND TO HELP.
COMMUNITIES PLAN FOR THOSE
PERMANENT HOUSING SO THEY ARE ON
IT AND JUST VERY VERY GRATEFUL
ON THAT.
JUST TALKING ABOUT --
OPPORTUNITIESOWN SYNTAX
CONFORMITY TO SOME CONCERNS WANT
TO BE ABLE TO FLAG BOTH --
FOR OBVIOUSLY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LA L. IN A SENATE BUDGET
STAFF.
IF THE STATE MOOSE ATTACKS
CONFORMITY AN OPPORTUNITY ZONES --
CONFORMING WITH WHAT FEDERAL LAW
IS.
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE LOCATED
WITHIN A NEW OPPORTUNITIES ON
CITY CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT HAVE
TO PAY ANY GAME ON THEIR TAXES.
TO TWENTY FORTY SEVEN AND THAT'S
A HUGE CONCERN AND GIVE WAY. TO
LARGE CORPORATIONS --
AND WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT IS GREEN
BUSINESS ON N PARAPHRASING HERE
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES WELT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS.
VERY BROAD.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE HYPER FOCUSED ON THE DETAILS
IF FOR MOVING TOWARDS
OPPORTUNITIESOWNS.
AND TAX CONFORMITY ON WHAT THAT
WILL MEAN FOR THE STATE OUR
COFFERS --
AS WELL AS WHAT OUTCOMES THAT WE
WANT TO ACHIEVE ME TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC --
AND NOT BROAD BECAUSE AS WE'VE
SEEN MULTIPLE PRESS REPORTS ON
EVEN MEMBERS OF THE CURRENT
PRESIDENTIAL MINISTRATIONS
FAMILY HAD BEEN ABLE TO TAKE.
ARE CONSIDERED --
OPPORTUNITY --
AND GAIN FROM OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
AN INCREASE IN ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE EDISON KNOW IF THERE'S BEEN
EXPLORATIONS ON THIS BECAUSE I
HAVE SOME CONCERN ON THAT.
ABSOLUTELY SO I THINK ON MAKE
TWO POINTS IN AND THIS IS AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION THE FIRST
IS THAT --
ON THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL WE'RE
STILL FINALIZING THE DETAILS
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
COMPLICATED IT'S NEW THERE ARE A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS.
AND WE IN PARTICULAR WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
PROJECTS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
VALUABLE AND TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE BITS INCENTIVIZING
INVESTMENT WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
SITTING ONE THING THAT'S
DIFFERENT OUR INTERPRET THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY RECEIVE ANY
TAX BREAK IT'S THE INVESTORS IN
THOSE PROJECTS SO I THINK THE
INITIAL GOAL OF THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS IS TO GET MORE MONEY
INTO THESE.
DISTRICTS WHERE THE MONEY
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT GO AND THEN
GIVE THOSE INVESTORS SOME TYPE
OF BREAK ON ANY CAPITAL GAINS
THAT A CREW --
I WILL SAY I THINK ARE GOVERNED
FIVE STAFF HAVE A DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION ON THAT --
AS THEY ARE NOT PAINTING FEDERAL
TAX IN THE NEW GAINES ON THAT
BASE WHEN THE OPPORTUNITIES
OWNERS CREATED SO WOULD LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S THAT'S
CORRECT FOR THE INVESTOR THAT IS
CORRECT GAINED.
IN THAT IS A POTENTIAL HUGE HIT
TO WHAT WOULD BE OUR STATE
BUDGET IF WE'RE GONNA BE
CONFORMING YES YES AND SO
CERTAINLY AND ESPECIALLY WHAT WE
DO AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WERE VERY WARY OF ANY --
ANY POLICIES THAT MIGHT AFFECT
THE GENERAL FUND IN A NEGATIVE
WAY SO AS PART OF OUR TAX
CONFIRM THE PACKAGE WE'RE DOING
OUR MODELING AND TAKING A HARD
LOOK AT WHETHER.
WHAT THE REVENUE IMPACT WILL BE
AND WHETHER THOSE PROJECTS WILL
BE BENEFICIAL AND I THINK THE
SECOND THING TO YOUR POINT IS
THIS QUESTION OF MORE YOU KNOW
HOW WILL HOW WILL THIS BE
DETERMINES OPPORTUNITY ZONES OF
ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED UNITS
AT?
FEDERAL STATE DETERMINATION --
BUT THE THE FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE
BEEN GETTING IS THE I'D LIKE YOU
SAID IT CAN BE HARD THIS IS A
PRETTY BROAD CATEGORY SO WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO STRUCTURE
WHAT TYPES OF INVESTMENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE BUT BY ANY DEFINITION.
IT'S GOING TO BE BROAD SO THE
REASON IT'S PART OF OUR
CONFORMITY PACKAGES WE TO THINK.
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK OUT FOR BUT THERE IS A
POSITIVE ELEMENT TO THEM
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU PAIR THEM
WITH THE IRAQIS.
THIS COULD ACTUALLY THE GOVERNOR
SAID TRANSPORTATION IS HOUSING
THE FACT THIS IS NEW AND THERE
IS A LOT THAT WE NEED TO WATCH
OUT.
FOR AGAIN I THINK THAT --
THE NARROWER NARROW THE FOCUS
THE BETTER --
AND IF OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE NEED
TO BE ADDED TO FIND AT ON AND
WHERE ARE.
DEFICIT IS AT BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
IS ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN THE VERY LOW
LOW AND MODERATE CATEGORIES.
SO IF THAT IS GOING TO BE A
FOCUS BECAUSE WHAT WE CONTINUE
TO HEAR AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
ANYONE THINKS I'M WRONG.
IS THAT MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS
ARE UNABLE. TO BUILD UNITS
WITHIN THOSE THREE CATEGORIES
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST OF
CONSTRUCTION.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT
THIS IS A ROAD THAT WE'RE GONNA
GO DOWN.
IT'S GOING TO BE FOCUSED.
AND NOT A GIVEAWAY.
AND NOT CAN IMPACT OUR STATE
COFFERS AND RIGHT NOW.
ST AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN GREEN
TECHNOLOGY VERY BROAD AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING
AT IT IS FOR THE FLAG THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S SOME
HUGE RAMIFICATIONS AS WE MOVE
FOR THAT ON IF WE'RE GONNA
CONFORM TO WHAT THE CURRENT
FEDERAL DEFINITION IS.
YES THAT'LL JUST MAKE ONE POINT
IN THAT IN THE INTEREST THIS OUT
BUT ONE THING THAT WE ALSO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION FINANCING OF
WE'VE SET OUT OUR GOALS.
FOR MAKING GET MAKING THIS
CHANG TO OUR TAX CODE WHICH
WOULD COST THE STATE MONEY AND
THOSE GOALS ARE VERY SIMILAR TO
YOURS.
THAT YOU MENTIONED ARE VERY
ALIGNED AT THE SAME TIME I THINK
ONE THING THAT WE THINK A LOT
ABOUT IS THE SIMPLICITY OF THE
TAX CODE AND OF COURSE THE TAX
CODE IS VERY COMPLICATED ALWAYS.
AND ALWAYS WILL BE --
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN YOU KNOW IT CAN BE HARD TO
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A
TRANSPORTATIONPROJECTS.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY FOLLOW
FALL INTO HOUSING WORE GREEN
JOBS BUT IF IT'S AN INFILL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT IT COULD
HELP BOTH OF THOSE THINGS.
SO FOR THE PURPOSES OF
SIMPLICITY YOU KNOW WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO BE
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS OR
DO WE CONFORM ON A BROADER SET
OF CATEGORIES LIKE YOU MENTIONED
THE PROPOSAL SOUNDS LIKE RIGHT
NOW.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
EMPHASIS OF GOVERNMENT ARE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
STEERING INVESTORS AND
HIGHLIGHTING PROJECTS TO GO IN
THE CATEGORIES THAT YOU OUTLINED
IN.
THE CONVERSATION TO BE CONTINUED
ON THE ISSUE OF INCENTIVES --
THE STATE DOESN'T.
ALWAYS AT HAS NOT ALWAYS HAD THE
BEST TRACK RECORD.
I'M GETTING ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE UNITS BUILT WHEN IT
COMES TO INCENTIVES --
AND WHAT HS ENDED UP HAPPENING
IN YEARS PAST AYE AND WOULD LOOK
pTO BE A BE ABLE TO VERIFY THIS
AS WELL.
IS THAT WHAT IS INDEED UP
HALFPENNIES ONLY INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD ITS
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE
PIPELINE AND BEEN APPROVED.
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO FIND NEW UNITS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PIPELINE AND OR HAS BEEN
APPROVED.
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND I THINK
THAT'S TOUGH ON AND WANTED TO
MAKE SURE IF WE'RE GOING DOWN
THAT ROAD LEARN FROM THOSE
MISTAKES BECAUSE THERE OF MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IN THE
PAST WE'VE ENDED UP SPENDING
HUNDREDS IF NOT OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS ON MOSTLY.
PRE APPROVED PROJECTS BUT NO
PROJECTS THAT ARE NEW BECAUSE
THEN CENTER PROGRAM.
SO I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
IN ON THE LAST ITEM ME AND IN
MADAM CHAIR.
IS ON A PERMANENT SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
LOOK WE HAVE --
ELEVEN TO TWELVE BILLION MOVING
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS IN THE
STATE.
IN WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT --
CENTER BELL IN THIS ENTIRE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE
INTERNET LINES COMING IN WHICH
IS FANTASTIC. TO BE A TO MAKE A
DENT -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WERE SOME
ABUSES IN RDA IN THE PAST THANK
WE NEED WE ARE LEARN FROM THOSE
MISTAKES.
PUT SOME TIGHT --
PARAMETERS AROUND.
WHAT WE WANT TO BE DOING THIS TO
BE A BE ABLE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING?
AND AT A MINIMUM PUT A TEN TO
TWENTY YEAR TIME FRAME SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THESE UNITS
BUILT.
BECAUSE AGAIN I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO RUN INTO OUR
DEVELOPERS COMING TO US AND
SAYING THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO BUILD WITHIN THOSE THREE
CATEGORIES.
VERY LOW LOW AND MOD WITHOUT
HAVING A PERMANENT SOURCE.
AS YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
FEEDBACK ON THAT.
SO RIGHT NOW THAT SOMETHING
FINDING I'M GOING MONEY IS IS
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE SO WE WILL
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'RE
CONSTANTLY MONITORING THE BUDGET
AND ONCE REVENUES COMING IN
APRIL WILL HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF WHERE THINGS ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE'S
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR LEYVA
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN THE
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR THE FOR THE PRESENTATION NOT
JUST A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS AND
SOME QUESTIONS --
AND IT OPENS.
PRIOR TO THE ABOLITION OF RDA --
BIG ABOARD SUPERVISOR AND AND A
CITY COUNCIL WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
HOUSING EMERGENCIES THAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
AND THAT WAS AN ON GOING REVENUE
STREAM OR 20% HAD TO BE SET
ASIDE.
FOR LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING AND SO I COUNTY WE WE
DID A GOOD JOB OF PROVIDING GET
AND WHEN THAT FUNDING SOURCE
STOPPED --
THAT'S WHEN RAN INTO PROBLEMS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT --
THE COST OF BUILDING TODAY AND
THE COST OF GETTING THROUGH
MUNICIPALITIES.
IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE KEEP ADDING MORE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND MAKING ANOTHER INSPECTION
ANOTHER MANDATE --
MORE EXPENSIVE FOR DEVELOPERS TO
PROVIDE THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP. TO CALIFORNIANS.
SO OUT FIRST TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AGAINST COULD SEE YOU
AGAIN SIR --
THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE FOR THE HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
IS A ONE TIME --
ALLOCATION CORRECT ONE TIME
MONEY TO BILLING --
ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLAR OKAY.
SO ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS SO
BASED ON ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER DOOR.
WHICH IS PROBABLY WHAT IT COST
TO BUILD.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOOK AT ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND UNITS FIFTY
THOUSAND UNITS BUT WE'RE LIKE A
MILLION UNITS.
UNDER WATER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M I DON'T YOU
MISTER BUT I DO APPRECIATE --
THE EFFORT --
BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO MORE --
THAN THAT.
AND WHILE I A APPRECIATE MY
COMMENTS FROM MY FRIEND SENATOR
Y. KASKI ABOUT PROP.
THIRTEEN MAYBE CONSTITUENTS IN
THE COASTAL COMMUNITIES CAN.
HAVE THEIR ASSESSED VALUES THAT
PRESENT A MARKET THAT RATHER
THAN THEIR BASE BUT PROP
THIRTEEN PROTECTIONS BUT I'LL
TELL YOU THAT.
AND MY DISTRICT AND IN MANY
INLAND COUNTIES --
THE BIG FEARS THE ABOLITION OF A
PROP THIRTEEN AND IT WILL TAKE
SO MANY -- A
GERIATRIC OLDER CALIFORNIANS
THAT ONE LIVE IN THEIR HOMES
IT'LL FORCE THEM OUT OF THEIR
HOMES.
IT'LL FORCE MANY MIDDLE CLASS
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS IN MY
DISTRICT THE LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK IT WILL FORCE THEM OUT
OF THEIR HOMES AND WE MAY BE.
EXACERBATING OF THE HOMELESS
CRISIS --
WITH THAT AND I JUST STARTED OUT
AS A A WARNING --
THAT -- THE
CITIZENS ARE ALREADY NERVOUS
ABOUT HI PROPOSITIONS ON THE
BALLOT IN TWENTY TWENTY BUT MY
QUESTION TO YOU SIR.
IS SURPLUS PROPERTY SO THE
GOVERNOR SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURPLUS PROPERTY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AVAILABLE --
FOR A LOT LOW INCOME HOUSING --
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION DONE AN
INVENTORY OF THAT SURPLUS
PROPERTY IS IT PUBLISHED IS IT
AND HOW WILL MUNICIPALITIES TO
BE ABLE.
TO APPLY TO ACQUIRE THAT LAND
AND AS HAS RULE MAKING BEEN DONE
AS TO HOW THOSE PROPERTIES CAN
AND WILL BE DEVELOPED.
YES SO.
ON THE QUEUE QUICK POINTS --
THE FIRST IS ON THE POINT THAT
YOU RAISED AT THE BEGINNING
WHICH I THINK IS SOMETHING THE
ADMINISTRATION REALLY AGREES
WITH IS THAT.
NUMBER ONE WE'D LIKE TO FIND
EVEN MORE SOURCES OF MONEY BUT
NUMBER TO THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
MAKING IS.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO SPEND OURSELVES OUT
OF WITH MONEY ALONE AND S I
THINK ONE PREMISE BEHIND THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGES THIS TAKES
LOCAL RULE CHANGES IN ZONING
CHANGES.
AND PERMITTING CHANGES AND EVEN
ALL THIS TOGETHER MAY NOT AMOUNT
TO THE SCALE OF THE PROBLEM THE
FIRST YEAR TO BUT WE'RE HOPING.
THAT DOES THINGS THAT MAY NOT
CAUGHT THERE JUST AS THE BUDGET.
THAT CAN ACTUALLY MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE AND SOLVING THE ISSUE
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT IF
YOU TAKE.
EVEN IF YOU MULTIPLY BY A BIG
FACTOR ARE SPENDING ANY DIVIDED
IT BY THE PER UNIT COST IT STILL
DOESN'T GET TO WHERE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BE EVEN ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS -- AND
THEN SECOND --
AND YOU CAN ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
PROPERTY RIGHTS I'M GONNA MOVE
ON FROM THAT.
AND I'M APPROACH YOU TODAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO SURPLUS
PROPERTY SO THE GOVERNOR'S AT
ISSUES EXECUTIVE ORDER SO THE
STATE IS IN THE PROCESS OF?
PUTTING TOGETHER THAT LIST RIGHT
NOW -- ONCE
WE HAVE THAT WAS THAT'S WHEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH ONE OF
THE RULES AND PROCESSES FOR WHAT
TO DO NEXT BUT THE WAY WERE
THINKING YOU KNOW JUST TO SHARE
OUR THINKING OF IT RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THAT.
WE WOULD HAVE THAT LIST AND THEN
WE CAN PUT THOSE OUT FOR EITHER
BATES ENOUGH FOR DEVELOPERS WERE
WILLING TO FOLLOW THE RULES IN
TERMS OF UNITS THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE OR IF THERE IS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS WILLING TO STEP UP AND
THERE ARE NECESSARILY ANY OTHER
PARTIES WE COULD ACTUALLY
TRANSFER THE LAND TO THEM
PERHAPS EVEN FOR A NOMINAL FEE
DEPENDING ON WHAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING --
AND THEN THEY CAN START BUILDING
UP PRETTY QUICKLY AFTER HAT
HAVE YOU THOUGHT AS AS YOU OFFER
THOSE PROPERTIES TO
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE YOU THOUGHT
OF MAKING A NEXUS TO FEE
REDUCTIONS.
A PART OF THAT PACKAGE IN THAT
BID PROCESS TO ACQUIRE THAT LAND
BASICALLY FOR NOTHING.
AT CENTER THAT'S A GOOD BECAUSE
WE HAD BASICALLY BEEN FOCUSING
ON THE LAND ITSELF YEAH TERMS OF
INCENTIVES THAT'S THAT'S A
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA WE WILL TAKE
AYE AYE THROUGH A VERY A BALL
OUT THERE BECAUSE YOU GIVEN THE
LAND FOR FREE THE THE THE FOR
USER ANOTHER.
COMPONENT THAT WE NEED TO LORD
HOPEFULLY --
YOU'LL I WAS AT THIS STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS AND AND AND I
WILL HEARD THE THE GOVERNOR'S --
CLAIM THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED SOME
SEQUEL REFORMS WHEN IT COMES TO
A PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
HOW SERIOUS IS THE GOVERNOR IT
IS HE IS HE WILLING TO SIGN A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT IS
GOING TO SEEK WITH STREAMLINED
NOT?
ELIMINATES EQUIPMENT SEQUENCE
STREAMLINED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO WE CAN GET HOUSING ON THE
MARKET FASTER.
SO WHAT FROM WHAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL --
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH
SENATOR TO RISE OUT.
THERE WE'VE DONE A LITTLE BIT
MORE THINKING AND EVENTUALLY
WILL PUT OUT OUR BILL WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BROADER HOUSING
PACKAGE I THINK IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION STONE YOU I THINK
WE'RE ABOUT FORTY FORTY FIVE
DAYS AND SO --
THE GOVERNOR HAS NOT COMMITTED
TO A SPECIFIC PACKAGE THERE YET
OKAY WILL BE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT -- AND
THEN WITH --
REGARD TO PROVIDING HOUSING.
FOR HOMELESS THE HOMELESS
POPULATION HIGH --
I I I LIKE TO SAY I AGREE WITH
MY FRIEND --
SENATOR BILL THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE A STRONG MENTOR MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING --
OTHERWISE WE'RE RECREATING
BASICALLY AN ASYLUM WHICH WE
DON'T WANT MENTAL ASYLUMS WE
WANT PLACES WHERE PEOPLE GET
COVER WHERE PEOPLE GET
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES AND SO IT HAS TO BE A
CONJOINED A CONJOINED EFFORT AND
I HOPE THAT THE GOVERNOR WILL
WILL LOOK AT THAT AS A MORE THAN
A ONE PRONGED ISSUE.
AND THEN FOR THE LA --
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN YOU
DID A STUDY THAT SHOWED THAT THE
COST OF BUILDING HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS.
BETWEEN FIFTY AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
HAVE YOU --
UPDATED THAT STUDY DO YOU KNOW
WHAT IT COST RIGHT NOW WITH I
MEAN WE HAVE.
SOLAR PANELS WE'RE ADDING ON NOW
THAT'S GOING TO CREATE OTHER
INSPECTIONS AND MORE COST WHAT
NOT THAT WE DON'T WANT TO BE
MORE GREEN IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT EVERY INCREMENTAL ADDITION.
TO OUR HOME EXPENSES PUSHING
MORE PEOPLE OUT OF THE REALM OF
AFFORDABILITY SO COULD YOU TELL
US WHERE WE ARE WITH RESPECT OR
COMPETITION.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT
DONE A DETAILED ANALYSIS TO
UPDATE THAT FIFTY TO SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR NUMBER THE
REFERENCE SINCE OUR TWENTY
FIFTEEN REPORT HOWEVER I THINK.
I THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR TO SAY
THAT THE MOST SIGNS ARE POINTING
TO THAT THE NUMBERS ARE PROBABLY
SOMEONE HIGHER THAN THAT NOW
WHERE WE SIT TODAY --
HOME THAT MOST OF THE FACTORS
THAT THAT FEED INTO THAT --
AS YOU MENTIONED --
BUILDING CODES --
OR LABOR IN THE CONSTRUCTION
MARIE COULD MATERIALS COSTS ALL
THOSE THINGS --
HAVE BECOME PROBABLY MORE COSTLY
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN I DON'T
HAVE A SPECIFIC NUMBER FOR YOU
OKAY SO --
IT THIS IS JUST ANOTHER A
VARIABLE.
AMONGST MANY IF WE'RE TRULY
GOING TO BE IN CITING
COMPETITION TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CITY CALIFORNIA IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME.
PAIN IF YOU WILL BY MANY
ENTITIES TO TO DELIVER THE
AMERICAN DREAM HERE IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
CAM THE LAST --
ISSUE A IS CAPITALIZE AGO WITH
MY FRIEND --
CENTER MCGUIRE WAS TALKING ABOUT
WAS OPPORTUNITIES OWNS --
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS TO BE
A A NARROW FOCUS ON OUR
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE BELIEVE OR NOT DON'T KNOW
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES OWNS EVEN ARE.
BUT IT IS A MECHANISM WHERE AN
INVESTOR COULD DIFFER A THEIR
CAPITAL GAINS IF YOU WILL
UNDERSTAND FOR TEN YEARS FROM.
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX MAYBE
THEY GET SOME EXTENSIONS TO TO
NEGATE THEIR AFTER TAX
ALTOGETHER BUT IT'S IT'S AN%
ALTERNATIVE TO TEN THIRTY ONE
EXCHANGE BUT IT'S MORE BROAD AND
YOU CAN GET INVESTMENTS IN AREAS
THAT.
TYPICALLY NEEDED LIKE OLD
REDEVELOPMENT SOME TWEAKING TO
IT WOULD GIVE THE ASSURANCES TO
MY COLLEAGUE THAT --
WE'RE NOT --
JUST MAKING THE RICH RICHER WERE
WERE WERE ACTUALLY DOING OUR
BEST TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING --
AND NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
STATE TREASURY --
I THINK OPPORTUNITIES OWNS OR
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
FURTHER REFINE ON AND ULTIMATELY
ONCE WE GET A REFINED IS.
TO TO PROMOTE THIS MODALITY OF
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT JUST CAN'T
BE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO SOLVE
THE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS IT NEEDS TO BE A PUBLIC.
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND PROBABLY
MORE MONEY WITH THE RIGHT
OPPORTUNITIES IS GOING TO COME
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE
PUBLIC SECTOR.
SO -- IF YOU
WANNA PINE IN THAT YOU CAN BUT I
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF MY
COLLEAGUES. TO DELIVER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND AND
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS THE HOMES
POPULATION WITH THE
ACCOMPANIMENT OF THE APPROPRIATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU MADAM BUDGET CHAIR --
AS I SIT HERE AND I LISTEN TO
ALL OF THE DISCUSSION I WANT TO
COME AT THIS FROM A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT ANGLE --
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND THE CHALLENGES
I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THERE IS A HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HOUSING? FOR WHAT I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYBODY TALK ABOUT
HIS WAGES WE DO NOT IN MY
OPINION ESTIMATION DO A GOOD
ENOUGH JOB OF PUSHING BACK ON
COMPANIES AND CORPORATIONS.
WE GOT VERY EXCITED WITH
OURSELVES WHEN WE PASS THE
MINIMUM WAGE A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO WHICH HASN'T TOTALLY GONE
INTO EFFECT.
BUT IN A COUPLE YEARS WORKERS
WERE. FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR IF
YOU'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO WORK FULL
TIME COMES OUT TO TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
WHERE I LIVE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WHERE IT'S CONSIDERED TO
BE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AT APARTMENT AN OLDER APARTMENT
A ONE BEDROOM IS GOING TO COST
YOU FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH SO IF I MAKING FUN THAT
PART TIME WORKER FROM SIMPLE
TIME.
AND I MAKING TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH GROSS.
HOW CAN I HAVE FOR THAT ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENT AT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS WE GET VERY
EXCITED WHEN PEOPLE MAKE
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR BUT
THAT PENCILS OUT TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DOLLARS
A MONTH?
BEFORE TAXES SO IF WE DON'T PUSH
BACK ON CORPORATIONS AND REQUIRE
THEM TO PAY A LIVING WAGE I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE'LL EVER SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM I THINK WE CAN FIND
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I THINK THE GOVERNMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE FORCED TO MAKE
MORE DECISIONS AND BE A BIGGER
PART OF IT.
SO I JUST WANT TO ASK ALL OF US
TO THINK ABOUT THAT AND THINK
ABOUT REAL WAGES AND MANY AND
WITH A LITTLE STORY.
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THERE WAS A YOUNG COUPLE
ALBERTAN CONNIE LEIVA.
WE WORKED FOR ALPHA BETA GROCERY
STORE WE MAY TWELVE DOLLARS AND
FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR AND THAT WAS
THIRTY YEARS AGO I KNOW PEOPLE
TODAY THAT DON'T MAKE TWELVE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR.
WE BOUGHT A BRAND NEW HOUSE FOR
NINETY NINE NINE NINETY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND MY PARENTS ABOUT THEIR BRAND
NEW HOUSE --
PROBABLY TWENTY YEARS EARLIER IT
WAS.
TO WOW DO YOU THINK THAT HOUSES
COULD EVER GET TO BE FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
LIKE NO THAT'S JUST CRAZY TALK.
WELL HERE WE ARE THIRTY YEARS
LATER AND THAT HELPS THAT WE
BOUGHT SELLS FOR FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE.
BACK IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT GAS WAS
NINETY TWO CENTS A GALLON EGGS
WERE SIXTY TWO CENTS A DOZEN SO
NOW THAT HOUSEHOLDS.
FOR FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND EGGS
ARE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE DOLLARS
A DOZEN --
GASES OF ROUGHLY FOUR DOLLARS
WILL UNDER A GALLON SO WHAT
SHOULD THAT GROCERY CLERK BE
MAKING WHO IS MAKING TWELVE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS THIRTY
YEARS AGO. FIFTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
REAL WAGES DON'T RISE THAT
GROCERY CLERK MAKES TWENTY
DOLLARS AND NINETY FIVE CENTS SO
I THINK WE NEVER GET OUT OF THIS
CYCLE.
IF WE DON'T EXPECT REAL WAGES TO
GO UP IF PEOPLE CANNOT PAY FOR
WHATEVER HOUSING WE BUT WE BUILD
IF PEOPLE CANNOT PAY FOR IT.
WHEN I BOTH OF OUR DAUGHTERS
LIVE IN ONTARIO THEY BOTH HAVE
AN APARTMENT ONE PIECE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY A MONTH THE
OTHER IS FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY A MONTH FOR A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT?
AND THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT THEY LIVE WITH THAT HAVE A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT AND IT'S A
WHOLE FAMILY BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO LIVE ON MINIMUM WAGE.
SO I JUST WANT TO SUBMIT THE
INTEL WE REQUIRE LIVING WAGES WE
ARE GOING TO ALWAYS BE IN THIS
SITUATION THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
YOU'RE DOING I APPRECIATE IT --
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING AND
HELP IN ANY WAY I CAN BUT THE
REAL ISSUE TO ME IS A LIVING
WAGE THANK YOU.
YOU MAY.
YEAH.
THAT WAS A POWERFUL IMPORTANT
MESSAGE TO IN --
THIS PANEL ON I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM
THE LA -- OR
FINANCE --
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL YOU'RE WELCOME TO DO SO AS
FOR BEING HERE AND HELPING TO
SET THE FRAMEWORK.
ON THIS CONVERSATION WE
APPRECIATE YOU.
I AM --
GOING TO EXERT MY POWER AS THE
CHAIR YOU ALL --
TO TO DO SOME MANIPULATION OF
OUR AGENDA OUR THIRD PANEL THE
LOCAL PERSPECTIVE RECENT
INVESTMENTS AND FURTHER NEEDS.
THOSE THREE PALLETS OF ALL
TRAVELS FROM OUT OF TOWN --
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE THE
ORDER AND ASK THE THIRD PANEL TO
NOW JOIN US IF YOU WILL.
WE BELIEVE MAYOR TUBS IS ON HIS
WAY -- BUT
AGAIN THIS IS THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
ABOUT RECENT INVESTMENTS.
WHAT'S WORKING AND FURTHER NEEDS.
FROM MISTER AND SELL WHO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HOMELESS
INITIATIVES FOR THAT COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES.
HE'LL BE FOLLOWED BY DOUG SHOE
MAKER WHOSE PRESIDENT OF MERCY
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND WE THANK
YOU MISTER SHOEMAKER.
FOR STEP IN AND PINCH HITTING
WE'D HAD A ANOTHER WITNESS WHO
GOT THE FLU THIS WEEK AS WE
THOUGHT IT BEST THAT.
THEY NOT COME TO THE PUBLIC
HEARING IF YOU GET MY DRIFT I'LL
START UP TO FILL OUR SHOES YES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
TRANSYLVANIAN BLINKING VERY HARD
WITH YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AM DELIGHTED.
TO BE HERE THIS MORNING TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT.
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY MOVEMENT
TO PREVENT AND COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS.
AND IN THAT CONTEXT SURE SOME
REFLECTIONS ON ISSUES FOR YOU
CONSIDER --
IN THE CONTEXT OF DEVELOPING
THAT.
SIR WE HAVE A HOMELESS CRISIS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS OF JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAD.
ABOUT FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
FAMILY MEMBERS IN INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT.
AND THAT CRISIS IS NOT NUDE
EXISTED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WHEN A LOT OF CHANGES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
ASSUMED A COUNTY WIDE LEADERSHIP
ROLE AROUND HOMELESSNESS GOING
WELL BEYOND WHAT IS REQUIRED
LEGALLY --
AND GOING BEYOND --
A ROLE FOR WHICH THE STATE OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES
FUNDING. TO THE COUNTY.
AND SINCE THAT TIME WHEN THE
HOME WAS INITIALLY BEGAN IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE'VE BUILT A POWERFUL COUNTY
WIDE MOVEMENT A TRUE MOVEMENT.
TO PREVENTING COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS.
THE HEART OF THIS MOVEMENT IS
BROAD AND DEEP COLLABORATION
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS.
WELL OVER A HUNDRED COMMUNITY
BASED ON THE SERVICE PROVIDERS.
MORE THAN FORTY CITIES.
FAITH ORGANIZATIONS BUSINESSES
THERE'S WHEN WE BEGAN AN
UNPRECEDENTED COLLECTION OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED INVITED GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY EXPERTS CAME
TOGETHER.
IN THE WINTER OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TO PUT OUR HEARTS AND
OUR MINDS TOGETHER TO DEVELOP A
COORDINATED SET OF FORTY SEVEN
STRATEGIES. TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED A
STRATEGIES ON FEBRUARY NINTH.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND WITH IT
THE APPROVED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME COUNTY
FUNDING.
AND INSTRUCTED US TO WORK WITH
THEM TO PURSUE AN ONGOING SOURCE
OF LOCAL REVENUE.
BECAUSE THE BOARD KNEW THAT IT
WAS LOGICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
SALVO NON GOING PROBLEM WITH ONE
TIME FINDING.
ON THAT SAME DAY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES OF COURSE THE LARGEST
CITY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ON FEBRUARY NINETY THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ADOPTED THE FIRST EVER
LOS ANGELES CITY COVERAGE OF
HOMELESS STRATEGY.
EXEMPLIFYING THE NEW BRIDE AND
DEEP COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
NOW THIS UNPRECEDENTED MOVEMENT
GAVE RISE IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO THEIR
SOMEWHAT MIRACULOUS APPROVAL BY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY VOTERS --
OF A SPECIAL SALES TAX ONE
QUARTER PERCENT. FOR TEN YEARS
LEGALLY DEDICATE HOMELESSNESS
WHICH IS GENERATING AN ESTIMATED
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
I SAY MIRACULOUS BECAUSE THIS
WAS AN OFF YEAR ELECTION THE
FIRST TIME IN MORE.
THAN A HUNDRED YEARS THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY VOTERS HAD EVEN
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO PROVEN REVENUE MEASURE IN AN
OFF YEAR ODD YEAR ELECTION WITH
LOW VOTER TURNOUT.
AND NOT STANDING --
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES SIXTY NINE
POINT 34% OF COUNTY VOTERS
APPROVED MEASURE H..
OUR GOAL IS TO ENABLE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILY MEMBERS IN
INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE FROM
HOMELESSNESS INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS.
WELL ENABLING ADDITIONAL THIRTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES MEMBERS
INDIVIDUALS TO AVOID BECOMING
HOMELESS IN THE SAME TIME PERIOD.
I'M DELIGHTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT IN THE FIRST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF MEASURE AGE.
OVER TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
HOMELESS FAMILY MEMBERS
INDIVIDUALS ENTERED INNER
MASSING IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MOVING FROM BEING.
I'M SHELTERED IN HOMELESS TO
SHELTERED IN HOMELESS IN THAT
EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD.
DURING THAT SAME EIGHTEEN MINES
FROM JULY. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO DECEMBER
200-018-11000 SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN HOMELESS FAMILY MEMBERS
AND INDIVIDUALS MOVED INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING.
WITH MEASURE H. FINDING RENTAL
SUBSIDIES AND OR SERVICES.
SO WE HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
LOCAL MOVEMENT.
I'M HERE TO ANECDOTES JUDGES
CONVEY DE THE BREADTH AND DEPTH
OF THAT.
MOVEMENT BEFORE I MOVE FORWARD.
ON FEBRUARY SEVENTH TWO WEEKS
AGO.
THAT THE AT A MAJOR HOTEL IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE GATHERED FOR THE
THIRD ANNUAL HOMELESS INITIATIVE
CONFERENCE AND WE TURNED AWAY
HUNDREDS MORE.
IT WAS A STANDING ROOM ONLY
CROWD OF FAITH LEADERS CITY
REPRESENTATIVES COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND OTHERS ALTOGETHER
TO REFLECT IN OUR EXPERIENCE.
THROUGH THIS EXTRAORDINARY MOVE
MEN AND TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AHEAD.
THE SECOND ANA JODIE'S EIGHT
BETWEEN MARCH IN MAY OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE CONVENE A
FIFTY MEMBER STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AS DIRECTED BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. TO DEVELOP SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN MEASURE H.
FINDING ACROSS TWENTY ONE
SPECIFIC.
MEASURE EIGHT STRATEGIES ALL OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN COLLABORATIVE
REALLY DIDN'T.
DEVELOPED IN THE INITIAL
HOMELESS INITIATIVE PLANNING
PROCESS.
THOSE FIFTY STAKEHOLDERS FROM
CITIES IN COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS HOW MUCH SERVICE
PROVIDERS FAITH ORGANIZATIONS
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS PHILANTHROPY
AND HE WOULD LIVE EXPERIENCE.
REACHED A CONSENSUS.
I KNOW BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
FINDING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
I CAN SENSE IS MARRIED THEY ANY
ONE OF THOSE FIFTY STAKEHOLDERS
HAD THE AUTHORITY TO BLOCK
CONSENSUS.
AND IF THEY HAD WE WOULD HAVE
GONE TO THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WITH SPLIT RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
THE MAJORITY REPORT.
AND MINORITY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
NOT.
ONE OF THOSE FIFTY STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT CONSENSUS ON THAT FINAL DAY
ON MAY TENTH OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN REACH CONSENSUS ON
OVER BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
FINING RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE WATCH WORDS OF THAT
CONSENSUS PLANNING PROCESS WERE
WIND LISTEN DEEPLY TO EACH OTHER.
AND SECONDLY LEAVE YOUR
ORGANIZATIONAL SELF INTEREST IN
THE ELEVATOR.
AND OUR ABILITY TO REACH
CONSENSUS ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS EXTRAORDINARY
TESTAMENT. TO AN EXTRAORDINARY
MOVEMENT.
NOT WITHSTANDING THIS MOVEMENT
AND THIS UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF
LOCAL REVENUE.
WE DESPERATELY NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THE RESOURCES WE ARE
GENERATING WITH MAJOR AGE ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THE CRISIS WE FACE.
AS I MENTIONED AS OF JANUARY OF
LAST YEAR.
THERE WERE OVER FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHICH REPRESENTED A MODEST 4%
REDUCTION FROM THE YEAR BEFORE
THE FIRST REDUCTION.
IN FOUR YEARS.
I DOUBT THAT SHARE AS THE
STATE'S HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAMMER HEAP FINDING INCLUDED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR BACK J.
WHICH RECEIVED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
FIRE FOR CONTINUING OF CARE AND
ARE TOO LARGE CITIES.
ARE BEING PUT TO USE IN MANY
IMPORTANT WAYS WITH THAT
COMPLIMENTED THE UTILIZING
EASTER MEASURE AGE FUNDING.
AND THE SINGLE BIGGEST WAY IN
WHICH SAYS FANS ARE BEING
UTILIZED CURRENTLY ARE FOR INNER
MOUTH SCENE.
BUT CAPITAL COSTS AND OPERATING
COSTS.
SO IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR LOCAL
EXPERIENCE BOTH WITH THE CURRENT
GROUND IF HE BINDING.
AND THE OUR PRICE A LOCAL
MOVEMENT THAT I'VE DESCRIBED.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE FOR
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE HELP THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL CONSIDER.
AS YOU ADDRESS THE PROVISION.
OF WHY --
HOPEFULLY VERY SUBSTANTIAL ONE
TIME FINDING TO LOCALITIES TO
HELP AS COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
FIRST WE URGE YOU TO MAXIMIZE
THE AMOUNT OF ONE TIME FINDING
THAT YOU PROVIDE.
WE UNDERSTAND THE REDDISH STAINS
TO COMMIT THE STATE TO AN
ONGOING FINING STORES THAT WE
WOULD OF COURSE VERY MUCH LIKE
TO SEE ARE NOT GOING FINING
SHORES.
BUT IF THE ULTIMATE DECISION IS
ONE TIME WE ARE G. MAKE THE ONE
TIME POD AS LARGE AS POSSIBLE.
END TO ALIGN THE LENGTH OF TIME
OVER WHICH THAT FINING CAN BE
USED WITH THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT YOU PROVIDE AND TO ALSO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
THE TIME FRAME FOR THE UTILIZED
ATION OF THE CURRENT HEAT
FINDING. FOR EXAMPLE THE CURRENT
HE FINING OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS EFFECTIVELY
AVAILABLE TO BE USED OVER TWO
FISCAL YEARS AND A LITTLEBIT OF
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
IF FOR EXAMPLE THE ONE TIME
AMOUNT WERE A BILLION DOLLARS IT
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW
THOSE FRIENDS TO BE USED OVER
FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
RATHER NEW TWO YEAR PERIOD THAT
WOULD NOT PRE THEN LOCALITIES
THAT COULD EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE
THE FINDING MORE QUICKLY FROM
DOING CHAU.
BUT WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR A
LONGER TERM.
APPROACH AND ADD THE POTENTIALLY
MAXIMIZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE UTILIZATION OF THAT ONE TIME
STATE FRIEND --
SECONDLY WE WOULD URGE THAT.
ANYONE TIME ST FUNDING FOR
LOCALITIES INCLUDED IN THE FIX
YOUR NINETEEN TWENTY STATE
BUDGET.
BE AVAILABLE FOR RAPID RE
HOUSING AS WELL AS FOR INTERIM
HAS A AND NAVIGATION CENTERS AS
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS A CRITICAL
COMPLIMENTING ROOM HOUSING RAPID
RE HOUSING PROVIDES TIME LIMITED
RENTAL SUBSIDIES OF SIXTY TWENTY
FOUR MINDS WITH INTENSIVE
SERVICES. FOR FAMILIES IN A
DAHLE TO HAVE A GOOD CHANCE OF
GAINING A REGAINING THE ABILITY
TO PAY THEIR OWN RIGHT.
TYPICALLY FOR EMPLOYMENT THOSE
SET IN SOME INSTANCES THROUGH
FEDERAL DISABILITY BENEFITS AS
WELL.
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND RAPID.
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND THE INFUSION OF A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF STATE
FINING THAT COULD ONLY BE USED
FOR IN YOUR MOUTH SEEN.
COULD HAVE THE EFFECT OF
CREATING AN IMBALANCE IN OUR
SYSTEM SIMILAR TO THE IMBALANCE
THAT WOULD RESULT.
IF HOSPITALS INCREASED EMERGENCY
ROOM BEDS BUT DDN'T INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF BEDS FOR PEOPLE TO
GO FROM THE EMERGENCY ROOMS IN
OTHER WORDS EXPANDING
INTERMETALLIC ZINE WITHOUT
EXPANDING.
RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO PAY FOR
PERMANENT HOUSING HAS THE EFFECT
AS INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE LIVING IN SHELTER.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO
MOVE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
LEADING THEIR TO BE BOTH AN
ACCUMULATION OF THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN SHELTER.
AND NO REDUCTION OVERTIME IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE STREET
BECAUSE THEIR PEOPLE TODAY ON
THE STREET COULD MOVE AND IN OUR
MAGAZINE.
PEOPLE WHO ENTER HOMELESSNESS
TOMORROW OR NEXT WEEK OR NEXT
MONTH WOULD HAVE NOWHERE TO GO
SO WE URGE THAT THERE BE
FLEXIBILITY.
IN BALANCING INNER AND HAS SEEN
AND RAPID RE HOUSING WITH ANYONE
TIME STATE FUNDING.
THIRDLY WE WOULD URGE THE ANY
NEW STATE FUNDING BE ALLOCATED
GEOGRAPHICALLY BASED ON NEED.
IN RE AS REFLECTED IN THE ANNUAL
HOMELESS COUNT.
WEEK KNOWLEDGE THAT SMALL
COUNTIES.
OFTEN NEED IN A STATE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY SEPARATE TREATMENT
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE --
AND NOW DEFINING THEY CAN BE
MEANINGFUL UTILIZED BUT ONCE A
BASE LEVEL OF FINDING IS MATT.
FOUR SMALL COUNTIES WE ARE
THEY'RE FINDING BE ALLOCATED
PROPORTIONATE TO NEED.
AND THEN FINALLY.
THE CURRENT HEAP AT FINDING
CARRIED WITH IT A REQUIREMENT.
FOR CITIES TO ADOPT EMERGENCY
SHELTER DECLARATIONS.
IN ORDER FOR THERE TO BE NO
RESTRICTIONS ON THE UTILIZATION
OF STEEP OF HEAT FINDING WITH IN
THOSE CITIES. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SEEK TO ESTABLISH
ANY REQUIREMENTS FOR CITIES.
THAT WOULD IMPACT THE
UTILIZATION OF A NEW ROUND OF
ONE TIME STATE FUNDING.
WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE MINISTRATION
ADOPT A MENU OF OPTIONS THAT
CITIES COULD COMPLY WITH.
IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE
MEANINGFULLY IN COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
CITIES BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
CITIES HAVE A CRITICAL ROLE TO
PLAY.
AROUND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LAND USE AND HOUSING HOUSING
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE CITIES
THAT ADMINISTER THEIR OWN PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
AND RECENTLY FORTY ONE CITIES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY COMPLETED
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND PAGES OF
CITY SPECIFIC HOMELESSNESS PLANS
WITH PLANNING GRANTS.
PROVIDED BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND THROUGH THOSE FORTY ONE CITY
SPECIFIC HOMELESSNESS PLANS
CITIES CAME FORWARD WITH THE
RANGE OF CREATIVE AND VERY
HELPFUL ACTIONS WHICH THEY
INTEND TO TAKE.
TICU AS PART OF THE COUNTY
WIDE MOVEMENT TO PREVENTING
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN DRYING ON THE
IDEAS PUT FORWARD BY CITIES IN
LOS ANGELES CAN YOU.
HAVE ACTIONS FROM WHICH CITIES
COULD CHOOSE IN ORDER TO
ELIMINATE.
ANY RESTRICTIONS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE APPLY TO THE
UTILIZATION OF THE FUTURE ROUND
OF ONE TIME STATE FINDING --
I ONE TIME STATE FUNDING WITHIN
THOSE CITIES.
LET ME JUST CLOSE IF YOU'LL
ALLOW ME IN SHARING WITH YOU A
QUOTE.
THAT I FREQUENTLY USE IN
SPEAKING TO THE LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
WHO ARE PART OF THIS MOVEMENT?
THE BUDDHIST SID THAT A SINGLE
CANDLE CAN LIGHT A THOUSAND
OTHERS WITHOUT DIMINISHING
ITSELF.
AND WHAT WE FIND IN THIS
MOVEMENT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS THAT.
NEW CANDLES ARE BEING LATE EVERY
DAY.
AS MORE MORE INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS JOIN THIS MOVEMENT
AND THE SAME PASSION THAT YOU
DEMONSTRATED TODAY.
AROUND BRINGING ARE HOMELESS
NEIGHBOR'S HOME HE SHARED BY
PEOPLE THROUGH AN ORGANIZATION%
SALAS ANGELES COUNTY BECAUSE
UNIQUELY IN MY EXPERIENCE.
EVERY HUMAN BEING.
CARES ABOUT HOMELESSNESS.
AND NO ONE IS FOR IT.
AND THAT COMMON GROUND GIVES US
THE ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER.
THE STATE [inaudible]
THE COUNTY.
CITIES AT ALL OF OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO BRING OUR HOMELESS
NUMBERS ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES TO GET A HOLD OUR
QUESTIONS TO THE IN THE PANEL
AND WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION BACK
TO BUY A WHOLE WIRE
AFFECTIONATELY REFERRED TO AS MY
MAYOR.
ALTHOUGH I HAVE NEVER RESIDED IN
YOUR GREAT CITY BUT WELCOME
MAYOR TAPS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR PERSPECTIVE --
THANK YOU MANAGEMENT MADAM CHAIR
AND AND AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SOME.
BOBBI BRIEFER I PERSONALLY WANT
TO MAKE THIS PRESENTATION MYSELF
FOR FOR A COUPLE REASONS OF A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO I WOKE UP AT
SIX AM WITH ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TO A
POINT IN TIME HOMELESSNESS COUNT.
ON IT'S ONE THING TO READ ABOUT
AND HEAR ABOUT IT BUT ACTUALLY
CLIMBING UP INTO THE OVERPASSES
ADMIN BARKED AT BY PIT BULLS WHO
WERE TRAINED IN.
SEEING FOLKS LIVING IN TENTS AND
LIVING IN CHILDREN AND FIT FOR
HUMAN BEINGS CAUSED ME TO
QUESTION WHAT WAS I DOING ON TO
LIVE UP TO MY SPOUSE VALUES IN
TALKING ABOUT THE DIGNITY
INHERENT DIGNITY --
OF OF EVERY HUMAN BEING AND I
THINK ESPECIALLYFOR CALIFORNIA.
OF AS A GOLDEN STATE AS THE SIDE
THE RESISTANCE I DON'T THINK WE
CAN BE HAT IF THE MOST
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE OUR
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE FOLKS ARE
EXPERIENCING THE BRIGHT.
AS A FORTY BUILDING HOUSING
CRISIS FOR EVERY ISSUE I THINK
OF MY LGBT YOUTH.
OR OFTENTIMES KICKED OUT OF
THEIR HOMES ARE HOMELESS I THINK
OF WOMEN FLEEING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I THINK OF STUDENTS I TAUGHT WHO
TOLD THEM THEY WORK HARD IF THEY
DO EVERYTHING RIGHT THEY CAN GO
TO COLLEGE.
ARE IN COLLEGE NUMBER HOMELESS I
THINK OF SINGLE MOTHERS LIKE MY
MOTHER I THINK OF WHO WERE LIVE
DRIVERS I I THINK OF CHILDREN
WHO DO NOT KNOW FATHER OWN.
OF OUR LIVING IN TENTS AND WE
STILL EXPECT OVER THE SCHOOL IN
EITHER EVERYDAY THAT SO YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO MAKE THIS
PRESENTATION MYSELF.
ON BECAUSE AS YOU ALL KNOW IT'S
A CRISIS.
IS ACROSS OF EPIDEMIC
PROPORTIONS AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
CHEN ZONING WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT BUILDINGS WERE NOT
JUST HER WHAT CONSTRUCTION WE'RE
TALKING OR WHAT TOPIC COMMUNITY
WHAT TYPE OF SOCIETY WOULD HAVE
A STATE WE WENT LIVE IN.
OR TALK ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS ON A
IN IN THEIR INHERENT DIGNITY.
I'M ACCORDING TO HIDE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STOCKTON AND
AND TERMS OF URBAN CITIES NOT
THE MARCY'S BUT URBAN CITIES
HAVE MORE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
PER CAPITA.
AND FOR ME AS MAYOR THAT THAT'S
AN ISSUE.
ON THE MEDIAN INCOME IN STOCKTON
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTIES ABOUT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS
THAN THE RATE REST OF THE STATE.
OF THE PAST YEAR WE'VE HAD WHEN
THE FACETS RISING RATE MARKETS
IN IN IN IN THIS COUNTRY --
APPARENTLY EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
CANNOT FIND HOUSING TODAY ALMOND
IN MY CITY.
AND IN THE END I ITEMS FOCUSING
ON STOCKTON BUT AS YOU ARE THOSE
ARE JUST THE STOCK IN THE SURE
SAKE COUNTY ISSUE THE STATE
ISSUE.
ONSITE YOU WENT OFF AS A THANK
YOU OFFER LEADERSHIP YOU GUYS
HAVE SHOWN.
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS OUR
MENTORS ALLOCATIONS OF EXCITED
THIS YEAR THAT'S OCT IS NOW
PARTY BIG MAYOR'S BIG CITY
COALITION SO WE'LL HAVE SOME
KEEP FINDING TO REALLY BEGIN. TO
HOUSE A WORK OF ART IT'S ME OVER
CARE TOUCH OUR INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR COMMUNITY --
OUR OUR HOUSE I I FOUND OUT THIS
AND EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH --
BUT 50% OF OUR FOLKS LIVE WORK
ON MINIMUM WAGE JOBS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY NOT US FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR I'VE LEARNED --
RECENTLY THAT STOCKTON IS NUMBER
THIRD IN THE NATION AMONG LARGE
URBAN CEO SEES FOR THE NUMBER
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND AGAIN NUMBER ONE
THE MONTHS LARGELY URBAN FEEL
FEES. FOR THE NUMBERS ARE PERSON
EXPERIENCING FAMILY HOMELESSNESS
AND IN IN IN IN THE MIDST OF
THIS CRISIS WERE NOT JUST
STANDING AROUND AND DOING
NOTHING WE'RE DOING ALL WE CAN
WITH THE MEAGER RESOURCES WE
HAVE SO WE'VE ALLOCATED TO
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
COMPRESSES DOLLARS TO TO HOUSING
TO THE CLEAN UPS WE PARTNER WITH
CAL.
ON TO FOCUS AND TARGET SOME
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO CONNECT THEM
WITH JOBS AND AND AND AND
SERVICES.
ARE WE'VE CREATE A HOUSING
MITIGATION FUND TO TRY ENTICE
LANDLORDS TO TAKE SOME THE DIFF
VOUCHERS AND THINGS PROVIDED FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE HOMELESS WE'RE VERY
ACTIVE IN OUR CONSUMER CARE OF
THE SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS WE
RECEIVED A ONE TIME HE PLANS
LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO HOUSE?
FOLKS IN PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
THE HOUSING AUTHORITY IN THE
SHELTER AND LOW INCOME HOUSING
PROVIDERS WITH OUR COMMUNITY
MEDICAL CLINICS WITH.
MOVEMENT SOCIAL SERVICES AND IN
WITH THEM.
AND INNOVATIVE FORM CALLED READY
TO WORK I'M REALLY THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX ABOUT HOW THE
ATTACK THIS ISSUE OF HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IN HOMELESSNESS.
MEANS UNDERSTANDING THAT HOUSING
IS DEFINITELY FROM THE MIDDLE
AND WE'RE MOVING.
ON THAT'S BECAUSE I LIKE TO WERE
MOVING TOWARDS A HOUSING FIRST
APPROACH BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT FOLKS THE JOBS FOLK THINGS
OPPORTUNITY --
EIGHT EIGHT X. CETERA.
BUT WITH THE SEVEN ARE HE BALLOT
CATION OF COURSE THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE RESOURCES DON'T MEET
THE NEEDS ARE BUDGET GREAT
PROJECTS WE WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
FIND THIS PAST YEAR.
BY PROVIDING HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT
COUNSELING TALKING ON JOB
COUNSELLING AND ANGIE THE
COMPLETION NOT BECAUSE IT WASN'T
IMPORTANT.
THAT BECAUSE IT WAS A PRIORITY
NOT BECAUSE WHEN THEY HELP THIS
EPIDEMIC WERE FACING BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T HAVE A AND THE FREE
SOURCES WE WEREN'T ABLE. TO
FURTHER SINCE OF AYE LOW INCOME
HOUSING CORPORATION WHICH WILL
ALLOW THEM A FOUR TIME HOUSING
NAVIGATOR IN WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM TO TARGET
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGHER IN THE
AIR AND MEDIAN INCOME.
WHICH NOT OTHERWISE ALLOW WITH
FEDERAL DOLLARS AGAIN WE YOU
IT'S GOOD PROJECT AT THIS
HEARTBREAKING THE WITH A
RESOURCE TO BE HAD WHEREVER THE
FIGHT WE WEREN'T ABLE --
TO TO FIND THAT SO I THINK THE
ASK FOR FOR THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK YOU ARE DOING
AND THAT YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN HERE
SINCE EARLY THIS MORNING TALK
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
I KNOW MANY OF YOU ON THIS CAN
BE DONE JUST TALK YES YOU DO
ACTION SOME OF THE FIRST SAID
MAYOR STOCK AND I STAND.
BY EVERYTHING A BUNCH OF MERS
WERE EXCITED ABOUT WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ENSURING THAT WE
SHOW THAT THE GOLDEN STATE IS
ACTUALLY TRULY A GOLDEN STATE
FOR ALL I I STRUGGLE WITH THIS
IDEA.
OF CALIFORNIA BEING AGAIN THIS
IN YOUR THE RESISTANCE IF POOR
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE WORK
AND A STATE.
I STRUGGLE WITH THIS IDEA THAT
WERE REVOLUTIONARY AND
STOCKPILING A BASIC INCOME WHEN
FOLKS WHO BENEFIT THE MOST FROM
BASIC INCOME CAN'T CAN'T CAN'T
CAN'T CAN'T AFFORD RENT.
I I STRUGGLE WITH THIS WITH THIS
IDEA THAT THAT EVERYTHING'S
GREAT AND SUNNY THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS BE PRAGUE OF BUT
AGAIN THE FOLKS I REPRESENT
FOLKS FROM THE COMMUNITY
ACTUALLYCOME FROM.
MY OWN FAMILY MEMBERS MY MOTHER
ACCEPTED A CONSULAR CALLING IN
SAYING WHAT ARE YOU DOING ABOUT
HOUSING TO RENT KEEPS RISING THE
RENT IS TOO DAMN HIGH AND WHAT'S
THE PLAN A STRATEGY --
FOR FOR ROUTING ADDRESSING IT SO
SOME THE IDEAS WE'VE HEARD THIS
MEET FROM THE FUNDING SHORTFALLS
WI FI I'M TRYING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE --
I THINK TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
FOR FOR A HOUSING PROJECTS OR
SOMETHING --
MANY CITIES IN CONSUMER CARE TO
BE VERY INTERESTED IN --
I THINK OTHER STATE AGENCY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERSHIPS
BUT THE WINNER TO MAKE CALTRANS
COULD BE HUGE SPACE WITH ALL THE
STATE OWNED LAND.
ON THAT'S OFTENTIMES BAKING AND
USED OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK
ALMONDS SOCCER MATCHES UNDER
UNDER PASSES BUT OUR FAIRGROUNDS
EXETER THERE'S PLACES WHERE WE
COULD DO SOME REALLY COOL WORK
AROUND PERMITS SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
AND HOUSING FIRST FOR FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND I THINK.
I'M GLAD THIS COMMITTEES TALKING
ABOUT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE AS YOU ALL
KNOW THEY'RE RELATED AS THE LA --
REPORT TOLD US THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE INTERTWINED BUT
THEY'RE DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS AND
AGAIN PRODUCTIONS NOT NOT SIMPLY
ENOUGH WE COULD BUILD ALL THE
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND OUR HOMES
AND ONE IN STOCKTON BECAUSE SOME
CISCO SACRAMENTO'S CAN MORE
EXPENSIVE HE WILL COME BY ON
THAT DOES NOTHING. FOR THAT
MAINTENANCE WORKER THAT DOES
NOTHING FOR THE JANET AT THIS
NOTHING OFFER A LOT OF FOLKS MY
COMMUNITY SO REALLY FIGURED OUT
HOW DO YOU BUILD.
HOUSING BUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND AND WHEN THE THINGS I SAY IN
STOCK ALL THE TIME MADAM CHAIR
IS IF YOU HATE HOMELESSNESS YOU
NOW LOVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IF YOU A HOMELESS THIS YOU WERE
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATE
WE WE WANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EVERYWHERE.
BECAUSE IN OUR SEIZE BECOME TO
THE POINT WHERE WE'RE
HOMELESSNESS THIS JOB IN THE
COUNTY HE'S FOR THIS WITH
AMAZING WORK.
LEADING R. C. O. C. NOT ALSO SAY
I'M FOR COMMUNITIES MORE RURAL
COMMUNITY SMALLER COMMUNITIES
THERE MIGHT EVEN BE THE
TECHNICAL THE EXPERTISE OF THE
CAPACITY TO DO SO THESE COMPLEX
THINGS SO I THINK IF HE CAN GO.
FROM THE RULES CITY SOME IN THE
CALIFORNIA CITY CENTRAL VALLEY
CITIES MAYBE SOME HELP AND CAN
PEOPLE UP TO DATE ABOUT WHAT IS
HOUSING FIRST HOW DO YOU DO IT
HOW YOU USE THAT FOR AN UC'S
TOOLS COLLECTED PASSED YOU MAY
NOT BE THERE AND AND THEN SOME
FOLKS.
THE BILL THE MORE TENSE.
ARM IT IS IS A SOLUTION FOR FOR
HOUSING THE FORTY TO THE
HOMELESSNESS AND IT FIT EXACTLY
EXACTLY CENTURY THEY SIMPLY.
IS NOT BUT I THINK WHAT WE SEE
IN THAT THAT FOLKS JUST WANT US
TO DO SOMETHING.
RYAN TO BE EASY FOR ME TO SAY
THAT BY FIFTY NEW TENANTS PUT
HIM OVER HERE AND I COULD GET A
GOOD PRICE FOR A DAY.
BUT UNTIL WE WORK WITH YOU ALL
WITH OUR COUNTY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO YOU BUILD MORE HOUSING
CRITICALLY HOW TO BUILD A FOUR
HOUSING HOW TO BE LOVED FOREVER
HOUSING HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE
THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE OUR STATE
GREAT.
THE FOLKS WHO DO ALL THE JOBS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO DO.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO TO
REFRAIN CONTINUE TO PROSPER AND
ROSE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORKING LEADERSHIP I'M HERE TO
PARTNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS THE
MAYOR AND I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE TENSE ARE FOR CAMPING
NOT RAISING CHILDREN AND ARE
GROWING OLD IN.
AND WEEKLY NOT IN THIS COLD
pAND IF YOU.
COULD STAY WITH US FOR A MINUTE
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
LAST WITH THIS AND WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SHOEMAKER THANK
YOU THANKS THANKS FOR THE TIME
TIRED OF ALL THE MAYOR THAT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE SOMETHING IT'S
VERY EASY TO DO.
BUT THIS WAY BECAUSE TIME --
I'M DOUG TO MAKE ON THE
PRESIDENT MERCY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO HERE AS IT
IS ON PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS --
SOME OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
MERCY HOUSING SOME NOT --
WE'RE A NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPER WE WORK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
I'M READING IN ROSEVILLE TO THE
BAY AREA DOWN TO SAN DIEGO AND
LOS ANGELES IN BAKERSFIELD.
OR ACTIVE IN ABOUT TEN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE --
WERE SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL IN THAT WE
DEVELOP BOTH FAMILY HOUSING
SENIOR HOUSING AND WHERE ONE OF
THE LARGEST SUPPORTIVE HOUSING --
DEVELOPERS AND PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
SO WE SORT OF BRING A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE I THINK TO THE WORK
AND WORK WITH MANY GREAT
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE STATE
AND I THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST I
JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK --
I'VE BEEN IN THIS FIELD FROM WAS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
I THINK I'VE NEVER BEEN IN A
MOMENT WHERE THERE'S BEEN SUCH
CLEAR LEADERSHIP AT THE STATE
LEVEL IN TERMS OF WANTING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE ON THIS.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S DUE TO THE FACT
THAT WE'VE DUG OURSELVES A HOLE
THAT IS BIGGER THAN ANY THAT
I'VE EVER EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFE
AND I'M.
HOPEFULLY ANY MY KIDS LIVES --
SO IT'S BOTH GOOD NEWS AND BAD
FOCUSED ON THIS --
AS MANY PEOPLE OF ALLUDED TO
WE'VE GOT MASSIVE ISSUES AND YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S COR ADDS IT COMES
DOWN TO A FEW THINGS --
ONE OF WHICH IS IS THE ABSOLUTE
SHORTAGE.
OF OF HOMES THAT ARE AFFORDABLE
THE LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FOLKS ANYTHING UNLESS WE GET TO
THAT.
BASIC CORE CONCEPT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO REALLY SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS ON I'M HAPPY THAT SO
MUCH OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON PRODUCTION.
AND I WANT TO JUST COMPLEMENT
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE GREAT
WORK THAT HAPPENED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS IN TERMS TO HEAP.
AND SB TO AND ARE GREAT WORK
WITH MANY OF YOU AROUND THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION ONE AND
TWO WERE EAGER TO GET THAT MONEY
OUT THE DOOR --
I KNOW FOLKS HAVE TALKED ABOUT
WILL GOSH WE'VE GOT SO MUCH
MONEY FLOWING OUT WE POSSIBLY
NEED MORE COMING OUT OF THE
STATE BUDGET.
I CAN JUST TELL YOU THAT WE WE
WE WORK IN A BIZARRE FIELD IN
WHICH WE RATION OUT.
YOU KNOW A DOLLAR A YEAR. TO A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND WE ACT
AS IF.
BY GIVING OUT SMALL AMOUNTS
EVERY YEAR WE'RE GONNA DO
SOMETHING WE'RE TREADING WATER
AT BEST.
AND IT'S BEEN A LOT WORSE IN
RECENT YEARS.
WE SORT OF CHOOSE BETWEEN WHICH
OF THE DIFFERENT HOUSING
PROBLEMS WERE TRYING TO SOLVE OR
RESOVE IN HOMELESSNESS.
ARE WE SOLVING THE PROBLEM FOR
THE MINIMUM WAGE WORKER WE SOLVE
THE PROBLEM FOR THE SENIOR --
WE OBVIOUSLY ARE NOT GOING TO
SUCCEED AS A STATE LESS WE DO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS AT ONCE --
AND WE'RE NOWHERE CLOSE TO DOING
THAT AT THE MOMENT I I WILL SAY
I THINK THERE'S A TON OF THINGS
IN THIS BUDGET.
BETTER FANTASTIC THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS US A JUST
BRIEFLY MENTION THAT I THINK
THAT.
THE FOCUS ON THE FLEXIBLE
OPERATING SUBSIDY POOL IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PROPOSAL AND WE
DO WORK AND IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I THINK.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION IN
THE STATE AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
IN THE COUNTRY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A MORE WELL
ORGANIZED APPROACH THAT THIS
WORK AND IF OTHER COUNTIES IN
THE STATE COULD COPY WHAT LOS
ANGELES IS DOING.
AND THEY COULD USE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO MIMIC
WHAT IS BEING DONE AND THE STATE
COULD SOUND REINFORCE.
THE NEED TO DO THAT IT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT --
THE ANALOGY SOMEBODY MADE FROM
THE OTHER DAYS LOS ANGELES IS A
BIT LIKE GOING INTO AN APPLE
STORE YOU WALK IN.
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE A
HOUSING DEVELOPER AND YOU WANT
DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT AS IN
THERE'S SUBSIDY FOR RENTS.
THERE'S MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS CASE MANAGERS FROM EASY.
BUT IT'S ALL TOGETHER IN
CONTRAST MANY OF THE ECONOMY
THAT WE WORK AND GREAT LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS GREAT
APPOINTED STAFF.
BUT YOU REALLY GOING TO A
NINETEEN EIGHTIES YOU KNOW
TECHNOLOGY STORE WHICH THEY SAY
I DON'T KNOW THE CPU MICHAEL
WITH THIS MODEM I REALLY DON'T
KNOW.
AND YOU SORT OF END UP GOING
DOOR TO DOOR TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CONNECT ALL THE DOTS.
THAT OUGHT TO BE CONNECTED
PROBLEMATICALLY AND SO I THINK
AS YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT YOU'RE USING I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
PRICKLY THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S BEING DELIVERED AS
AN INCENTIVE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT YOU YOU DO MORE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT BECOMES A
LITTLE BIT MORE LIKE THE APPLE
STORE THAT IS LOS ANGELES AND A
LITTLE BIT LESS LIKE CRAZY
EDDIE'S OR WHATEVER WHATEVER
YOUR ANALOGY MY DAY --
I'M NOT I'M NOT SAYING THAT I
JUST WANT TO SAY I DO THINK THAT
THAT THAT POOL OF FUNDS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE WORK WITH AND MANY
AMAZING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT IT IS NOT
UNUSUAL WHEN I TALK TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO YOUR ABOUT HUNDRED
THOUSAND HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN IMPACT FEES.
FOUR INDIVIDUAL UNITS OF HOUSING
SO WHEN YOU'RE BUILDING A GIANT.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED UNIT OR TWO
HUNDRED UNIT OF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LOCAL JURISDICTION
EFFECTIVELY [inaudible]
WASHING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MONEY. TO PAY
FOR ALL THESE OTHER THINGS AND I
DON'T THINK IS A STATE WE CAN
AFFORD THAT ANYMORE --
I WOULD REALLY LOVE TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES INACTION IN
THAT REGARD AND I THINK THAT
FIGHTER MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCENTIVES --
MIGHT BE A PLACE FOR YOU TO
THINK ABOUT WHERE YOU WOULD
APPLY THAT AND WHERE THAT WOULD
GO O COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY.
DO SOMETHING TO EITHER REDUCE OR
WAIVE THOSE FEES I THINK WOULD
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF GOVERNMENTAL BEHAVIOR.
MAKES A LITTLE BIT LESS
DIFFICULT FOR US TO EXPLAIN TO
VOTERS YOU DON'T REALIZE THAT.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY PAYING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PARKING
SCHOOL FEES WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOLLARS.
SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING I'D RECOMMEND ON THE
ON THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS --
FOR NEW STATE TAX CREDITS THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE WERE VERY EXCITED ONE
ECHO THE COMMENTS PLEASE PUT AS
MUCH MONEY. ONE TIME AS YOU CAN
INTO THIS BUDGET IF YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU CAN'T KEEP THINGS --
OBVIOUSLY WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE
STATE TAX CREDIT RECORD THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT IS IN
MANY WAYS THE BACKBONE.
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
ENTITIES IN PRACTICALLY EVERY
PROJECT IS BUILT AROUND THE
STATE --
IT'S WE HAVE ABOUT THREE THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED UNITS IN
DEVELOPMENT AROUND THE AROUND
THE STATE ABOUT TEN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT EVERYONE OF
THOSE INVOLVED ALONG CANALS AND
TAX CREDIT AS ITS CORE FINANCE
AND IF THERE WERE MORE OF IT WE
WOULD BE BUILDING ARE PROJECTS
FASTER AND WE DELIVERING.
HOMES TO PEOPLE THAT NEED IT ONE
THING I I DO WANT TO SAY IS --
YOU KNOW IT'S THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE SEEN AN EMPHASIS ON THE
MODERN INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
IN THAT STATE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
I KNOW I SPEAK FOR A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN SAYING I THINK
THAT'S THE TIME HAS COME TO DO
THAT KIND OF WORK AND I THINK
IT'S IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT MOVE
FORWARD ON THAT.
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT IT IS.
TO EIGHT THERE'S NO REASON THE
PROGRAM COULDN'T JUST THAT AND
I'M PROGRAM WHICH I THINK WOULD
BE A DISSERVICE TO ALL OF THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
SO I'M SURE THAT --
MARINO WHINER RAY PEARL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK ON
THAT.
AS YOU GET TO IT --
THIRTY THERE MANY OTHER THINGS I
WANTED TO SPEAK TO I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON ON THE
FACT THAT ON THE THE THE
CHALLENGE WE REALLY HAVE IS A
STATE.
IS THAT. FOR EVERY PERSON THAT
MERCY HOUSING OR THE CITY LOS-ANGELES OR THE CITY STOCKTON.
GETS OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
WE'VE GOT TWO MORE PEOPLE
FALLING IN BECAUSE THAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE SO SEVERE --
AND I THINK WE WANT TO CAUTION I
THINK A LITTLE BIT AROUND
RUSHING TO THE SCENE OF THE FIRE.
AND NOT INVOLVING OURSELVES IN
FIRE PREVENTION --
AND I THINK I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW IS THE STATE
AND I THINK CENTER SKINNER FOR
TO THIS EARLIER.
WHEN SHE TALKED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AS A AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR SOME OF
THE OTHER WORKERS ARE IN THE
STATE?
WE WE SIMPLY HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT PEOPLE ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS.
MUCH FASTER THAN WE'RE GETTING
THEM OUT.
AND SO WE CAN'T SIMPLY AND WE'RE
A PERMANENT SO KLAY FOCUS ON
PERMITS FOR BOUGHS AND WHAT WE
SEE IN THE STATE IS THAT WE
ALMOST ROUTINELY IGNORE.
EXTREMELY LOW AND VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE NOT
IN THE SPECIALTY POPULATIONS
WHEN WE RUN. TO THE TO THE NEW
TO THE NEW CRISIS OF THE DAY.
AND WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT I I WOULD JUST TELL YOU
THAT THERE IS A REAL
[inaudible]
SHOCKING --
LACK OF FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE THIS MASSIVE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGE OF SENIORS YOU'RE ALL
AWARE THAT NOBODY HAS TO TELL
YOU WHAT THE BABY BOOM AS OF
THAT THE RETIRING --
BUT WE HAVE ALMOST NOTHING
HAPPENING IN A CONCERTED WAY IN
TERMS OF FEDERAL OR STATE POLICY
TO ADDRESS.
THE FACT WE HAVE SO MANY SENIORS
WHO ARE.
ARE ON THE EDGE OF HOMELESSNESS
AND FALLING ALMOST AS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER SENIORS ARE
IN FACT THE FASTEST GROWING PART
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION BUT
THEY'RE CERTAINLY AMONG THEM --
AND THERE'S GOING TO GROW BIGGER
AND IT'S GOING TO GROW BIGGER
BECAUSE WE ARE REALLY NOT TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING SPECIFIC AROUND
SENIOR HOUSING.
LASTLY I JUST WANNA.
I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH A STORY
I USED TO BE THE HOUSING RECTOR
OF SAN FRANCISCO UNDER NOW GET
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME OF WHEN HE
WAS MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
REMEMBER BEING CALLED OUT --
WHEN THE PICO GROUPS AND IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAS BEEN A MEETING AT
ST ANTHONY'S CHURCH AND THE
MISSION DISTRICT?
AND IT WAS A GROUP OF LARGE
LATINO HOUSEHOLDS.
AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
HOMELESSNESS PREFERENCE THAT WE
HAD PUT ON A NEW BUILDING --
AND HOW IT WAS SPECIFICALLY FOR
P. HOMELESS.
AND THIS WOMAN TURNED TO ME AND
SHE SAID LOOK.
I SLEEP IN A ONE BEDROOM UNIT
WITH MY SON AND MY DAUGHTER.
I AM NOT THROWN MYSELF ON THE
STREET I'M NOT THROW MYSELF IN A
SHELTER.
I'VE DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT.
I WORK IN A REALLY HARD JOB AND
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT I'M
EXCLUDED FROM HAVING A SHOT AT
THIS HOUSING.
BECAUSE I'M DOING ALL THE RIGHT
THINGS [inaudible]
AND YEAH I MEAN YOU COULD TELL
THAT THAT WAS A AN INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL MOMENT FOR ME
PERSONALLY --
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN SAY%
ABOUT THAT YOU JUST RECOGNIZE
THE INHERENT LACK OF WISDOM OF
YOUR OWN OF YOUR OWN POLICY
MAKING AT THAT MOMENT --
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE WORKING ON A
SYSTEM A SCARCITY --
AND IF WE WERE WORKING THE
SYSTEM A SCARCITY I WOULDN'T OF
HAD TO FACE THAT WOMAN DOWN AND
SAY I GOT TO CHOOSE BETWEEN.
THIS CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL IT'S COSTING A
HOSPITAL A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AND YOU WHO
AREN'T --
BUT THAT'S THE DILEMMA WE FIND
OURSELVES IN A STATE AND I THINK
IF THIS BUDGET MOVES FORWARD AND
CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK.
THAT YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO RIGHT THE LEGISLATURE WE
WON'T HAVE TO FACE AS MANY OF
THOSE CHOICES IN THE FUTURE.
SO I REALLY GREATLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO FIND AS MUCH
OF THIS WORK IS YOU CAN DO.
ENCOURAGE MUCH OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND WITH THAT
INCENTIVE FUND SO THANK YOU.
THANKS TO ALL THROUGH WITH YOU
FOR VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONY AYE
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE MAYOR
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE A A TIME.
RESTRICTION --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE LA --
DOCTOR THAT WAS PROVIDED TO US
TODAY BUT ON THE FINAL PAGE PAGE
NINE THEY GAVE US A SHEET --
THAT'S AND TITLE CONVERSATIONS
ON HOUSING HOMELESSNESS AND IT
REALLY IS JUST KIND OF SOME
BULLETS IN TERMS OF AREAS --
THAT THEY SUGGESTED WE SHOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT AND AND IS
MORALITY KNOWLEDGE THAT MANY OF
THEM ARE HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL --
REFORMING LOCAL ZONING LAWS
ALTERED ALLOCATION OF LOCAL
TAXES AND FOR MORNING IF YOU
WOULD JUST COMMENT --
FROM A LOCAL LEADERS PERSPECTIVE --
THERE'S BEEN A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED HERE --
THAT AT LEAST IN MY DISTRICT WAS
NOT RECEIVED WARMLY --
THAT GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
AND HAVE A MORE DIRECT OVERSIGHT
OVER LOCAL ZONING SO WHAT WHAT
SAY YOU.
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT WILL ALSO BE FOR FOR
STOCKTON AND START --
BECAUSE I DO THINK TO TO THE
POINT LA --
REPORT TALKED ABOUT A LOT OF THE
LOCAL ZONING LAWS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT --
FOR LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACTUALLY SOMETIMES THAT SO MUCH
AND STOCKTON BACK AT SEEING
OTHER COMMITTEES TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND ALLOW ZONING FOR FOUR
FOUR MILES AND SO I DO THINK.
GIVEN THE CRISIS WERE FACING IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
STEP THE STATE TO STEP IN --
I THINK SOME OF THE THINGS THE
GOVERNOR IS DOING IN TERMS OF
USING A STAKE IN SOME CASES WITH
CITIES TO COMPEL THEM THE BILL.
TO THE CAN JUST BE A COUPLE
CITIES.
WHO HAVE IN MY TWO LEADERS OR
WHATEVER WHO TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PERHAPS EVERY CITY EVERY
CITY EXCUSE ME HAVE TO PULL?
THEIR OWN WAYS ARE FROM THE
LOCAL LEVEL I THINK.
WE WE WE APPRECIATE A TIMING
ABILITY TO MOVE AND I THINK THAT
THERE INCREASING OUR CASES OF
DOLLARS TO HELP US MAKE PRODUCTS
PENCIL OUT MAKES IT MUCH MORE
EASIER.
ON TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH CONSTITUENTS BY THINK.
NOT JUST IN FROM A LOCAL LEVEL
BY THE STATE WE HAVE TO SOME OF
ITS FOR STRIKING TO ME HOW
OFTENTIMES THE ZONING LAWS
HISTORICALLY AND CURRENTLY HAVE
BEEN USED TO DISENFRANCHISE IN
MARCH RIGHT.
POOR PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR
EXCEPT DURING I THINK AT THE
STATE WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AS WELL
THAT IT'S IN POINTS HAVE LOCAL
CONTROL LOCAL AUTONOMY.
ON BUT BUT THERE THERE IS AN
ISSUE WHEN I LOOK WHICH ARE A
LOCAL ATTORNEY IS A POLICY WALL.
IF YOU WILL THAT THE BLOCKS AND
LEAVE THE SOME PEOPLE OUT.
THANK YOU AND I AND I CAN I
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS WE'RE ALL
GOING TO DO THINGS VERY
DIFFERENTLY AND AND MAKE IT
REALLY TOUGH PERHAPS YOU KNOW
POLITICALLY.
DICEY DECISIONS CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR BASIC
INCOME PROJECT THAT YOU'RE DOING
AND STOCKED IN AN AND IT BECAUSE
I THINK ABOUT IT AS A OUT OF THE
BOX.
KIND OF STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH
THE CORE ISSUES WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS JAN AND I THINK A LOT OF
IT WE SEE REFLECT THE IN THE
EITC ECCENTRIC MENTIONED IN THE
IN IN THIS BUDGET EVEN DATA
DIVISION --
IDEA BUT ESSENTIALLY --
IT'S AN OLD ALMOST AS AN IDEAL
MRS OF THE UNION FOR THOMAS
PAINE WAS TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE
LATE SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS --
DOCTOR KING --
SOCIALIST LIKE MILTON FRIEDMAN A
REGION NEXEN ALSO WERE WERE
FLIRTING WITH THE WITH THIS IDEA
IN IN THAT PROBLEM TO TRY TO
SOLVE IT I THINK WHEN YOU
SINNERS MICHIGAN A WAGE IS NOT
INCREASING --
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE AND IT'S IN
A GREAT NATION A DESTINATION
WILL NATION IS THERE ANY EXCUSE
FOR PEOPLE NOT TO HAVE JUST NOT
THAT LUXURIES WITH NECESSITIES
TAKEN CARE OF SO WE PARTNER WITH
THE GROUP CUT ECONOMIC SECURE
FORTY ONE FORTY FIVE EMERGENCY.
WHICH IS A RATE INCREASE IN TWO
QUARTERS FOR OF FOR FOR EXAMPLE
TO SEE WHAT WE LOOK LIKE TO HAVE
IT -- THE
IDEA WERE ABLE TO RAISE AN AWFUL
IMPROPER LEASE WOULD HAVE TO USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR THIS
DEMONSTRATION BUT STARTING
FRIDAY A HUNDRED THIRTY FAMILIES
SELECTED FROM THROUGHOUT THE FOR
THE CITY --
WHO ALL LIVE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS ADDER BELOW THE
CITY'S MEDIAN OF FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS?
ALSO SOME MAY BE MORE THAN THAT
SOME MAKE LESS BUT THEY ALL LIVE
IN NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THAT'S
THE MEDIAN INCOME ARGUMENT FIVE
AND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR THE NEXT --
EIGHT EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN IN
AGAIN TO YOUR POINT SENATOR.
THE IDEA IS NOT TO BE BOLD FOR
BEING BOLD FAKE ABOUT
TRANSMITTING TWO YEARS IN
COMMUNITY MAYES LISTENING PEOPLE
COMPLAIN ABOUT.
NOT NOT NOT SAYING I WANT TO BUY
A MERCEDES BEINGS ARE WHEN THE
PARK MY GOT SOMEWHERE BUT REALLY
LIKE MAYOR I'M HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH PAIN UTILITIES.
AND I'M WORKING.
I'M HAVING PROBLEM PAYING RENT
AND I'M ORKING TWO JOBS I'M
HAVING PROBLEM THE FOR ANY CHILD
CARE AND IT'S LIKE ALL THESE
FOLKS.
WHO ARE NEARLY WORKING WORKING
THEMSELVES TO DEATH FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN HOUR DAYS I REMEMBER ONE
TIME I WAS ON MY WAY TO THE
AIRPORT HERE?
IN MY UBER DRIVER HAD TO STOP IN
CALL RANGE CHILD CARE BECAUSE
SHE HAD LEFT HER CHILD AT HOME
ALONE A SEVEN YEAR OLD BECAUSE
SHE'S GOT THIS NOTIFICATION SHE
THOUGHT.
IT WOULD BE A BIG BIG TRIP
ANOTHER THE TRADE OFFS THAT
FOLKS THEY'RE MAKING EVERYDAY SO
THAT'S WHAT KIND OF MOTIVATES
THAT WORK IN BUT IS ALSO.
A BELIEF IN THE EYE IN THE AGAIN
TO MY EARLIER POINT THIS IDEA OF
THE INHERENT DIGNITY.
OF PEOPLE IN IN HUMAN BEINGS IN
SOMETHING AS SMALL.
AS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
LOSING IT SINCE THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AGAIN --
COULD MAKE SUCH A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE WHERE PEOPLE CRYING
ON FRIDAY BECAUSE THEY COULD
AFFORD TO BUY THAT NEW CAR --
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS HUNDRED OUR%
RATE INCREASE IT JUST GOT THE
WEEK BEFORE SO EXCITED TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE NEXT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT REGARDS WEBS
WITH THIS PROJECT I THINK THAT
THE STATE WILL HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH.
POVERTY AT ITS CORE BUT ALSO THE
FACT THAT.
WORKING POOR MOST PEOPLE OTHER
PEOPLE ARE TO PAY CHECKS ONE
PAYCHECK ONE LIFE INSTANT AWAY
FROM BEING FOR WHEN THE FICTION
AWAY.
OF FOR BEING HOMES FOR THE NEXT
TEN YEARS NOTHING OF THE STATE
THAT'S PRODUCING SO MUCH WEALTH
ENGINEERING SO MANY IDEAS.
ARE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY BE IT OUT LEAD THE WAY TO
NATION FIGURE OUT HOW TO TAKE
CARE FOLKS.
ALLOW FOLKS TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
I APPRECIATE YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE MAYOR BECAUSE HE HAS TO
LEAVE CENTER LEYVA OF THE MAYOR.
BEAUTIFUL IS NOT REALLY A
QUESTION I IT'S MOSTLY STATEMENT
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I WAS YOU WERE THE
REASON I CAME TO THE BUDGET
HEARING TODAY NOT BECAUSE IT'S%
NOT ALWAYS FASCINATING.
BUT I'VE BEEN READING ABOUT WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING AND I JUST
THINK IT'S GREAT TO BE SO
INNOVATIVE AND JUST LOOK HERE WE
HAVE THIS PROBLEM WHAT HOW WE
THINK OUT OF THE BOX SO I I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I HAVE OTHER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS BUT I WILL RESERVE THE
NOTHING I WOULD SAY THAT AS A
MATTER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
REALLY LOOK AT IT YOU PROBABLY
DO THIS IN A BECAUSE I'M A
LITTLE BIT OF A ONE TRICK PONY
ABOUT WAGES.
AND A LOT OF TIMES BUSINESSES
COME INTO CITIES AND THEY DON'T
PROVIDE A LIVING WAGE AND THEN
WE WONDER WHY FOLKS ARE ON
WELFARE AND WHATNOT AND THEN
THEY DON'T ALSO PROVIDE A
PENSION AND THAT'S WHY OUR
SENIORS.
ARE HOMELESS SO WAGES PENSIONS
WE HEAR ABOUT THEM A LOT AT THAT
YOU KNOW THERE ARE PROBLEM.
BUT THE PROBLEM CALL FALLS TO
ALL OF US IN GOVERNMENT WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T MAKE A LIVING WAGE
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE A PENSION
ONCE THEY GET OLDER SO THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING VERY
INNOVATIVE WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOUS UP MISS SKINNER FOR
THE MAYOR YES WITH --
SKYNYRD'S BY MAYOR CABS THANK
YOU FOR REFERENCING THE COLOR OF
pLAW.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
FOR I WOULD RECOMMEND EVERYONE
READ IT'S A BRILLIANT BOOKS BY
RICHARD ROTHSTEIN.
AND IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE DEALING
A LOT RIGHT NOW WITHIN OUR
SOCIETY AND OUR CULTURE WITH TRY
WITH KIND OF LIFTING UP.
LIFTING UP THE COVERS AND SEEING
HOW CERTAIN POLICIES THAT SOME
OF US TOOK FOR GRANTED AND HAVE
FELT WERE. FOR EITHER GOOD
PURPOSES OR SOMEHOW NEED TO BE
PROTECTED WERE IN FACT VERY VERY
EXCLUSIONARY AND RACIST IN THEIR
ORIGIN AND IN VERY DELIBERATELY.
SO THE THING ABOUT COLOR FLAWS
THAT IT HELPS REALLY ON EARTH
THE HISTORY OF HOUSING POLICY IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WHICH INCLUDES OWNING IT IS NOT
ONLY BUT ALSO OUR LENDING
POLICIES ARE EVEN THE WAY WE
CONSTRUCTED.
OF PUBLIC HOUSING AND HOW OF
COLOR IN KIND OF PUBLIC HOUSING
PEOPLE IN ANOTHER SO AND AND A
CORE [inaudible]
THE ZONING WAS TO EXCLUDE.
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND M. BLACK
PEOPLE FROM CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS AND IF WE LOOK
TODAY AT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IT
WORKED REALLY REALLY WELL.
AND ANYWAY SO IT'S A GREAT BOOK
THANK YOU FOR REFERENCING IT AND
I RECOMMEND EVERYBODY READING IT
AND TAKE YOU FOR YOUR GOOD
COMMENTS AND A FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR FOR
COMING -- A
LOT OF MY FORMER CONSTITUENTS IN
SAN JOSE HAVE MOVED TO STOCKTON.
AND WHICH MEANS THAT THE DRIVE.
TO SILICON VALLEY FROM STOCKTON.
IN TERMS OF THE HOUSING AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IMPACTS --
EXASPERATED --
THE MAYOR OF CUPERTINO.
WHERE ONE OF OUR LARGEST SINGLE
EMPLOYERS --
EXISTING THEY BUILD A TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT CIRCULAR
LARGE CAMPUS COMPANY CALLED
APPLE --
EXIST THERE OF SAID THAT IN HIS
STATE OF THE CITY SPEECH.
THAT HE WAS GONNA.
BUILT A WALL AROUND CUPERTINO
AND SAN JOSE WAS GOING TO PAY.
FOR THAT'S WHAT HE SAID --
THE MAYOR CUPERTINO SET UP.
AND IT WAS REACTION.
TO THE WORK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO TO HAVE EVERYBODY PROVIDE
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
OF HOUSING.
SO WE'RE GETTING THAT KIND OF
REACTION FROM.
SOME OF THE CITY'S OUT THERE --
THE QUESTION IS WHEN WE HAVE
THAT KIND OF REACTION
[inaudible]
AND WHERE THE STATE GOVERNMENT
AND WE THE YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW
CITIES.
AND I WAS ON THE COUNCIL SAN
JOSE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS.
CITIES ALWAYS COME THE STATE
ASKING US FOR FOR MONEY AND I
THINK THE ISSUE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION MONEY.
CAME UP --
EARLIER.
HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE LIKE HIM?
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WHAT WAS YOUR SUGGESTION BE TO
DEAL WITH HOW DID YOU HOW WOULD
YOU DEAL WITH THE OUT OF YOUR
SITTING IN THE GOVERNOR SHOES?
SAME WHEN YOU'RE ELECTED
GOVERNOR DOWN THE ROAD YOU KNOW.
THAT'S THE QUOTE SO NO
DISRESPECT TO TO THE MAYOR
CUPERTINO WHO I DON'T KNOW --
WHAT?
I THINK IN THAT CASE BECAUSE
IT'S FOR VALUES CONVERSATIONS I
WOULD PROBABLY TALK TO I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME PICO AFFILIATE IN
CUPERTINO ARE NEARBY.
ANSWERS SOME PASTORS AND
CHURCHES I'M SURE THERE'S PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN CUPERTINO
DON'T WIN THE CUPERTINO IN OUR
PRIME LEAN HEAVILY.
ON COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE CREATE PRESSURE TO MAKE
COMMENTS LIKE THAT AN ACCEPTABLE
BUT ALSO THE START EDUCATING
THAT.
BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS A VISCERAL
REACTION WHEN THEY SEE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WERE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS LIKE NO ONE LIKES
IT IT'S PEOPLE ARE UPSET THEY'RE
ANGRY THEIR STRESS SOMEONE
YOU'RE OFFERING.
GOING ON WHEN PEOPLE SEE THAT
GREAT WE GO.
WOW I TALK ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS
THAT HAVE TO LIVE LIKE THIS
ESPECIALLY IN IN OUR SOCIETY SO
I THINK.
IT'S AN EDUCATION AROUND BECAUSE
WE WERE BEGINNING TO THAT WERE
CONSTRUCTED NOW ABOUT THIS IDEA
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN BE
THE BOOGIE MAN.
IF WE DON'T WANT TO SEE PEOPLE
ON OUR STREETS THAT FOLKS NEED
TO BE ABLE FOR TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND FOR SOME PEOPLE
THAT'S A TOO MUCH ABOUT IN OUR
HOME.
HIM BUT THIS TIME WHO LIVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO I THINK IT'S A
I MASS EDUCATION CAMPAIGN BUT I
THINK.
CONCRETELY IT'S REALLY YES.
ORGANIZING INCREASING PRESSURE
THIS IS ACTUALLY AN UNACCEPTABLE
SANTA TAKE YOUR SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT PEOPLE LIKE ME TO LIVE IN
THE CITY I LIVE IN.
AND AND HELP THE MAYOR SEE THE
SEE THE LIGHT ANOTHER QUESTION
FOR YOU MISTER MERRETT IS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER WITHDREW THE CDG
PROGRAM I THINK IT OCCURRED.
RIGHT BEFORE YOU BECAME --
YOUR TENURE AS LOOKED AT FISHEL
BUT I THINK THE CD BG PROGRAM
WAS ONE OF THE MAIN STREAMS. FOR
FUNDING FOR HOUSING RELOCATION
PROGRAMS FOR SENIORS ALL THOSE.
OF THIS COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT
IN LOW INCOME AREAS --
USE.
NOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
WITHDRAW FROM THAT AND ALL THE
OTHER FEDERAL HOUSING PROGRAMS.
WHAT THINGS DO YOU THINK THE
STATE SHOULD DO TO STEP IN TO
THE OUT LOS THE UNDERPINNING OF
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
BECAUSE WE GO TALK ABOUT THE
STATE ROLE THE FEDERAL ROLE.
AND THE CITY ROLE IN THE COUNTY
ROLE.
SO HOW HOW WOULD YOU --
HOW WOULD YOU LOOK AT THAT AND
DID YOU THINK THE CD BG PROGRAM
WAS -- A
GOOD MODEL.
A LOVE SEAT CBG AND TO YOUR
POINT WE NEVER HAVE ENOUGH SO
AGAIN THERE'S ALL THESE GREAT
PROJECTS.
IN WHEN THE FROM THE MALL.
AND THEY WERE IN AND ABLE TO
SERVE IN TERMS OF THE STATE.
I KNOW THE REVENUE PROJECTED
REVENUES HAVEN'T COMING AS WE
EXPECTED BUT I THINK AT SOME
POINT A CONVERSATION ABOUT WE'RE
DOING CANNABIS REVENUES TO GO.
ON THAT'S IN LINE WITH VALUES
AND PRIORITIES MAKE ME EXTREMES
ARE FROM BEFORE YOU GUYS.
ON BUT I WOULD SAY.
THAT JUST WITH NO PRIOR RESEARCH
I THINK THAT MAKES SENSE IS A
NEW REVENUE STREAM IT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATE TOTALLY TO ANYTHING YET
TO SEE.
EPIDEMIC THE NUMBER ONE CRISIS
FACING THE STATE IT MAY MAKE
SENSE TO DIVERSE SOME THOSE
DOLLARS THERE --
FOR THAT --
AND THEN IN TERMS OF TO YOUR
POINTS IN YOUR SKINNER --
ANOTHER BUT THERE REALLY ANY
PASSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE WAS ABI
VACATED BY MATTHEW DESMOND --
HE TALKS ABOUT HOW.
HE HAS THIS PHRASE PARTICULARLY
IN IN THE CONSERVE MILWAUKEE BUT
HE SAYS A MILWAUKEE FOR BLACK
MEN THE EXPERIENCE OF BEING
LOCKED IN THE FOR BLACK WOMEN'S
BEING LOCKED OUT FOR I GUESS A
THIRD OF BLACK WITH MILWAUKEE
HAD BEEN INFLICTED.
AT SOME POINT AND I'M SURE THAT
TREND SIMILAR THROUGHOUT --
SO THAT THAT THAT'S ANOTHER
GREAT BUT CAN ALSO TALK ABOUT
OTHER POLICY CHOICES ABOUT
REQUIRE HUGE ALLOCATIONS OF
MONEY THINGS LIKE I'M RIGHT TO
COUNSEL FREE FICTIONS WHICH BAG
OF 90% OF FOLKS WHO HAVE COUNSEL
WHEN ABOUT THE VICTIM.
DON'T GET EVICTEDSO I DON'T
KNOW BECOME HOMELESS OVER A
SECOND STOCKTON WE'RE LOOKING AT
SO WHAT CAN WE DO LOCALLY. TO
BEGIN POUNDING THAT BUT AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND I THINK.
CANNABIS REVENUE ARE FINDING
SOME SORT OF REVENUE STREAM MET
UPON STARTS WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT.
THIS IS AN CLUBBING ONCE HE SAID
THE PRIORITY YOU EITHER THANK
YOU APPRECIATE I KNOW THAT TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE.
YOU KNOW --
MISTER AND SALE YOU AND THE
MAYOR MADE A COMMENT ABOUT --
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO ONE THAT'S
FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THAT GOES WITHOUT SAYING --
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AGAINST A NUMBER OF THE
PROPOSALS TO HELP HOMELESS
PEOPLE --
AND DATE.
RISE UP IN THEIR VERY VOCAL --
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO TO GO TO UTAH --
WHO ARE WAS SENT BY THE SENATE
LEADER AT THE TIME TO LOOK AT
THEIR MODEL?
CALIFORNIA'S NOT YOU TIME
CRYSTAL CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR--
MISTER AND SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE AMAZING UNPRECEDENTED
COALITION OF GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES THAT HAVE COME TOGETHER.
BETWEEN THE CITY AND COUNTY AND
WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR WAS PRIVATE
SECTOR.
SPECIFICALLY.
AND WHAT I SAW ON UTAH WAS
UNIQUE TO UTAH BUT IT WAS
PRIVATE SECTOR CHURCH.
AND ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
COOL IT WAS FASCINATING.
WORD LITERALLY SPEAKING FROM THE
SAME SCRIPT.
SO I I AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
ARE AT A UNIQUE POINT IN TIME
NOW IN CALIFORNIA WHERE MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT WE WE
FIGURED OUT IT IS A CRISIS WE
ALL HAVE TO DO OUR PART.
THE STATE HAS BEEN NEGLIGENT WE
HAVE STEPPED UP IN RECENT YEARS
TO DO OUR PART.
WHO ARE WE MISSING IN THE PUZZLE
PIECE IN TERMS OF REALLY COMING
OUT WITH A CAKE THAT WITH THE?
RIGHT EQUATION TO TRY TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE WHO WHO
[inaudible]
WHO'S MISSING.
WHAT IF IF THAT QUESTION IS IS
FOR ME MADAM CHAIR AT LET ME LET
ME JUST FIRST SAY THAT IF I IN
ANY WAY CONVEYED?
THAT THE EFFORT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS STRICTLY WITHIN
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WAS NOT MY INTENTION AND
THAT IS BY NO MEANS THE CASE
RIGHT -- I
THINK I SHARED THAT WHEN WE
INITIALLY LARGE THE HOMELESS
INITIATIVE --
AT THE DIRECTION THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE UNDERTAKE
EIGHTEEN POLICY SUMMITS THAT
WINNER THAT BROUGHT TOGETHER
FOUR HUNDRED INVITED GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY EXPERTS.
AND OUR MOVEMENT HAS BEEN A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE COUNTY
CITIES HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS PHILANTHROPY.
BUSINESS AND FAITH ORGANIZATIONS
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THE
CONFERENCE I MENTIONED ON
FEBRUARY SEVENTH THEY BROUGHT
TOGETHER. EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE
IN A STANDING ROOM ONLY --
CONVENE.
MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE NON
GOVERNMENTAL PROBABLY.
PROBABLY CLOSE TO TWO THIRDS
WERE COMBINATION OF COMMUNITY
BASED ON MY SERVICE PROVIDERS --
PHILANTHROPY --
AND FAITH ORGANIZATIONS --
SHOW.
CERTAINLY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AYE GENERATING A DEEP SENSE OF A
LINE MANAGE.
ACROSS THOSE SECTORS AND NOT
ONLY BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND
CITIES WHERE RELATIONSHIPS HAVE
NOT ALWAYS BEEN SMOOTH IN
RELATION ALMOST AS BY WITH --
PHILANTHROPY AND BUSINESS HAS
BEEN FUNDAMENTAL --
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE UNITED
WAY OF GREATER LOS ANGELES THREE
THEIR HOME FOR GOOD PROJECT
WHICH WAS A PARTNERSHIP FROM THE
BEGINNING.
BETWEEN THE ORGANIZED CIVIC AND
BUSINESS LEADERSHIP AND
PHILANTHROPY HAS BEEN
FUNDAMENTAL ALL ALONG AND TO DAY.
THAT UNITED WAY HE IS
SPEARHEADING THE EVERYONE IN
CAMPAIGN WHERE EVERYONE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHO WANTS TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
CAN SIGN UP AND A PRIMARY FOCUS
OF THE EVERYONE IN CAMPAIGN IS
TO SUPPORT THE CITING.
THE INNER AM PERMITS SUPPORTED
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACROSS
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IF I COULD JUST IS FOR TO
COMMENT BRIEFLY ON THE POINT
I'M NOT EVERYONE'S IN AGREEMENT
ON ALL OF THE SOLUTIONS --
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE I'M NO
WHEN USING DIFFERENT
HOMELESSNESS.
I KNOW WHEN IS FOR IT.
AND THAT IS INDEED A COMMON
GROUND NOW THAT SAID REASONABLE
PEOPLE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON SOLUTIONS.
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT NOT
TO DEMONIZED.
PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
PARTICULAR SOLUTIONS --
AND AS WELL AS NOT TO DEMONIZED
PEOPLE WHO HAVE VERY LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CURRENT.
REALITY IF I STILL THAT YOUNG
CHILDREN AT HOME.
AND THERE IS A PERSON
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
CAR IN FRONT OF MY HOUSE --
AND PERHAPS RELIEVING HIM OR
HERSELF.
IN MY FRIEND YARD I WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT --
NOW WAS THERE ANY MY PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT TO COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS SO I THINK THAT
WHAT THE COMMON GROUND.
AS HUMAN BEINGS AND WHAT WE FEEL
IS THE MAYOR MENTION THIS SURVEY
OF NEURAL RESPONSE AND WE SEE A
FELLOW MEMBER OF OUR SPECIES
SLEEPING ON THE SIDEWALK.
I THINK THE COMING GROUND USE
THAT BASIS FOR DEEP ALIGNMENT
AND GIVES US THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD --
AND TO ENGAGE IN SORT OF
MEANINGFUL DISCOURSE I'M AROUND
A RANGE OF SOLUTIONS I WOULD
ALSO SAY FINALLY ON THE QUESTION
OF CITING --
GETTING INURNMENT PERMITS
APARTMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CITED DOESN'T REQUIRE WINNING AN
ELECTION AND IT ALSO DOESN'T
REQUIRE A 100% --
AS THE PEOPLE TO SUPPORT A
PARTICULAR PROJECT.
UNITED WAY DID A POLL THAT
SHOWED THAT 70% OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY RESIDENTS 70%.
SUPPORT DECIDING OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD NOT IN THERE ZIP
CODE.
DIED IN THEIR CITY IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. TO THE KEY AROUND
CITING SO THAT THE VOICES OF THE
30% DON'T DROWN THEM OUT
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT. TWENTY COMMENTS --
I ADMIRE MR AND CELLS
APPRECIATION FOR THE HUMAN
SPECIES --
AYE AYE AYE MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
MORE JUDGMENTAL --
HAVING HAVING WORKED IN LOTS OF
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE BROUGHT
FORWARD PROPOSALS WHERE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO HOLD
COMPLETELY CONTRADICTORY IDEAS
IN THEIR HEAD AT THE SAME TIME
AROUND THIS TOPIC AND SO --
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
I THINK MOST ELECTED OFFICIALS
WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY DO NOT
WANT THE POWER TO ZONE OR THE
POWER TO APPROVE PROJECTS TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM.
BUT I'VE NOTICED I PARTICIPATED
IN THE CASA PROCESS THAT I THINK
SOME OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH.
IS THAT THE THE ELECTORATES
DESIRE TO PUNISH LAWMAKERS THAT
MAKE THE RIGHT MOVES AROUND THIS
IS PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK IT WOULD BE
A GREAT SERVICE TO LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO TAKE SOME OF THIS
POWER AWAY.
AND I THINK THE REASON WHY I
BELIEVE THAT IS BECAUSE OF 70%
OF THE ELECTORATE REALLY DOES
SUPPORT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
THE OTHER 30% IS ABUSING THE
PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE.
AND ERY VOCAL IN AN IN
ELECTIONS. TO MAKE IT VERY VERY
PAINFUL FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE THE
RIGHT CHOICES AND SO I THINK.
I HEARD YOU SAY EARLIER SENATOR
THAT WE'VE GOT SOME PROPOSALS
THAT NOT EVERYONE IS IN
AGREEMENT WITH.
BUT I THINK WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
PAST THE POINT OF CAN WE ALL GET
THEIR COOPERATIVELY --
I WILL TELL YOU THAT WE LOST
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON A PROPOSAL TO BUY A
MOTEL THAT HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
FOR PURCHASE BY A LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE IT WAS --
LET'S JUST SAY IT AT OUR THE
CUSTOMERS --
AND WE WENT AHEAD AN OPTION THE
PROPERTY AND FACED AN
UNBELIEVABLE BACKLASH --
FROM FOLKS THAT DID NOT WANT TO
DO IT WAS GOING TO BE HALF OF
FORMALLY HOMELESS VETERANS AND
HALF -- FOR
I THINK FORMALLY HOMES SENIORS
LIKE IF I COULD BE WRONG ABOUT
THAT SECOND PIECE --
WHAT WHAT I'VE NOTICED IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT WHAT --
MISTRANSLATED EARLIER ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING LOS ANGELES NOW
IS IF YOU GO ON THE WEBSITE YOU
CAN SEE BY EACH COUNCIL DISTRICT.
WHICH OF THEM IS ACTUALLY
MEETING THE GOALS IN TERMS OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN
THEIR DISTRICT AND SO WHEN WE
HAVE GONE OUT TO DISTRICTS THAT.
HAVE BEEN DONE A LOT OF THIS
WORK WE ARE GETTING A RECEPTION
IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN THE
ONE WE GOT EVEN TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS AGO --
IT MAY NOT ENABLE A LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL STAND UP TO A
TOTALLY CRAZY SITUATION BUT I
THINK IT.
IS VERY IMPORTANT SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW TO SENATOR BELLS
QUESTION ABOUT CUPERTINO.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
MAYBE IS NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD IS
THAT ONE OF THE REALLY POWERFUL
THINGS ABOUT REDEVELOPMENT LAW.
WAS IT ACTUALLYGAVE MONEY TO
PURCHASE PROPERTY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
NOW A LOT OF THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE SPENDING AT THE STATE
LEVEL IS ACTUALLY COMING IN THE
FORM OF GAP FUNNY THAT COMES
AFTER YOU MADE THE PURCHASE
RIGHT.
AND SO I THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR
THE CUPERTINO IS OF THE WORLD
AND YOU SORT OF CONSTRUED TRUST
IT WOULD STOCKTON I THINK.
WHO WOULDN'T WANT TO GIVE MAYOR
TUBS OF MONEY --
TO TO ARE UNFORTUNATELY A BUNCH
OF VERY JOBS RICH COMMUNITIES
OUR STATE WHERE IF YOU GIVEN THE
MONEY THEY'RE GOING TO DO
ANYTHING WITH IT.
AND SO I THINK THE QUESTION FOR
YOU IS LEGISLATORS IS AT WHAT
POINT DO PEOPLE LOSE THE RIGHT.
TO PROCEED AT THEIR OWN PACE AT
FOR ME WAS ABOUT A DECADE AGO --
I SENSE THAT NOW IS THE MOMENT
FOR MANY OTHERS.
AND AND I GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY
I THINK I THINK THAT I I
RECENTLY HEARD AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL TALK ABOUT IS I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHO IT IS BUT JUST LIKE
WE DO ON EVERY OTHER TOPIC WE
HAVE.
A STANDARD OF CIVIC BEHAVIOR
THAT WE EXPECT OUT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND AND FRANKLY IF
PART OF IT IS ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOUSING SHORTAGE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE.
THAN THERE OUGHT TO BE A SERIES
OF BEHAVIORS THAT WE EXPECT A
LOW COLLECTED OFFICIALS WERE
APPOINTED OFFICIALS OR WHATEVER
IT IS. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THOSE THINGS AND IF THEY CAN'T
OR WON'T --
I I THINK IT IS TIME FOR THE
STATE TO ACT AND REMOVE SOME OF
THOSE SOME OF THOSE OF THIRTIES
AND I AND HONESTLY I THINK.
IT WILL BE TO THE BENEFIT OF
MANY LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
ARE OTHERWISE PUTTING COMPLETELY
UNTENABLE SITUATIONS AND WHO
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS WILL TELL
YOU.
I'M TOTALLY FOR YOUR PROJECT I
AM TOTALLY THE PUBLIC HAS SPOKEN
AND YOU'VE GOTTEN THROUGH SEQUEL
AND ALL THE LAWSUITS ARE OVER
I'M GONNA COME OUT FOR IT.
BUT THAT'S TOO LATE TO THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL [inaudible]
THANK -- THE
MAKING SOME GOOD POINTS HERE AND
I WAS COMPELLED BY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT RAPID RE HOUSING.
THERE WERE MANY IMPEDIMENTS TO
THAT.
IS THERE ANY HOPE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
FOR FASTRACK PERMITTING OR
CONSOLIDATED PERMITTING THE THAT
WOULD BE AN ELEMENT OF HELPING
WITH YOUR FAST TRACKING WOULD
NOT.
SO I AM CENTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION THAT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT CHAIR BIG
KNOWLEDGE THAT.
WITH THE PARTIAL EXCEPTION OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF FAMILIES
AND ADULTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
WILL ESCAPE HOMELESSNESS NOT BY
MOVING INTO NEWLY BUILT HOUSING.
THEY WILL MOVE INTO ALREADY
EXISTING HOUSING.
AND THEY WILL NEED A RENTAL
SUBSIDY TO DO IT NOW THAT SAID.
THE ABBOTT THEY SHOULD THE DEEP
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE STATE FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND UNIT SHORTFALL IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE.
IS THE GROUND OF OUR HOMELESS
CRISIS THAT'S WHAT'S CAUSING
RENTS TO GO UP.
AND RATES GOING UP IS WHAT'S
CAUSING PEOPLE TO BECOME.
I IN NO WAY WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
FUNDAMENTAL IMPORTANCE OF
INCREASING HOUSING SUPPLY.
AND POTENTIALLY TAKING OTHER
POLICY ACTIONS TO MITIGATE RENT
INCREASES.
BY.
THAT SAID THERE IS NOT THE
LINEAR RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
A FAMILY OR DAHLE HE'S HOMELESS
TODAY.
AND MOVING INTO A NEWLY BUILT
UNIT TOMORROW IT'S MORE OF THESE
INDIRECT RELATIONSHIP IN TERMS
OF THE MARKET DYNAMIC OF SUPPLY
AND DEMAND AND ITS IMPACT ON
RENTS.
SO THAT SAID --
THE KEY TO MOVING FAMILIES AND
ADULTS IN TWO IN A RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAM IS LOCATING THE
AVAILABLE UNITS --
AND THE FACT THAT THE HOUSING
MARKET IS SO TIGHT IS THE
BIGGEST IMPEDIMENT TO THAT NOW
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE THROUGH INCREASING
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS.
IS AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY. TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THAT'S AN
AREA WHERE WE ARE FOCUSING --
QUITE SUBSTANTIALLY ON YOUR VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT
PERMITTING THAT IS PRIMARILY A
CITY RESPONSIBILITY I'M IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY 90%.
OF OUR COUNTY RESIDENTS LIVE IN
ONE OF OUR EIGHTY EIGHT
INCORPORATED CITIES EIGHTIES
EACH OF THOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES TO THEIR CITY COUNCILS.
AND SEE MANAGERS AND DAD
PLANNING COMMISSIONS THAT MAKE
THE DECISIONS --
AROUND PER MEETING AT YOUR
PROJECTS EITHER BY RIGHT OR ON A
DISCRETIONARY BASIS. ONE OF THE
INTERESTING.
OBSERVATIONS THAT I'VE HAD OVER
MANY DECADES AND MISTER
SHOEMAKER SOMEWHAT [inaudible]
NOTED THAT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE LONG
COMPLAINED.
ABOUT STATE MANDATES.
PARTICULAR UNFUNDED MANDATES.
BUT I FOUND OUT MANY YEARS AGO
THAT SOME OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
SILENTLY REALLY LIKED THOSE.
MANDATES.
BECAUSE IT GOT THEM OFF THE HOOK.
WELL I GET THAT.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THAT
HAD WE WALK A MIDDLE GROUND NOW.
TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
PRESSURES ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
BUT ALSO THEN TO ENCOURAGE
DECISION MAKING.
AND GETTING THE JOB DONE IT'S
JUST A IT'S BEEN A PARADOX
THAT'S BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME.
THEN WILL THE LEGISLATURE ONE OF
THIS FILM WITH THAT BURDEN
WEALTH IT SEEMS LIKE IT HAS FOR
OVER A LONG TIME BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S THE ANSWER IN THE
FUTURE FOR THE STATE TO SUE MORE.
RESPONSIBILITYOF LAW FOR THEM
TO TO COMMENT ON THAT.
YEAH YEAH.
I I KIND OF MOVED OFF ON TO THAT
YET NO I APPRECIATE THE THE THE
COMMON SENATOR I I GUESS I WOULD
SAY -- IN
SOME WAYS I DON'T KNOW THE
YOU'RE TAKING ON MORE THAN
MANDATE AS MUCH AS JUST --
TECHNOLOGY THAT THERE ARE
ASPECTS OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS TO DON'T WORK VERY WELL.
AND SO TO HAVE DIRECT DEMOCRACY
OR SOMETHING APPROACHING IT.
BE THE RULE OF THE DAY FOR THE
APPROVAL OF INDIVIDUAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT SEEMS LIKE A BAD.
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM AND WE'VE
GOT REPRESENTED DEMOCRACY FOR A
REASON.
BUT WHEN IT COMES A LAND USE
DECISIONS IT'S IF WE DO A
PLEBISCITE ON EVERY PROJECTAND
AND SO I WOULD SAY IT'S ACTUALLY
MORE.
AT A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN SEE THAT.
OUR SYSTEM FOR MAKING DECISIONS
WHEN WE HAVE AN OVERWHELMING
NEED TO MAKE THEM.
IS NOT OCCURRING WITH THE TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US OF
THE PROCESS EITHER WE HAVE SET
UP AND SO.
I DON'T THINK YOU'D BE TAKING ON
AS MUCH AS ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE GOT A LITTLE
BIT TOO FAR IN TERMS OF PROCESS
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
AT THIS WRESTLING OTHER POINT IN
A WHEREVER YOU'RE GOING TO
LOCATE.
AN SHELTER FOR HOMELESS
[inaudible]
PERSON.
WHAT ARE YOUR OPTIONS ARE THE?
CONSIDERABLE FOR HAVING THOSE
LOCATIONS BE WITH NEXUS.
TO TREATMENT MEDICAL CARE.
EDUCATION.
ALL THOSE.
THAT TO THEM PORTENT PART OF
GETTING SOMEONE PERMANENTLY OFF.
THE THE SO CALLED TREADMILL OF
HOMELESSNESS.
CHOOSE SENATOR --
PRIOR TO YOU ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE HOMELESS INITIATIVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN MOST
PUBLICLY FUNDED --
EMERGENCY SHELTER IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHICH ONLY OPEN FOURTEEN
HOURS A DAY.
SO THE RESIDENTS HAD TO LIGHT AT
BEACH DAY NIGHT.
WE CHANGE THAT SAY NOW ALL
PUBLICLY FUNDED INTERN HAS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS OPEN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND THEREFORE FUNCTIONS AS A
PLATFORM FOR ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND PERMANENT HOUSING
[inaudible]
THE AS LONG AS IN ROOM HOUSING
IS ACCESSIBLE VIA PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
I WOULD SAY GENERALLY THAT IT
WOULD BE --
AFIQ COULD BE A FEASIBLE
LOCATION IN TERMS OF MEETING THE
SERVICE NEEDS THE OTHER THING I
WOULD SAY THERE.
IS THAT.
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN
THEIR LIVES IS RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
JUST LIKE FOR ALL OF US.
AND FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
GENERALLY.
THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT MANY OF
US TAKE FOR GRANTED.
ARE DEEPLY FRAYED OR NO LONGER
EXIST PARTICULARLY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FAMILY [inaudible]
AND WHAT WE FIND IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
MORE LIKELY. TO BE LONG TERM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RESIDENTS THAN
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOUSED.
THE DESPITE THE MINUTE THE
PEOPLE COME TO SANTEE CALIFORNIA.
PARTICULARLY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE WEATHER IS GOOD --
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THE DATA SHOWS THAT THAT IS NOT
TRUE AND THEN IN FACT THREE
QUARTERS.
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAVE LIVED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS
MANY FOR THEIR ENTIRE LIVES.
AND THEREFORE THE KEY QUESTION
FOR US AROUND CITING IN ROOM
HOUSING S LESS ABOUT ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND MORE ABOUT BEING IN
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
ARE HOMELESS AND THEREFORE WILL
BE WILL GO BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD
RATHER SLEEP ON THE STREET.
IN THE COMMUNITY THEY KNOW WHERE
THEY GO GO TWENTY MILES AWAY TO
AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT --
COMMUNITY SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
WHICH CRITICAL TO DISTRIBUTE IN
ARM HOUSING --
RALLY IN A WAY THAT'S ROUGHLY
PROPORTIONATE TO THE
DISTRIBUTION OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
THAT SAID.
IF THERE'S A CITED SOME PUBLIC
TRANSIT IN A COMMUNITY WHERE
PEOPLE THERE IS A COMMUNITY OF
PEOPLE EXPANSION ALMOST AS THE
NEEDS THAT INNER HOUSING.
THAT WE WOULD CONSIDER THAT --
A VIABLE SITE NOW I ONE ALSO
JUST CRIED FRIENDS BEGIN FOR
WORK. ONE OF THE LARGEST URBAN
AREAS IN THE COUNTRY THE LARGEST
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY --
THE ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION MIGHT
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT AROUND THE
QUESTION OF THE LOCATION OF
INNER MAY HAVE SEEN.
THE OTHER RELATED SERVICES THANK
YOU.
THIRD OR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
SHOEMAKER --
MISTER ANSEL'S USE THE WORD
CITING QUITE A BIT THE USE AN
IMPORTANT WORD THAT WAS SCARCITY.
SO I WANNA.
ASK YOU THREE QUESTIONS THE
FIRST IS WHERE AND HOW ARE YOU
FINDING LAND --
YOU'VE ALREADY KIND OF HINTED AT
NIMBY ISM --
BUT I I WANNA KNOW HOW YOU'RE
MAKING GET PENCIL OUT AND WOULD
YOU CONCLUDE WITH A SUCCESS
STORY.
HER I THINK I WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTOOD THE SECOND QUESTION
ARE WE MAKING A PENCIL --
IN TERMS OF OPPOSITION OR JUST
IN TERMS ARE JUST AS A
FINANCIALLY YEAH HOW DOES IT ALL
WORK IS REALLY HARKING ABOUT
SERIOUS COST YEAH YEAH --
YOU KNOW I HONESTLY MERCY
HOUSING MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
UNUSUAL IN THE SENSE THAT WE ARE --
OUR ROOTS ARE OBVIOUSLY WITH
CATHOLIC SISTERS AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF RELATIONSHIPS WITH FACE
BATES ORGANIZATION SO AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER OF PROPERTIES
COME OUR WAY VIA A CHURCHES.
AND OTHER RELIGIOUS GROUPS
SYNAGOGUES COME TO US THAT WAY
US OF A LOT OF SOCIAL SERVICE
NONPROFIT TO COME FORWARD.
THAT YOU KNOW MIGHT WORK WITH
AUTISTIC.
A YOUNG ADULT AND SAY LIKE
RICHARD WERE DYING TO SERVE THIS
POPULATION WILL HELP US BUILD
SOME HOUSING FOR AND WE GOTSOME
LAND TO DO IT --
WE WE ALSO ARE LUCKY TO WORK
WITH A LOT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DO GREAT WORK --
WE HAD A COUPLE OF AMAZING
EXPERIENCES IN LA COUNTY WITH A
MONTY --
THAT YOU KNOW.
IT OUT ALL THE THE THE SMALLER
PIECES OF LAND IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
AND HAVE --
AND MAYBE I'M NOT ENDING WITH A
SUCCESS STARTED I'LL JUST SAY
THAT THE TIME FROM WHICH A MONTY
DECIDED TO MOVE ON TO ME TO THE
TIME WHICH HAD A PERMIT AND ALL
THE MONEY TO GO.
WAS YOU KNOW.
THE QUESTION A MONTHS NOT YEARS --
AND WE HAVE NOW WE'RE NOW
BUILDING OUR SECOND --
DEVELOPMENT THERE --
FOR FORMALLY HOMES THAT --
AND I THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT
A GOVERNMENT'S THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE MOVING FORWARD
ON SURPLUS PROPERTY WHEN YOU
WANT TO DO WHAT YOU CAN DO IT --
AND THEN OCCASIONALLY WE DO WE
DO PURCHASE PROPERTY WE'D WE DO --
ESPECIALLY AROUND BERMAN
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
ACQUIRE HOTELS AND MOTELS OFTEN
BECAUSE FASTER WAY TO GET TO THE
FINISH LINE ON ON THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES --
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE PERFECT
PLACE FOR SOMETHING BUT IT'S
IT'S IT'S ONE OF THE THE ONE OF
THE WAYS WE DO IT --
AND YOU KNOW AND OCCASIONALLY GO
OUT AND IF WE'RE REALLY ANXIOUS
TO GET SOMETHING IN A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY WILL GO AHEAD AND AND
WORK WITH A BROKER IN TRYING TO
FIND A WAY TO PURGE THE LAND.
ON IN YOU KNOW IN DIFFERENT
DEVELOPERS WORK DIFFERENTLY IN
THAT REGARD I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY MORE ON THE
RELATIONSHIP SIDE A LITTLE BIT
LESS ON THE REAL ESTATE BROKERS
AND SOME OTHERS --
IN TERMS OF PENCILING IT OUT I I
THINK THIS IS --
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW WHICH
IS I THINK AT THIS POINT IN A
MAYBE FOR THIS BEFORE MOST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS OF
THE STATE HAVE TO GO TO SEVEN OR
EIGHT DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
FUNDING FOR ITS DEVELOPMENT.
AND EACH ONE HAS SOMETHING
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
YOUR YOUR MANDATE IS THAT MY
BUILDING BE BLUE.
AND YEARS IS THAT IT ALSO BE
BANK AND SO I'VE GOT TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT'S BLUE AND PINK
IN ORDER TO GET IT DONE.
AND I THINK THAT --
THE FEWER SOURCES OF FUNDING WE
USE FOR EACH PROJECT THE BETTER
OFF WE BE CITING ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A I DON'T USE
MY WORDS HERE CAREFULLY BUT A
LITTLE BIT DISCONCERTING ABOUT
THE WAY WE TEND OF FUND MONEY OR
FUND.
DEVELOPMENT AS WE WE SORT OF TRY
AND PILE THE SMALLEST AMOUNT
POSSIBLE FROM ONE SOURCE TO
LEVERAGE ANOTHER IN THE LEVERAGE
ANOTHER WHEN IN FACT I THINK.
WOULD BE IN THE STATE'S INTEREST
TO SORT OF SAY LET'S MAKE THE
FUNDING AWARDS FOR EACH OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS.
TWICE AS BIG ARE THREE TIMES AS
BIG SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO GO TO
THE STATE FOR LOTS OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FUNDS.
AND THEN LOTS OF DIFFERENT
REGIONAL GROUP FOR THAT AS I BOB
BY LAND I GET LAND FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I GET SOME MONEY FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL TO KIND OF DO
THE DESIGN SEARCHES AND I GOT A
ONE SOURCE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
TO MAKE IT WOK --
OFTENTIMES THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE AND I THINK.
AS A LEGISLATURE THINGS ABOUT
THE USE OF ITS MONEY IT'S SORT
OF TEMPTING TO SORT OF SAY LET'S.
LET'S SPREAD THIS EVERYWHERE
SHOULD BE SURE THAT WE HAD EVERY
COMMUNITY WHEN IN FACT YOU CAN
HIT EVERY COMMUNITY BUT YOU JUST.
WOULD BE BETTER IF YOU MAY THE
WARTS FROM EACH PROGRAM SLIGHTLY
BIGGER SO I WILL I WILL SAY THAT --
AND I GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY
LIKE I YOU KNOW AGAIN BACK TO A
MONTY I I'M AMAZED AT THE
RECEPTION WE GOT THERE IS
PROBABLY FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO
BUT I CAME IN WITH A COUPLE OF
OTHER FOLKS --
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THIS FIELD FOR
FORTY YEARS --
I'VE NEVER SEEN A RECEPTION LIKE
THAT AND I LITTLE OURSELVES --
LITERALLY THE ENTIRE DOWNTOWN
WAS STOPPED.
IT FELT LIKE EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN EVERY VETERANS OF
ANY WAR OR ANY WANTED EVER SERVE
IN THE MILITARY WAS THERE.
MANY OF THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AROUND ON MONTY WHERE THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE ASKING HOW DID YOU
GET THIS DONNA HOW DO WE DO IT
AGAIN -- AND
THE GOOD NEWS FOR US IS SOME OF
THOSE FOLKS OF THEN GOT CALLED
US UP AND SAID FROM PLACENTIA OR
NORWALK OR WHATEVER IT IS.
I SAW THE PROJECT YOU DIDN'T
AMOUNT TO COME INTO THAT OUR
COMMUNITY AND I KNOW MERCY IS
NOT ALONE IN HAVING I THINK YOU
KNOW THE BEST ADVERTISEMENT FOR
ANOTHER.
OPPORTUNITY IS TO REALLY DO
GREAT WORK AND TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY SO.
I THINK THERE ARE LOTS OF PLACES
LIKE THAT THAT ARE JUST.
THEY'RE STEPPING UP IN A YOU
KNOW WE LITERALLY HAVE TO TURN
AWAY DONORSOF FOOD FOR OUR
VETERANS HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ON
MULTI.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT IS
SO OVERWHELMING PEOPLE ARE
CONSTANTLY COMING TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OFFERING TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FOOD --
YOU KNOW IN AN EFFORT TO HELP
THE FORMALLY ALMOST THAT SO I
THINK YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN AN
AMAZING EXPERIENCE AND YOU KNOW
I I THINK THERE ARE LOTS OF
OTHER COMMUNITIES LIKE THAT SO.
I WANTED TO I WANT JUST TO FOLKS
THAT AREN'T ARE DOING GREAT WORK
I MEAN THERE ARE SOME AMAZING
AMAZING --
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS ALLOW
WAIT.
YOUR SUCCESSES LIKE IN EL MONTE
BE YOUR ANTIDOTE. TO DOING
SOMETHING SOMEWHERE ELSE TO SAY.
IN YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A NAME
BE EXPERTS YOU'LL HAVE TO BRING
THE TORCHES AND PITCHFORKS
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE IS AN ILL
MONEY.
AND IT'S IT'S A WIN WIN WIN.
AND IS AT A WAY TO INOCULATE.
THE RESIDENTS OF THE NEIGHBORING
CITY YOU KNOW IT IS REALLY
EFFECTIVE WHEN YOU CAN GET FOLKS
TO DO IT --
AND UNFORTUNATELY --
AN ERA IN WHICH THE INTERNET IS
THE SOURCE OF A LOT OF
INFORMATION --
WEEK WE TRY VERY HARD TO GET
FOLKS TO COME AND VISIT WITH
OTHER FOLKS ARE TALK TO PEOPLE
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE THAT.
I HAVE NEVER HAD THE EXPERIENCE
PERSONALLY OF OF NEIGHBORS
COMING UP TO ME AFTER BUILDING
IS IN PRICE AND IN OPERATIONS
AND SAYING I TOLD YOU WAS GOING
TO BE AWFUL.
I GET THE OPPOSITE EVERY TIME
WHICH IS GREAT I I YOU KNOW I
WAS SUPER NERVOUS ABOUT THIS I
REALLY DIDN'T BELIEVE YOU WHEN
YOU TELL ME WAS GONNA BE OKAY
AND IT IS.
I'M A LITTLE EMBARRASSED
INSTAGRAM THAT I'VE FOUGHT TO
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I REALLY
SUPPORT THIS NOW AND I WISH I'D
KNOWN WHAT I KNOW NOW.
BUT IT'S HARD TO GET THAT OUT TO
AS MANY PEOPLE AS YOU LIKE BUT
IT'S IT IS EXPERIENCE I THINK OF
MANY.
IF NOT MOST OF US IN THIS FIELD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MANAGER.
I'M ON THAT QUESTION OR OVERALL
A RECALL BRIEFLY BEFORE YES IF I
COULD THERE.
THE AND AGAIN.
I TALK ABOUT ME ABOUT ABOUT MY
QUESTION.
IF I COULD THERE'S TWO POINTS
I'D LIKE TO RAISE THAT AT THAT
HAVE BEEN SERVICE YET --
FIRST ON THE QUESTION OF THIS
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION I DO WANT
TO SHARE THAT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
THERE IS ENORMOUS INTEREST IN
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES. TO
BUILDING --
HOUSING FOR FAMILIES AND ADULTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TIMES
ON TUESDAY IN THE PRINT EDITION.
IN THAT CALIFORNIA'S SECTION WAS
DEDICATED TO OUR HOUSING
INNOVATION CHALLENGE WHERE WE
UTILIZED FOR A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS A MEASURE H. FUNDING FOR
FIVE VERY INNOVATIVE NON TAX
CREDIT PROJECT PROJECTS.
WHICH HAVE THE POTENTIAL --
TO BE SCALED TWO HUNDREDS OR
EVEN THOUSANDS OF UNITS BEING
BUILT AND RELYING ON OUR
EXPERIENCE THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAS ALLOCATED.
A FULL 10% OR A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THEIR ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS --
LAB PROPOSITION TRIPLE H.
HOUSING BOND FINDING 80% OF
WHICH HAS TO BE FOR PERMITS A
PART OF HOUSING --
TO AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH SHE
DOESN'T EXPLICIT DOESN'T.
EXCLUDES TAX CREDIT FINANCING BY
IT IS INTENDED TO BE A FASTER
AND CHEAPER APPROACH WHICH COULD
INCLUDE NON TAX CREDIT ARE
PROJECTS AND SIMILARLY THE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
IS PUTTING TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FINDING INTO AN
INNOVATIVE --
PROPOSAL PROCESS SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT OUT THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF FERMENT AND INTEREST.
IN ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BOTH ALTERNATIVE
CONSTRUCTION METHODS.
AND ALTERNATIVE FINANCING
METHODS AN ALTERNATE
CONSTRUCTION METHODS ARE NOT
EXCLUDED FROM TAX CREDIT
FINANCING WHETHER IT'S PRETTY
FABRICANT TRAINER OR OTHER
ALTERNATIVE METHODS BUT I JUST
WANTED TO INTERJECT THAT.
I INTO THE CONVERSATION AND THEN
FINALLY JUST TO TIED DOWN TO A
CENTER MORE LAX --
QUESTION.
RELATIVE TO CITIES WHICH AGAIN
MAKE THE LAND USE DECISIONS IN
IN THE IN OUR STATE ARE
CURRENTLY --
ENABLING CITIES TO MOVE TOGETHER.
RATHER THAN SEPARATELY IS IN OUR
VIEW AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND WE HAVE BEEN VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT ENGAGING THE
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IN.
TRYING TO MOVE.
TOGETHER MEANING TO GO ON THE
SAME TIME LINE THAT YOU DO
SIMILAR THINGS SAY WHEN WE
ENGAGE FORTY ONE CITIES TO
WANTED TO DEVELOP CITY SPECIFIC
HONEST AS PLANS HE WAS ON THE
SAME TIME LINE.
AND THEN WE ALLOCATED NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
CITIES ARE COMPETITIVE PROCESS
IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE PLANS.
SO.
THE INTENTION OF DOING THAT IS
THAT CITIES ARE AFRAID OF BEING
MAGNETS.
I'VE DRAIN PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FROM SURROUNDING
COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES.
IF CITIES MOVE IN PARALLEL NOT
THE SAME IF THEY'RE MOVING TO
GATHER IN A CONSTRUCTIVE
DIRECTION THEN THEY CAN OVERCOME%
THAT FEAR.
OF BEING A MAGNET --
AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT
THAT'S VERY POSITIVE THAT
DYNAMIC AND WE IN FACT ARE
SUPPORTING.
THE SEVEN COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH
ONGOING FINDING ESSENTIALLY FOR
HOMELESS COORDINATORS WITHIN THE
COGS WHOSE JOB IT IS TO SUPPORT.
THE CITIES IN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS IN COORDINATING THEIR
EFFORTS SO IN THIS NINE MILLION
DOLLARS I MENTIONED WE HAVE MANY
CITIES.
THAT FOR EXAMPLE MANHATTAN BEACH
REDONDO BEACH AND HERMOSA BEACH.
AFFLUENT BEACH CITIES IN --
NORTH OF LONG BEACH AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHO CAME TOGETHER
TO SEE FINDING YOUR SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR
HOMELESSNESS PLANS SIMILARLY WE
IN THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY WHICH
IS WHERE I MONEY IS LOCATED AT
THE HEARD MENTION OF A MOMENT
AGO.
COMING TOGETHER SO I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE IS THAT IN ADDITION TO
ANY ACTIONS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT TAKE AROUND
CITY RESPONSES CITY DISCRETION
OR CARRIAGE OR STYX'S SATIATED
WITH THE EXERCISES CITY
AUTHORITY.
I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THINGS YOU COULD DO
THAT WOULD.
ENCOURAGE CITIES TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AND TO WORK TOGETHER.
SIMULTANEOUSLY --
BECAUSE I HI IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE PARTICULAR AROUND AND USE.
WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAS BEEN A VERY ENGAGING PAL WE
APPRECIATE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS THE FINAL PANEL APPROACH TO
THEM AND COURAGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO STAND UP AND
STRETCH.
THIS IS A SHORT RECESS BREAK.
BEFORE THE NEXT PANEL COMES
FORWARD.
REPORTER.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHILE.
WE TALKED ABOUT.
COLOR OF LAW AND THE FACT THAT
THOSE ARE STILL VERY RECENT LAWS
THAT.
WERE ON THE BOOKS WHAT WE DIDN'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT WAS THE ROLE
WE TALKED ABOUT NIMBIS WILL WE
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE ROLE.
BIAS IMPLICIT IN OTHERWISE.
PLAYS AS AN ADDITIONAL LAYER
INTO HOW PEOPLE RESPOND TO THE
HOMELESS POPULATION THAT WE ALL.
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR HAVE THIS
OR RESPONSE TO BUT WHEN PEOPLE
DON'T LOOK LIKE YOU AND YOU
KERRY AN INTERNAL BIAS HOW THAT
ALSO COMPLICATE YOUR ABILITY. TO
BE OPEN --
TO THERE IS HOUSING OPTIONS AND
I DO THINK THAT WAS IT.
THE THING WE TALK ABOUT
EXPLICITLY BUT IT CAN'T BE
IGNORED.
EVERYBODY TAKING THEIR STRETCH
RECESS BRIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
REFER [inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
THE STATE RESPONSE RECENT
ACTIONS IN IMPLEMENTING NEW
PROGRAMS PANEL --
FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS --
TO THE AGENDA.
AND WERE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
POLICY THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT ZACH
HOMESTAND.
WILL HEAR FROM MARK STIVERS
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT.
FOLLOWED BY.
FIVE PRONOUNCE YOUR FIRST NAME
FOR ME FRIENDS ASK FRIENDS ASK
FRANCE F. MARTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY.
AARON FOLLOWED BY GINNY.
HAD A FOOT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE HOMELESS COORDINATING IN.
FINANCING COUNCIL I'M GLAD TO
MEET YOU.
WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON --
I'M CYCLE THE DIVISION OF
HOUSING POLICY DEVELOPMENT AT A
CD -- SO THE
DIVISION I EVER SEE IS TASKED
WITH PROVIDING POLICY EXPERTISE
IN ALL HOUSING ISSUES INCLUDING
DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING NEW
POLICY -- A
LOT OF WHICH WAS FROM THE
HOUSING PACKAGE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE ALSO --
ARE THE PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE PROVIDE
THE REGIONAL NEEDS --
A STAR THE IDDLE HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATIONS AS WELL AS IN REVIEW
AND APPROVAL HOUSING ELEMENTS
FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
START WITH THAT.
SO MANY ASPECTS OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE AS WELL SOME
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR'S COME TO
ON MY DIVISION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
TODAY I'M GONNA SPEAK ABOUT --
SPECIFICALLY THE PLANNING GRANTS
THAT WERE PART OF SB TO THE
BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS ACT
WHICH I AS YOU ALL KNOW CREATED
AN ONGOING REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THE STATE. 250% OF THE FIRST
YEAR'S RUNNER REVENUES GENERATED
LAST YEAR WHEN SPECIFICALLY FOR
PLANNING GRANTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COMBINED --
THAT HALF IS ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MILLION AVAILABLE AS
OF FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH WE ARE
STILL.
WAITING FOR THE FINAL REVENUES A
TRICK ONE FROM TWENTY SEVEN SR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR SB TO FOR
ABOUT ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION RIGHT NOW.
THE PLAN GRANTS ARE TO BE USED
TO HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES
UPDATE PLANNING DOCUMENTS AND
ZONING ORDINANCES SO SOME YOUR
QUESTIONS EARLIER HOPEFULLY
THIS'LL AT SOME CLARITY --
THAT CAME UP TO ALSO BE USED TO
IMPLEMENT PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
TO STREAMLINE HOUSING APPROVALS
AND ACCELERATE HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
FACILITY HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
PARTICULAR FOR LOWER AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
PROMOTE DEVELOP A CONSISTENT
WITH CITY PLANNING --
PRIORITIES.
THESE GRANTS EIGHT MONTH OVER
THE COUNTER PROCESS. TO
JURISDICTIONS TO ONE HAVE A H.
E. APPROVED VALID HOUSING
ELEMENT COMPLAIN HOUSING ELEMENT
HAVE SUBMITTED A RECENT ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORT TO THE STATE.
DEMONSTRATE THE PROPOSED
ACTIVITY HAS A NEXUS TO
ACCELERATE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND OF COURSE ARE CONSISTENT
WITH STATE HOUSING LAN PARTIES.
WE ISSUED OUR GUIDELINES OUR
FINAL GUIDELINES FOR THESE
PLANNING GRANTS IN DECEMBER AND
WE PLAN ON ISSUING THE NOTICE
THE FUNDING BILL AVAILABILITY AT
THE END OF NEXT MONTH.
WE HAVE CREATED WE TO FAST TRACK
THE AWARDS BY LISTING IN THE
GUIDELINES SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES
WHICH HAT WE HAVE DETERMINED
ASSISTANT EXHORTING HOUSING
PRODUCTION CITY SERVICES THE PRE
APPROVED.
IT AND IF I POLICY PURDY AREAS
WHERE THEIR AUTOMATIC YOU WILL
BE DEEMED WORTHY TV ACCELERATE
HOUSING PRODUCTION WITHOUT THE
NEED FOR FURTHER DEMONSTRATION
OR NEXUS.
SOME OF THESE ACTIVITIES ARE A
REZONING LAND TO PERMIT HOUSING
BY RIGHT.
CREATING OBJECTIVE DESIGN AND
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS.
RATING SPECIFIC PLANS COUPLED
WITH SICK WITH STREAMLINING. TO
POINT SENATOR CASKEY ENCOURAGING
EXCESS READ WILLING YOU DIDN'T
UNITS AND OTHER INNOVATIVE
BUILDING STRATEGIES --
INITIATING EXPEDITED PROCESSING
SO I GOT THE PERMIT THAT'S WHAT
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES.
THE MINIMUM AWARD IS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND A MAXIMUM
WARD IS A SLIDING SCALE BASED ON
POPULATION ESTIMATES SO --
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR A
LARGE CITY OF OVER. 200-100-0200
FIFTY THOUSAND FOUR A MEDIUM
SITS AYE CITY BETWEEN SIXTY
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PERSONS AND HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOR SMALLER LOCALITIES
UP -- TO
SIXTY THOUSAND COUPLED WITH
THESE PLANNING GRANTS WE ARE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FUNDED BY 5% OF THIS PLANNING
SHEER.
AND IT'S INTENDED TO HELP YOUR
SIX AND I DE STRATEGIES WORK
BEST FOR THEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO EXPEDITE AND GET TO INCREASE
TOSSING PRODUCTION.
SO ARE --
PURCHASE A CONSISTENT IS IN THE
FOLLOWING FOUR CATEGORIES.
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO
JURISDICTIONS SELF ASSESSMENT
TOOLS TO IDENTIFY BOTTLENECKS
IDENTIFY WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
IMPROVE PROCESSES EXCELLENT
PRODUCTION.
KIND OF BEST PRACTICES AND TOOL
KITS THAT CAN BE USED ACROSS THE
BOARD AND THE COORDINATION WITH
OUR REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO THAT
THOSE TECHNICAL SCHOOLS CAN BE
DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE THOSE TOOK ITS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL FOCUS ON PROVEN
EXAMPLES THAT HAVE LED TO
HOUSING PRODUCTIONS WHICH
INCLUDES SPEAKER STREAMLINING BY
RIGHT ZONING.
EXPEDITED PERMIT PROCESSING FOR
EXAMPLE.
AND WE HAD ACTUALLY EXECUTE A
CONTRACT WITH AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED POLICE WORKS FINE WAS A
CONTRACT ON FEBRUARY SIXTH. TO
ASSIST IN DELIVERING THIS
TECHNICAL SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THEY'LL DRESS FOR
MAJOR DELIVERABLES HELPING
HELPING.
PROMOTE THOSE POLICY PRIORITY
AREAS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
ACCELERATING THOSE KIND OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION TOOL KITS.
MARKETING AND OUTREACH A COURSE
OF PLANNING OR INTO A MIXTURE
EVERY JURISDICTION CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE AND AND
DIRECT ASSISTANCE APPLICANTS IF
HE'D.
SO THEY WILL ALSO DEVELOP AN
AUDIT TOOL TO ENGAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN IDENTIFYING
BRIGHT THE RIGHT POTENTIAL
ACTIVITIES FOR THEM.
SO THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THESE
ACTIVITIES.
FUNDED WILL A HELPFUL
GOVERNMENT'S OBVIOUSLY BE BETTER
POSITIONED ALSO ACCESS THE
MYRIAD OF RESOURCES WE HAVE
COMING DOWN THE PIPELINE RIGHT
TO ACTUALLY CREATE MORE HOUSING
MORE FOR WILL HOUSING.
SO -- MARKS
I RESERVE MY COLLEAGUE FROM OUR
TO BE I'M HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE EIGHT SOME
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON A MARKS
DIVERS ON THE ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE OF THE DIVISION EACH
CITY THAT PUTS OUT MOST THE LOAN
AND GRANT PROGRAMS.
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO DILIGENTLY TO
IMPLEMENT THE HOUSING PACKAGE OF
MEASURES FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AS WELL AS THE BONDS
THAT WERE APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
IN THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR --
I'M GONNA START A LITTLE BIT
WITH THE SB TWO PROGRAMS --
BECAUSE THAT SORT OF OVER THE
WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON MOST
CURRENTLY SO AS TO AS ACT
MENTIONED THE SB TO PROGRAM
TWENTY FIRST YOUR COMPONENT.
AND 50% OF THAT MONEY WENT TO TO
PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE MINISTERING
THE FIRST --
IS THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS AND HOUSING
PROGRAM IT GETS HALF OF THAT
MONEY SO --
IS GEARED TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
AS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN
MANY OF THE PRESENTATIONS IT'S A
FLEXIBLE SOURCE. TO TO COUNTIES
THROUGH ENTITIES DESIGNATED BY
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE TO SPEND
ON THE STRATEGIES PRIORITIES
THAT THEY HAVE IT CAN BE FROM
RAPID RE HOUSING TO ADD
NAVIGATION SHELTERS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING AS THE SORT OF HOW THEY
SEE FIT.
AYE WE'VE ALREADY GRANTED THE
FIRST.
ROUND OF FUNDING TO EVERY SINGLE
COMMUTE KING A CONTINUED KERR
DID APPLY AND WE GIVE GRANTS TO
EACH.
ONE WITH A TOTAL OF FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ADDED SO THE SOME OF THAT
MONEY WAS NOT SB.
SO WITH A LITTLE BIT BIGGER IN
THAT FIRST ROUND THAT IT WILL BE
IN THE SECOND ROUND BUT NONE THE
LESS WE AND WE WILL HAVE A
SECOND ROUND IN MARCH OF THIS
YEAR THAT'S ROUTE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
AGAIN EACH CONTINUE OF CARE DID
RECEIVE THEIR FIRST ROUND GRANTS
WERE EXPECTS TO USE THE
APPLICATION FROM EACH CONTAINING
OF CARE IN THE SECOND ROUND.
BUT THAT IS A ONE TIME WHEN YOUR
PROGRAM --
THE SECOND TRANCHE OF SB TWO
FUND'S OF WEIRD MINISTERING IS --
WAS TESTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROGRAM CALLED THE HEALTHY
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIANS.
IN THE IDEA OF THIS PROGRAM
REALLY IS.
TO BUILD SUPPORT PRESS FOR
HOUSING FOR FOLKS ON MEDICARE
WHO ARE VERY FREQUENT USERS
THESE ARE THE FOLKS WHO COST THE
STATE AND COUNTY THE MOST
DOLLARS A MEDICAL HEALTH CARE.
VARIOUS STUDIES SHOW THAT IF YOU
HOUSE FOLKS IT'S ACTUALLY
CHEAPER TO HOUSE FOLKS THEN IT'S
KEEP PROVIDING THIS LEVEL OF
SORT OF MERGING TO CARE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS --
SO WE WILL HAVE --
FOR THIS YEAR ABOUT NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT SIXTY THAT
FROM THE SB TO FUNDS. THIRTY SIX
MILLION OF THAT FROM THE
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
RICHER FEDERAL FUNDS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA.
A AND THAT WILL GO OUT --
IN -- MARCH
WITH A NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY.
AND IT AGAIN THAT THAT MONEY IS
ONLY AVAILABLE FOR ORDERS FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AGAIN FOR THIS MEDI CAL
POPULATION.
ABOUT THAT WE WILL START TAKING
APPLICATIONS IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS SO WE HOPE TO HAVE THOSE
AWARDS LATER THIS YEAR.
AND SO THAT'S THE FIRST YEAR OF
THE SB TO FUND THE WE'RE MISSING
TO THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
VISION STARTING YOUR TO THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED US.
TO GIVE 70% OF THE MONEY FROM
THE SB TO REVENUES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SO WITH THE
PERMANENT LOCAL HOUSING PROGRAM --
WILL HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
WE HAVE PUT OUT OF FRAME IS BY
FORMULA AND I WILL SAY THAT WHEN
YOU GET THE FORMULA USES THE
COMMUNITY ALL THE BLOCK GRANT
FORMULA.
WHEN YOU START GETTING THE SOME
OF THE SMALLER CITIES THE
AMOUNTS THAT WERE GIVING OUT ARE
QUITE SMALL I'D SAY OF THE THE
THE SMALLEST GROUP OF CITY THE
AVERAGE ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT THEY WOULD GET EACH?
EVEN THE NEXT TROTTER CITIES OUT
THE AVERAGE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SO YOU KNOW
SOMETHING YOU KNOW WE MAY
MONITOR THINK ABOUT AS WAS IS --
IN MISTER THIS PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD --
BUT NONE THE LESS --
WE'RE HAVE PUT OUT A DRAFT
FRAMING PAPERWORK GETTING SOME
IDEAS FROM FROM THE COMMUNITY ON
SORT OF HOW WE WANT.
TO ADMINISTER THAT PROGRAM WE WE
PUT WE INTEND TO PUT OUT DRAFT
GUIDELINES IN APRIL AND START.
ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS IN AUGUST --
BUT YET SO WE ARE MOVING IN WITH
THAT PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD.
AND THEN I ALSO WE ALSO TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE KNOW PLACES
LIKE HOME NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM THIS IS AGAIN A USES
FUNDS IN A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACTED TO HOUSE FOR
PERSONS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS --
IT WAS THE SUBJECT OF FOR THE
PROPOSITION TWO ON THE BALLOT IN
NOVEMBER THAT THE WITH THE VOTER
SORT OF VALIDATED THIS APPROACH.
WE HAVE ALREADY.
NO EVEN EVEN BEFORE THE BALLOT
MEASURE WAS APPROVED IN
ANTICIPATION OF THAT WE PUT OUT
A COMPENDIUM A NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY FOR NON COMPETITIVE
FUNDS.
SOME OF THE FUNDS ARE GO BYE BYE
FORMULA TO COUNTIES.
AND AND THAT IS OPEN TO COUNTIES
FOR YEAR TO COME IN AND AND
REQUEST THOSE FUNDS.
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR AGAIN
BEFORE THE BALLOT BEFORE THE
ELECTION --
WE OPEN UP THE COMPETITION FOR
THE COMPETITIVE SIDE WE HAD FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE --
AND I WILL KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
A FOR COUNTIES IF THEY HAVE MORE
THAN 5% THE STATE'S HOLD
POPULATION THINKING CAN KIND O
COMBINE THOSE COMPETITIVE NON
COMPETITIVE OUT AND GET A BLOCK
GRANT.
WE ARE ABOUT TO WARD THOSE FUNDS
TO THREE VERY LARGE COUNTIES --
WE EXPECT TO GET AN APPLICATION
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ALSO IN THE
NEAR FUTURE BUT SO SO THOSE FOR
CANADA GOING TO KIND OF RUN THE
PROGRAM ON THEIR OWN.
THE FOR THE REST OF THE STATE --
WE JUST PUT OUT A NO FOR FOR OUR
COMPETITIVE FUNDS --
WE HAD A NINE HUNDRED AND NINETY
FOUR MEN SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION
AVAILABLE SO WE ARE GOING
THROUGH AND READING AND WRITING
THOSE APPLICATIONS NOW --
WE WILL BE ABLE TO FIND MOST OF
THE APPLICATIONS OBVIOUSLY BUT
NOT ALL.
AND THEN LASTLY --
YOU KNOW WE AVE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROGRAMS FROM
THE SB THREE HOUSING BONDS THAT
WE ARE MISSING WE WE INTEND TO
PUT OUT SIX NOTICES THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE.
NOTICES THE FUNDING AVAILABILITY
IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS --
THAT TO KIND OF KEEP THOSE
PROGRAMS OING ON SORT OF A
LITTLE BIT OF A STAGGERED
SCHEDULE --
THE FIRST ONE WILL BE THE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM WHICH IS
I I WOULD SAY OUR MAIN.
KIND OF WORK COURSE RENTAL
HOUSING --
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
PROGRAM AND THAT WILL GO OUT --
IN APRIL FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
SO BOTTOM LINE IS WE ARE TRYING
TO DILIGENTLY PUT THE MONEY OUT
IN AN EXPEDITIOUS MANNER WE'RE
TRYING TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND HOW
WE SORT OF STRUCTURE THESE
PROGRAMS --
LOOKING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
OUR GUIDELINES BEFORE WE SORT OF
PUT THE PROGRAMS OUT --
BUT WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE FAST
TO GET THAT MONEY AT THE DOOR
BECAUSE WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
THE HOUSING NEEDS ARE DIRE AND
EXTREME AT THIS MOMENT AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THOSE PROJECTS THE
RENT READY TO GO ON ON THE
GROUND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON HOW MY NAME IS
FRIENDS ASK MARTY.
ON I'M THE NEW LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK HERE ON BEHALF OF COLLEGE
OF FAYE AND OF OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TIA BOWMAN PATTERSON.
AS YOU ARE ALL AWARE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS IS
REACHING ALARMING LEVELS.
AFFECTS BROAD SEGMENTS OF OUR
SOCIETY HANDS ON DECK APPROACH
WITH DIFFERENT AGENCIES WORKING
IN CONCERT WITH ONE ANOTHER.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE'RE
SEEING MORE ENERGY BOLD IDEAS
AND FOCUS ON SOLVING THE HOUSING
CRISIS THAN ANY TIME IN RECENT
MEMORY.
AT AT AT AT COLLEGE OF A FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS WE HAVE BEEN BE
TOOLING OUR AGENCY.
I HAVE BECOME MORE EFFICIENT AT
SERVING MORE LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE HAVE BUILT AN IMPRESSIVE
PUBLIC PRIVATE ENGINE THAT STAND
READY TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO HOUSING CRISIS.
FOSTER MAY GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND ABOUT OUR AGENCY
OR REASON ACCOMPLISHMENTS ON THE
STATUS OF A CURRENT WORK.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW COLLEGE
OFFICIALS AS A STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LENDER I WAS CREATED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO DEVELOP
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN STATE GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE CAPITAL INVESTORS
COLLEGE OF A IS UNIQUE BECAUSE
WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT SELF FUNDED
AGENCY.
WE FINANCIAL OPERATIONS FROM
REVENUES GENERATED WHO ARE
LENDING ACTIVITY AND WE INVEST
ANY EARNINGS IN TWO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE PROVIDE LOW COST DEBT
FINANCING RAISED IN PRIVATE
CAPITAL MARKETS WHICH SERVES TO
COMPLEMENT OUR SISTER AGENCY A
CD THAT PROVIDE FEDERAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT FUNDED
SUBSIDIES.
ON THE SINGLE FAMILY SIDE WE
OFFER MORTGAGES TO A NETWORK OF
LENDING PARTNERS WE PARA
MORTGAGES WITH DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND CLOSING COST
ASSISTANCE. FOR LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS MOST OF THEM
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
INCLUDING.
MIXED INCOME HOUSING SPECIAL
NEEDS HOUSING HOUSING FOR
SENIORS AND HOUSING FOR VETERANS.
THE SCOPE AND APPROACH THE
CONTINUUM OF HOUSING NEEDS IS
ADDRESSED IN COLLEGE OF ITS
MISSION.
THAT WHICH IS TO CREATE AND
FINANCE PROGRESSIVE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS SO MORE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE A PLACE TO CALL HOME. TO
GIVE YOU A BIT OF AN UPDATE ON
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON AT
COLLEGE OF A WHOLE SHOW WITH YOU
IF YOU.
ARE RECENT ACHIEVEMENTS IN THREE
KEY AREAS HOMEOWNERSHIP MULTI
FAMILY UNDER OVERALL FINANCIAL
POSITION.
FIRST A FEW METRICS --
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
LAST YEAR COLLEGE OF A CLOSED ON
OVER TWO BILLION IN MORTGAGES
FINEST THROUGH A PRIVATE CAPITAL
MARKETS HISTORIC HIGH FOR THE
AGENCY.
THAT HAS ALLOWED US TO SERVE
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ALLOW THEM TO BECOME
HOMEOWNERS FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR WE ARE PROJECTED TO
BREAK THAT RECORD AGAIN.
AND FINANCE THREE BILLION IN
MORTGAGES SERVING OVER TEN
THOUSAND HOUSING.
ANOTHER IMPRESSIVE METRIC IS THE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
WORTH OF DOWN PAYMENT AND
CLOSING COSTS ASSISTANCE FOR
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS THAT WE
HAVE DELIVERED IN THE LAST YEAR.
AND THE PEOPLE WE SERVE AT
COLLEGE OF A ARE AS DIVERSE AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ITSELF
WE ARE PROUD TO SAY THAT OVER
TWO THIRDS OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
WE HELP.
BECOME HOMEOWNERS IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WERE TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED BLACK AND BROWN BE
OUR WORST.
THIS SECOND AREA WHERE I WANT TO
SHARE SOME --
SOME REASON MILESTONES IS OUR
MULTI THE FATE LAST YEAR.
PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
A MILLION AND FINANCING TO HELP
CREATE OR PRESERVE TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED UNITS OF MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING.
SINCE THE EIGHT INSTANCE
INCEPTION WE HAVE CREATED.
AND PRESERVED MORE THAN SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND UNITS.
OF MULTI FAMILY HOUSING AND
PROVIDE A FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FINANCING.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
CONTINUOUSLY INCREASED OUR
UTILIZATION OF PRIVATE ACTIVITY
BONDS PROVIDING THREES.
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION IN BOND FINANCING.
THE USE OF PRIVATE ACTIVITY
BONDS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
GENERATE THE 4% LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT WHICH IS A
VITAL SOURCE TO BUILDING MOST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE THIRD AREA LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IS OURFINANCIAL
STRENGTH WHICH HAS BEEN IN
KNOWLEDGE WHETHER TWO MAJOR
CREDIT RATING AGENCIES MOODY'S
AND FINANCIAL AND POURS --
THEY HAVE RAISED A CREDIT RATING
SPEND TIMES IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND ME AND ARE MOODY'S
RATING IS A ONE WITH POSITIVE
OUTLOOK OR AS A B. RATING IS A
PLUS WITH A POSITIVE OUTLOOK.
BOTH RATING AGENCIES ATTRIBUTE
ARE CREATING QUITE A RATING
UPGRADES TO EXPERIENCE
MANAGEMENT AND FIVE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS OF STRENGTH IT EQUITY AND
PROFITABILITY RATIO.
OUR RATINGS ARE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AS A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION THESE RATINGS GIVE
US THE ABILITY TO ACCESS CAPITAL
AND HELP MORE FAMILIES.
SOMEOF THE MOST EXCITING
INITIATIVE WE ARE CURRENTLY
ROLLING OUT ARE RELATED TO THE
HOUSING PACKAGE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS YOU
HEARD A SHE IS IMPLEMENTING THE
MAJORITY OF THIS PACKAGE BUT
COLLEGE OF A HAS A HAS A ROLE AS
WELL PROP ONE BUYS BY VOTERS
LAST NOVEMBER ALLOCATE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION. TO COLLEGE OF
A FOR DOWN PAYMENT AND CLOSING
COSTS ASSISTANCE FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS WITH LOW TO MODERATE
INCOMES.
THIS WILL BE USED TO EXPAND OUR
EXISTING DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE TO ME WITHA WITH THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION WE WILL WE BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE DOWN PAYMENT OR CLOSING
COST ASSISTANCE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL. TWENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE NEXT --
WALL PROP ONE FUNDING IS ONE
TIME AS BE.
TO PROVIDES AN ONGOING PERMANENT
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND STARTING IN
20001915% OF SB TWO FUNDS WILL
FLOW TO COLLEGE OF A FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CREATING.
MAKES THE INCOME MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING.
OVER THE PAST YEAR COLLEGE OF A
HAS ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS AND USED
THEIR INPUT TO DESIGN A NEW
MAKES INCOME PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IS THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND
SPECIALLY ITS SPONSORS AND A PRO
TEM ATKINS FOR PARTNERING WITH
US.
AND MAKING THIS PROGRAM POSSIBLE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE WERE
EXCITED TO OPEN OUR APPLICATION
FOR THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
PROGRAM WHICH MAKES FORTY
MILLION AVAILABLE AND IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE FINANCING TO
SUPPORT THE PRODUCTION.
OF UP TO ELEVEN HUNDRED NEW
UNITS FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE MIX INCOME IT PROGRAM IS
PRODUCTION FOCUSED IT'S DESIGNED
THIS GAP FINANCING FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THAT PLAN ON USING BONDS AND TAX
CREDITS BUT NEED ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO PENCIL OUT.
THIS PROJECT WILL SERVE A BROAD
RANGE OF INCOMES ANYWHERE
BETWEEN 30% AND A 100% OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
WE ARE ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS TO
APRIL THIRTIETH AND WILL BE
ANNOUNCING AWARDS IN THE SUMMER.
AS YOU CAN SEE WOULD BUILD UP
POWERFUL PUBLIC PRIVATE EGET AT
COLLEGE OF IT HAS THE CAPACITY.
TO HELP WITH THE HOW THE CRISIS
WE STARTED READY TO COLLABORATE
WITH PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS TO SOLVE
ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING TIME
HIS HEART.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE --
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M TO ANYBODY FOOT
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
IN MY REMARKS THIS AFTERNOON
WILL ADDRESS BRIEFLY THE ROLE
AND SCOPE OF THE COUNCIL.
SOME OF THE MAJOR ACTIVITIES AND
DELIVERABLES WERE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON AND THE STATUS OF THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
ARE HEAP AS WELL AS SOME LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THAT PROGRAM TO
DATE.
TURNING FIRST TO THE ROLE AND
SCOPE OF THE COUNCIL AS YOU KNOW
THE COUNCIL WAS ESTABLISHED IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY A
SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY CHAIRED A
AUTHORED BY A ARE CHAIR --
SENATOR MITCHELL TO OVERSEE THE
OF HOUSING FIRST GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS AND AMONGOTHER
THINGS TO IDENTIFY AND
COORDINATE STATE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES TO PREVENT AN ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
THE COUNCIL WAS INITIALLY HOUSED
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
AND IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET --
IT WAS MOVED TO THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY.
THE CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL --
WAS DESIGNATED --
TO BE THE SECRETARY OF THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY.
AND THE BUDGET ALSO PROVIDED
FUNDING TO HIRE FULL TIME STAFF
OF WHICH ONE IS MYSELF. TO
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTING HOUSE ALL
OF THE COUNCIL MANDATES
INCLUDING HE THE COUNCIL IS
COMPRISED UP TO NINETEEN MEMBERS
REPRESENTING STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS.
WITH PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY STAKE
HOLDERS.
THE COUNCIL MEETS QUARTERLY AND
COUNCILMEMBERS PROVIDE INPUT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE THE COUNCIL'S GOALS.
THERE IS AN INTERAGENCY WORKING
GROUP THAT MEETS TWICE A MONTH
TO SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
COUNCIL.
PROVIDING INPUT AND SUPPORT TO
COUNSEL STAFF IN ACHIEVING
COUNCIL GOALS.
CURRENTLY THE MAJOR FOCUS OF THE
INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP IS
IMPLEMENTING HOUSING FIRST.
TURNING NEXT TO THE COUNCIL'S
CURRENT WORK IN ADDITION TO
IMPLEMENTING KEEP WHICH I WILL
COVER IN MORE DETAIL SHORTLY.
THE COUNSELORS IMPLEMENTING
SEVERAL OTHER IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES.
AS I MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO WORK
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT HOUSING
FIRST ACROSS ALL STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS WITH HOUSING AND
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES
PROGRAMS.
A CHECKLIST FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
USE PROGRAMS AND IDENTIFYING ANY
CHANGES NEEDED TO REGULATIONS
AND GUIDELINES WAS DEVELOPED.
SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS HAVE DONE
THEIR ASSESSMENTS AND MADE
PRESENTATIONS TO THE COUNCIL TO
DATE OF THOSE ARE MY TWO SISTER
AGENCIES SITTING.
BY LEFT --
CAL HFA --
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ALONG WITH
THE TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE REMAINING DEPARTMENTS
REPRESENTED ON THE COUNCIL --
TO COMPLETE THEIR HOUSING FIRST
ASSESSMENTS AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT ALL THE INITIAL ASSESSMENTS
AND CHANGES NEEDED TO GUIDELINES --
WILL BE COMPLETE BY JULY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
REQUIRED IN STATUTE.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF DATA AS SENATORS SKINNER
MENTIONED EARLIER AND SO WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
POTENTIAL STATE LEVEL HOMELESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE DATA
NECESSARY TO MAKE INFORMED
POLICY DECISIONS TO BETTER ALIGN
OUR RESOURCES WITH THE NEEDS OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATIONS IN OUR
STATE.
THE IMMEDIATE PRIORITY PHASE ONE
IS ESTABLISHING A STATE HOMELESS
DATA SYSTEM THAT GIVES THE STATE
ACCESS TO DATA THAT IS CURRENTLY
ALREADY BEING COLLECTED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
THROUGH HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS.
THE SECOND PHASE WOULD BE TO
BUILD A PLATFORM THAT CAN ALSO
INTEGRATE.
AND ANALYZE DATA COLLECTED FROM
STATE AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS OTHER LOCAL
SOURCES.
IF FUNDING IS MADE OF A
AVAILABLE FOR THIS WORK
PROCUREMENT FOR PHASE ONE WHICH
IS AGAIN GETTING ACCESS TO DATA
ALREADY COLLECTED.
COULD BEGIN IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'RE ALSO
EMBARKING ON AN INITIATIVE TO
DEVELOP A DATA DRIVEN EVIDENCE
BASED HIGH LEVEL STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR THE STATE.
THIS WORK WILL FOCUS ON
IDENTIFYING STATE STRATEGIES TO
STOP THE GROWTH IN HOMELESSNESS
SHELTER THE ON SHELTERED AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE OVERALL
NUMBERS OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A FIRST STEP IN THIS WORK WE
ISSUED AN INVITATION TO THE
RESEARCH POLICY AND PROGRAM
EXPERTS IN CALIFORNIA. TO
PROVIDE US WITH BRIEF WHITE
PAPERS ON THEIR EVIDENCE BASED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SPECIFIC
PRIORITY ACTIONS THE STATE
SHOULD TAKE IN THE NEXT ONE TO
THREE YEARS.
AND FINALLY WERE WORKING WITH
OUR STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS
TO COLLABORATE IN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEER TO PEER
LEARNING. FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND TO LOOK FOR
OTHER WAYS TO COORDINATE STATE
AND FEDERAL HOMELESSNESS
ACTIVITIES AND ALIGN PROGRAM
GOALS REQUIREMENTS AND TIMELINES
WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
TURNING NOW TO AN UPDATE ON KEEP.
AS YOU KNOW THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY.
AID PROGRAMMER HEAP AS WE CALL
LISTEN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
IT'S A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME FLEXIBLE BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE.
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONTINUES OF CARE.
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS ARE THE
ELEVEN LARGEST CITIES THOSE WITH
A POPULATION OF THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND AS OF JULY
AS OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THE
FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
AND FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED USING A
FORMULA THAT'S BASED LARGELY ON
THE JURISDICTION SHARE OF THE
STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
THE PROGRAM GUIDANCE WHICH
MAPPED OUT APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS AN ALLOWABLE
ACTIVITIES WAS ISSUED IN AUGUST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE NOTICE
OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY WAS
ISSUED ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH AND
THE FIRST TWO APPLICATIONS FROM
THE CITY OF OAKLAND IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO WERE ALSO WERE
SUBMITTED ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH.
WE RECEIVED APPLICATIONS FROM
ALL FORTY THREE CONTINUES OF
CARE AND THE ELEVEN LARGE CITIES
BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS
THE CUT OFF DATE FOR ROUND ONE
OF FUNDING.
AND THIS I REALLY GOOD NEWS
BECAUSE IT MEANS A SECOND ROUND
OF FUNDING IS NOT NEEDED.
AND ONCE HE FUNDS OF ALL BEEN
DISPERSED THE HEAP TEAM WILL
TURN ITS ATTENTION TO PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO THE COUNT THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE IN CITIES AS THE IMPLEMENT
THEIR HEAT FUNDED PROGRAMS.
I BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
GIVEN A CHART THAT SUMMARIZES
THANK YOU GOOD.
SO I'LL JUST TOUCH ON A COUPLE
OF KEY KEY POINTS. ONE WE
CONSISTENTLY MET OUR INTERNAL
GOAL OF AWARDING HEAP FUNDS
WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS OF RECEIPT
OF A COMPLETED APPLICATION.
WE ALSO CONSISTENTLY MATTER IN
COULD TORNAL GOAL OF DISBURSING
KEEP FUNDS WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS
OF RECEIPT OF AN EXECUTED
STANDARD AGREEMENT. FOR A 100%
OF THESE GRANTS WE HAVE MET OUR
COMMITMENT TO DISPERSE HEAP
FUNDS IN THIS IS DISPERSED IN A
SINGLE PAYMENT.
ONCE THE CONTRACT HAS BEEN
EXECUTED.
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF THE DAY
SHIN WAS WAS DEEMED COMPLETE.
AS OF FEBRUARY NINETEENTH MORE
THAN 80% OF ALL HE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN DISPERSED.
ALL OF THE ELEVEN LARGE CITIES
HAVE RECEIVED THEIR
DISBURSEMENTS SO THOSE FUNDS ARE
OUT IN THESE COMMUNITIES ALREADY
HOPEFULLY DOING SOME GOOD --
SO FAR THE CITIES AND CONTINUES
OF CARE THAT HAVE BEEN AWARDED
HE FUNDS HAVE COMMITTED TO
ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS IN THE
FOLLOWING MAJOR CATEGORIES.
THE TOP CATEGORY IS SERVICES
WITH ABOUT 38% OF THE TOTAL
FUNDS.
NEXT IS CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR OF TOTAL HE
FUNDS.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE HAS BEEN --
PROPOSED 413% OF TOTAL FUNDS
AWARDED.
HOMELESS YOUTH HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED ALMOST 7% OF TOTAL HE
FUNDING AND WE WERE PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THIS IS HIGHER.
THAN THE 5% SET ASIDE REQUIRED
FOR USING HE FUNDS.
AND LIKEWISE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS --
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED LESS THAN 5%
CAP THAT WAS ALSO ALLOWED IN
HEAT.
WITH ABOUT 4% OF TOTAL FUNDS
GOING FOR ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEN OTHER WHICH INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE --
BATHROOMS AND HAND WASHING
STATIONS OF REPRESENT ABOUT 3%
OF TOTAL FUNDS.
TURNING FINALLY TO LESSONS
LEARNED FROM HEAT.
IT'S CLEARLY EARLY DAYS WITH THE
PROGRAM WERE JUST IN THE IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING AND
DISBURSING THE REMAINING FUNDS.
ON BUT I THINK THERE ARE STILL A
FEW LESSONS LEARNED THAT I HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR SUCCESS IN
ESTABLISHING THE PROGRAM AND
DISBURSING THE FUNDS SO QUICKLY.
FIRST THE AUTHORIZING STATUTE
WAS CLEARER BUT NOT TO DIRECTIVE
IN THE MAJOR PROGRAM STRUCTURE
ELIGIBLE APPLIQUE APPLICANTS AND
USES AN ALLOCATION FORMULA
PROVISIONS.
IT ALLOWED US TO MOVE AHEAD%
QUICKLY AT THE SAME TIME GAVE US
ENOUGH DISCRETION TO MAKE THE
SPECIFIC DECISIONS BUT
INEVITABLY ARISE WHEN DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROGRAM.
SECOND WE DELIBERATELY SET OUT
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM AS SIMPLE
TRANSPARENT AND STREAMLINED AS
POSSIBLE.
WITH AN EYE ON HOW WE COULD MAKE
THINGS AS EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR
OUR APPLICANTS AND NOW OUR
GRANTEES.
WE TOOK FLEXIBILITY TO HEART THE
WORKING HARDTO ENSURE
SUFFICIENT GUIDANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS WHY RECEIVED OUR FIRST
APPLICATIONS FROM SAN DIEGO IN
OAKLAND ON THE SAME DAY THAT WE
ISSUED THE NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY.
THIRD WE TOOK PARTNERSHIP
SERIOUSLY OF THE THREE POSITIONS
AUTHORIZED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT KEEP ONE IS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LIAISON WHOSE PRIMARY
ROLE IS TO DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONTINUES OF CARE.
KEEP STUFF SPENT A LOT OF TIME
LAST FALL AND ACTUALLY TWO OF MY
STAFF FOR DOING PRESENTATIONS AS
I SPEAK --
DOING PRESENTATIONS AND WEBINARS
ACROSS THE STATE HOLDING WEEKLY
OFFICE HOURS AND ANSWERING A
LARGE NUMBER OF EMAILS AND CALLS.
THROUGHOUT THE APPLICATION
PERIOD THE TEAM ALSO PROVIDED
ONE ON ONE SUPPORT AND DIRECTING
GAUGE MEANT WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHICH WAS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LIAISON
CONTINUES TO HOLD WEEKLY OFFICE
HOURS IN WHICH ALL CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONTINUES OF CARE.
CAN CALL IN TO DISCUSS ANY TOPIC
WITH BOTH THE STAFF AND WITH
THEIR PEERS.
AND FINALLY WE KNOW THE WORK IS
NOT OVER.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE REAL
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM MEANING
THE FUNDS ARE USED EFFECTIVELY%
AND EFFICIENTLY AND MAKE REAL
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
WE MISCHIEF QUICKLY INTO
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING GOOD REPORTING
PROCESS SEES AND MONITORING
PERFORMANCE OVER THE LIFE OF THE
GRANT.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OVERALL
APPROACH WE WILL ENGAGE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES WITH THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO PARTNERSHIP
FOCUSING ON HOW WE CAN ASSIST
GRANTEES IN ACCOMPLISHING THEIR
GOALS.
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE PANEL --
FOR BEING HERE AND YOUR
TESTIMONY.
QUESTION CENTER MORE LAW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST HAD
ONE QUICK QUESTION [inaudible]
FOR MR --
HOMES THAT.
WHICH YOU DON'T ACTUALLY WAS --
FOR MISTER STIVERS SHOULD
MENTION SP TO GIVE US A AN
UPDATE.
I RECENTLY SPOKE TO AN ESCROW
ASSOCIATION AND THEY'RE YOUR
FRONTLINE THEY'RE COLLECTING
THIS FIGURED OUT I GET THE SENSE
ARE GETTING PUSHED BACK TO LIKE
WHY ARE WE PAYING. FOR THIS AND
WHERE IS IT GOING SO I'M
WONDERING IF MAYBE YOU COULD
THINK ABOUT COMMUNICATING WITH
THE ASSOCIATION'S UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
SO YOU PUT IT IN THEIR
pBEING SPENT.
IN YOUR AREA SO THAT YOU CAN.
IT COMMUNICATE THAT TO TO YOUR
CLIENTS WHEN THEY THE FAR
WHATEVER.
THEY DO.
BUT JUST JUST AN IDEA THAT IS A
GOOD IDEA WE CAN WORK WITH THE
THE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY TAX
COLLECTOR'S AND ASSESSORS IN AND
RECORDERS AND PROBABLY GET SOME
INFORMATION OUT TO THEM THAT
WOULD BE BY IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
QUESTIONS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ESCROW AGENTS WOULD BE GREAT.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU MENTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LOCKED
FOR A GOOD IDEA IN A SOLUTION
APPRECIATE TO WITH THE WHOLE
TIME WE DID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
NONE THANK YOU TO THE PANEL WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
WERE GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND GIVEN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE I
SEE QUEUING UP.
AND THE LATENESS OF THE HOUR
BECAUSE I KNOW I'M GONNA LOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU ALL TO KEEP YOUR REMARKS.
DOES THE LINE GETS LONGER.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU ALL TO KEEP
YOU THINK YOU YOUR REMARKS WITH
IN A MINUTE PLEASE.
FIRST WITNESS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M FAIR MCDADE
TING ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY --
I WANT TO SAY THAT --
COLLABORATION WITH COUNTIES AS
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE ARE A KEY COMPONENT
OF ANY HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ISSUE WE APPRECIATE ON THE U.
HEARING FROM LOCALS TODAY AS
WELL AS THE FOLKS ON THE LAST
PANEL ALL OF WHICH WE'VE BECOME
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THEY'VE DONE.
A LOT OF WORK TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH COUNTIES AND WAS C. SACK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS FUNDING IS
GOING OUT WHAT THE HOMELESSNESS
COORDINATING FINANCING COUNCIL
DID GETTING THE MONEY OUT WITHIN
FIFTEEN DAYS IS ON HEARD OF WE
TRULY APPRECIATE IT.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET --
AS INCLUDING THE LOCAL FIND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING.
THIS HEARING TODAY AND HAVING
THESE VOICES HEARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU I THINK WE FOUND IT
HELPFUL TO THE NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU MANAGER DAVID JOHNSON
HALF OF THREE SEPARATE CLANS.
OF FIRST THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE A
MENTION THIS TO MISTER WHITE
HOUSE YOU LEFT THEY'VE GOT A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM OVER SIX
THOUSAND OF THEIR HOUSING UNITS
HALF FOR AN H. AWAY THE DOESN'T
ALLOW EIGHTIES.
THEY DESPERATELY NEED WORKFORCE
HOUSING THEY'D LIKE TO SEEK THAT
ADDRESSED LEGISLATIVELY JUST
LIKE YOU DID FOR A TWO WAYS WITH
SOLAR SO THERE'S A PATTERN THERE.
SECONDLY BEHALF OF PASADENA WE
HAVE A HUGE GLUT OF HOUSING ITS
OWN BY CALTRANS THE WOUNDED FOR
MULTI DECADES AND WE ASKED SOME
ATTENTION OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS. TO SEE WE CAN EXPEDITE
SOME OF THAT TRANSITION
ESPECIALLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND LASTLY A BATH OF SAN ROSE IN
THE OTHER DISASTER STRICKEN
COMMUNITIES IF THERE'S FUNDING
AVAILABLE WE THINK A PRIORITY
FOR PARADISE FOR SANTA ROSA FOR
REBUILDING WE LOST FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS -- AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THIS
HOUSING MONEY GIVEN PRIORITY TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
BILLS THANK THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE COUNTY HAS SPENT
A LOT OF TIME AND INVESTMENT ON
ENDING HOMELESSNESS AND AND THEY
ARE WORKING ALONG WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR TOWARD
THAT AIM.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
INVESTMENTS MADE --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF INCLUDING
MILESTONES IN THIS CURRENT
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE FUNDING --
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED SHOULD BE --
DISPERSED THROUGH THEHEAP
PROCESS AND THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS AND HOUSING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION.
IF YOU MAY BE AWARE THAT WE
ESTABLISH THE HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION I'M AS A DIVISION --
TWO YEARS AGO IN ORDER TO HELP
LA COUNTY BUILD OUT OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS --
WE CONCLUDE THAT WE CANNOT BUILD
OUT IF WE'RE BUILDING HOUSING
UNITS AT FOUR HUNDRED PLUS
THOUSAND PER UNIT WHAT WE REALLY
DID DO IS FIND WAYS TO RE HAVE
OUR WAY OUT OF THE HIGHER
HOUSING CRISIS.
ECHOING A COUPLE THINGS I HEARD
DOG PREVIOUS PANEL MEMBERS SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE UNITS.
OF LOW INCOME HOUSING MOSTLY IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES BUT
EXTENDING WEST TO HOLLYWOOD AND
AS OF LAST WEEK EAST TO EL MONTE --
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE HOUSING --
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW INCOME
WHO ARE AT RISK OR OR ARE
HOMELESS AND TO GET THEM INTO
HOUSING RIGHT AWAY WE THINK MORE
ATTENTION NEEDS TO BE PAID TO
FINDING WAYS. TO TO RE HAVE
EXISTING FACILITIES MAKE THEM
LEVEL -- AND
PROVIDE THEM FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE RATHER THAN BUILDING FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR UNITS --
AS ARE ONLY HOUSING --
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS --
FOCUS THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL AND
MEMBERS OF THE CLEANING GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WESLEY
SAVER AND I'M A POLICY ADVOCATE
AT JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TWO BUDGET PROPOSALS.
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS ARE THE
FIRST PROPOSAL WOULD ADDRESS THE
MOUNTING CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS ACCORDING
TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND WANTED
FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS --
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS ARE TO
HELP MEET THIS NEED THE PROPOSAL
WOULD DEDICATE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO IMPLEMENT A
RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
HOMELESS STUDENTS ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES.
AND UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES PROGRAM WOULD REQUIRE
CAMPUSES THAT RECEIVE FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO MAXIMIZE
THE FINANCIAL AID THE HOME
STUDENTS RECEIVE.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDING FOR
HOUSING SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
FIGHT --
COORDINATING FINANCING COUNCIL
CAL THIS IN THE COUNTRY THE
SECOND HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
YOUTH WHO AREON SHELTER YET AS
FOUND IN THE COMMITTEE AGENDA
JUST ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
STATE'S ANNUAL SIX HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS --
SIX OR NINE MILLION DOLLARS IS
DEDICATED TO HOMELESSNESS ARE SO
WEIRD YOU SUPPORT --
THESE TWO IMPORTANT PROPOSALS
AND THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE PLEASE.
CHERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS --
GERRY DREW SO --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE SOON
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NEARLY
HALF A MILLION STUDENTS AT ALL
TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES ON AS
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTIONED
WE AND OUR SYSTEM HAVE TEN POINT
9% OF OUR STUDENTS WERE
SUFFERING FROM HOMELESSNESS
WHICH MEANS ABOUT.
BUDGETS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
JOINED WITH OUR OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATIONS YOU SEE.
AS SUCH TROUBLE SEE REPRESENTING
THE UC AND BUT YOU SEE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
ADVOCATING FOR SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE THIS.
AND ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR --
REQUEST TO UTILIZE RAPID RE
HOUSING ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
MADAM TO OUR SENATORS --
CHASING AND SALAS OF WE LOST THE
JOURNAL BE WHATEVER YOU WANT.
APPRECIATE BUT OF DISCUSSION OR
A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS SURROUNDING
RESOURCES --
AND FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WHICH WE APPRECIATE AND
I'M SURE MY FRIENDS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN
APPRECIATE THIS IDEA BUT THERE
IS A PART OF A REVENUE THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION.
A GROWING PART OF REVENUE AND
BACK WITH REDEVELOPMENT
ELIMINATION WAS FIRST PRESENTED
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
NOTED SIMPLY ELIMINATING
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES AND
RETURNING THE PROPERTY TAX ON A
SYSTEM THAT WAS DEVISED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
MEANING AB EIGHT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THE NEEDS OF MODERN
COMMUNITIES SO MOST OF MY
CLIENTS CITIES ARE GOING TO GET
SEVEN CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
AS WE START TO PAY OFF THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT BONDS --
AND AND SO THERE THERE IS A PART
OF REVENUE ALL NEW MONEY THAT
USED TO GO TO REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED FOR THIS COMPLICATED
ISSUE AND PROBABLY JUST
COMPLICATED IT.
EVEN MORE WITH WITH THE SLOTS
BUT JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
I COULD AFTERNOON CAN LOW'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS AND WHEN I
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING TODAY
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP AROUND YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND NOTE THAT YES WE DO HAVE 54%
OF THE NATION'S YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT DOESN'T EVEN
INCLUDE.
THOSE YOUTH WHO ARE PREGNANT AND
PARENTING THEMSELVES THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
YEAR.
I'M WANT TO SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR REQUESTS FOR A
SPECIFIC FUNDING POTTON STREAM
FOR YEARS SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING FOR YOU THAT THEY ARE
GONNA END UP BECOMING ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS POPULATION --
AND THAT ALSO THERE'S ALSO BEEN
SOME RECENT STUDIES FROM I'M A
DOCTOR THAT.
YOU SEE BERKELEY AROUND THAT THE
MORTALITY RATE FOR YOU ON THE
STREET IS ACTUALLY TEN TIMES
HIGHER THAN THEIR HOUSE PEERS SO
WE ARE REALLY TALKING ABOUT LIFE
AND DEATH FOR THESE.
LET'S POPULATION SPECIFICALLY
AND SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING THE
KIND OF POPULATION HAS GROWN
BECAUSE WE HAVE INVESTED SO
LITTLE AT THE STATE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS TO SERVE YOUTH AND
THEY ARE OUR FUTURE.
AND I KNOW I'VE TALKED TO SOME
SERVICE PROVIDERS ONLY TALK
ABOUT RAFTERY HOUSING FOR YEARS
IT'S ACTUALLY WRAPPING HOUSING
BECAUSE FOR A LOT OF THEM THEY
NEVER ACTUALLY HAD A HOUSE FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
WE'VE GOT TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
SUPPORT AND SERVICES THAT BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S WHY THE BEAUTY OF THAT
PROGRAM IS NEARING.
THE HOUSING ALONG WITH THE
SERVICES TO GO WITH IT SIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT.
HELLO I'M LISTEN I'M STUDENT
FROM YOU SEE MERCED AND WE WOULD
LIKE FORCE TO HOMELESSNESS TO BE
A PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATION
WE KNOW THAT ONE OUT OF EVERY
TWENTY STUDENT AT THE UC'S ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
SUPPORT FOR BASIC NEEDS
RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US YES SIR.
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS POSH
ON HIGH REPRESENT TO YOU SEE
SOON ASSOCIATION --
WHICH REPRESENTS HIS CROSS THE
UC AS WAS MENTIONED JUST NOW ONE
OUT OF EVERY TWENTY SECONDS AT
THE UC ARE HOMELES SIZE WE HAVE
IS CONVERSATIONS AROUND OUR
HOUSING ALMOST IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND.
THAT THE COURT GOING CRISES AT
THE US TWO LEVELS WALL AND I
ENTERED --
THE DUCATION INSTITUTIONS SO I'M
HERE TODAY.
ON THAT AND TO PROVIDE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST --
TWO IS RAPIDLY HOUSING PROGRAMS --
THAT WOULD GO TO BE ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS TO TO TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE SO AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
KATIE PATTERSON AND I'M WITH
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST OR ONE
OF THE ONLY NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT --
PROTECTS FARMLAND AND PROMOTES
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND FARMING
PRACTICES AND NO WORKS TO HELP
THE NEXT GENERATION OF FARMERS --
AS WE ARE FOLLOWING YOUR
COMMITTEE DISCUSSIONS AND AND
THE OVERALL HOUSING DISCUSSION --
IT IT'S REALLY APPARENT TO US
THAT THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S ON ADJACENT
FARMLANDS ARE PRIME FARM LANDS
IN CALIFORNIA.
OTHER WE JUST NEED TO BE --
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
AREA -- AND
LOOKING AT A PIECE THAT WE
PRODUCE SAVING FARMLAND GROWING
CITIESAND WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE SOME STRATEGIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
THAT CAN HELP US BE A VALUED
PARTNER A AS WE START TO LOOK AT
YOU KNOW HOW --
WE'D IN YOU KNOW ENCOURAGE SMART
GROWTH IN SMART DEVELOPMENT --
TO MEET SOME OF THESE CRITICAL
HOUSING --
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISSUES SO
PLEASE SEE US AS A PARTNER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
JEANNIE MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK I WANTED TO
ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE --
THIS IS BEEN IMPORTANT HEARING
ON THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
APPRECIATE THE HEARING MATERIALS
CALLING OUT THE PROBLEMS OF OF
LOW DENSITY HOUSING ALSO
EXACERBATING ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS AND PARTICULARLY THE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS --
WE KNOW THAT LOW DENSITY
SPRAWLED ABOUT ARM LANDS AND WE
HOPE THAT AS WE BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE CONSIDER CONTACT INFILL
DEVELOPMENT THAT ALSO BRINGS IN
HOW WE DO A BETTER JOB AT
FARMLAND PROTECTION SO THEY WERE
BUILDING DENSITY IS PROTECTING
OUR FOOD SHEDS AND ADDRESSING
THE CLIMATE CRISIS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS VERY INFORMATIVE --
HEARING IT'S WHO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
FROM ALL THESE DEPARTMENTS AND
FROM THE FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
PRIMARILY MY COMMENTS TO BE A
WERE AROUND THE BUDGET WE'RE
VERY ENCOURAGED TO SEE --
THE INVESTMENT AND HOMELESSNESS
IN THE BUDGET AND WE'RE REALLY
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR AND SEE IN
THE BUDGET HERE REALLY FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP --
THE PARENTS TO THE HOUSING FIRST
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE THE IN THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT A HOME IS A
SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS AND NOT --
JUST EMERGENCY SHELTER SO --
I KNOW US IN OUR MITCHELL AT
CHAMPION THAT --
THAT APPROACH BY THE STATE WERE
REALLY GLAD TO SEE THAT MOVE
FORWARD OVERALL I'M VERY PLEASED --
WITH -- THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL HOWEVER I JUST
CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE FACT
THAT -- 30%
OF THE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS --
TO ENHANCE HOUSING PRODUCTION --
AND SO --
THOSE DON'T NECESSARILY --
IT'S FOR UNDEFINED BENCHMARKS
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
ACHIEVE AND ALSO THERE --
THE FUNDS ARE TO BE USED FOR
GENERAL PURPOSES --
WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE --
THAT AUGMENTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE BENCHMARKS ARE THINGS THAT
REALLY ADVANCE HOUSING
PRODUCTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ALSO THAT THOSE FUNDS THAT
GO TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THOSE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS ARE TARGETED
TOWARDS ACTIVITIES.
THAT -- HELP
REDUCE THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS A
MAN NAMED LOUIS MANTE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN BE --
WANT TO GENERALLY ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AND JUST EXPRESS SUPPORT --
FOR EACH ITEM THAT LA --
LISTS IN THEIR IN THEIR
RECOMMEND IN THIS HIGHLIGHT MISS
MORALES IS COMMENTS ABOUT HOW
THE RATE OF POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA.
A IS MUCH HIGHER THAN IT
OTHERWISE WOULD BE AS A FUNCTION
OF THE COST OF HOUSING HERE --
WANTED TO JUST --
ECHO THE MAYOR STOCKTON IS WELL
IN HIS COMMENTS ABOUT THE AN
INHERENT MORAL DIGNITY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
HELP HERE IS AS ADVOCATES AND
POLICYMAKERS.
AND ABOUT HOW THAT DIGNITY
OBLIGES US TO HAVE WHAT CAN BE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CONTENTIOUS POLICY IDEAS AND AND
AND DIFFERENT WAYS OF OF
REFRAMING STATE LAW AND AND
LOCAL LAW --
IN GENERAL WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT OF
YOUR VERY BUSY DAYS TO FOCUS ON
THIS ISSUE AS MUCH AS YOU HAVE
TODAY.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR PROPOSALS IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIAN UC PEANUTS REAL
POLICY AS WELL AS A LAMB
COALITION REPRESENTING
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE --
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP A
DISABILITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S WITH AIDID
THE SUPPORTED BY REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES AND WHICH WE HAD HEARD
MORE ABOUT THE ID COMMUNITY
AMONG SISTERS QUESTIONS A VERY
ROBUST DISCUSSION HOWEVER.
THE VAST MAJORITY RELIES ON SSI
ALONE ARE IN NEED OF EXTREMELY
LOW --
AFFORDABLE HOW EXTREMELY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PERRANCE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE'VE SEEN --
20% MORE LIVING AT HOME AS
OPPOSED IN THE COMMUNITY WITH
AGING CARE GIVERS.
AND WANT TO MENTION TWO POINTS
ABOUT THIS ONE TO QUOTE THE
DIRECTOR FINANCE THAT --
IDENTIFYING ONGOING POTS OF
MONEY IS VERY DIFFICULT TO DO OF
THE LAMB COALITION HAS DONE SO
IN HIS BROUGHT THAT. TO THE
ATTENTION THE LEGISLATURE --
ONE WOULD BE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY SAVE BY THE
CLOSURE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS --
WHICH WAS IDENTIFIED BY A REPORT
LAST YEAR FROM ALEJO THAT ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING SAVINGS
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF ALMOST
CENTER IS CLOSED.
AND THAT SAVINGS USED TO BE
SPENT ON BIG LARGE INSTITUTIONAL
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE THAT HE CAN
BE SPENT ON SMALL INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY HOUSING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SHOULD BE.
SECOND PART OF FUNDING IS THE
PROPERTIES THEMSELVES AND THE
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS --
REVENUE FROM THOSE PROPERTIES
THEMSELVES --
IS COULD SHOULD IN COULD GO --
TO NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SECOND JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COME TO SENATOR LEYVA THAT WAGES
ARE IMPORTANT DISCUSSION OF THIS
AS WELL.
AND NOT JUST CORPORATE WAGES
HOWEVER WE ALL --
DICTATED BY STATE RATES FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR PEOPLE ID
DE A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOES
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS.
ALMOST ENTIRELY ON MINIMUM WAGE
WAGES BECAUSE OF LOWER ITS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOU --
HELPING TO CLOSE OUR PUBLIC.
COMMENT --
RAISING THEM A CRITICAL ISSUE TO
THIS OVERALL CONVERSATION --
I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES --
FEEL AS I DO ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
TODAY'S HEARING WAS WE GOT A LOT
OF INFORMATION --
THAT WE WILL ALL HAVE TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THIS IS OUR
LAST FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING --
UNTIL PERHAPS AFTER THE RELEASE
OF THE MAY REVISE WE MAY HAVE
ONE MORE --
BUT YOU ALL WILL GO FORTH AND
START YOUR VERY IMPORTANT WORK
IN THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS STARTING --
IN TWO WEEKS THINK TWO WEEKS
FROM TODAY --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMIT AND WE STAND ADJOURNED